ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY TODAY'S
TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WE DO NOT
YET HAVE.
ENOUGH MEMBERS FOR QUORUM BUT
ENOUGH TO START IS A SUB
COMMITTEE SO WE WILL DO THAT.
WE HAVE SENATOR WIENER.
IS WITH US TODAY SCHEDULING THIS
HEARING AND FOR WORKING WITH US
IN THE BILL APPRECIATE IT.
OUR S. B. NINE NINE THE WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT TRANSGENDER
INDIVIDUALS ARE WHO ARE IN
CUSTODY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
OR IMPRISONED WITHIN A COUNTY
JAIL.
WILL HAVE THE RIGHT TO AFFIRM
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY THEIR
PREFERRED FIRST NAME GENDER
PRONOUN AN HONORIFIC ON REQUIRE
THAT THOSE BE USED BY THE
FACILITIES STAFF.
S. B. NINE NINETY ALSO FURTHER
REQUIRE OR FURTHER REQUIRES AYE
THAT INCARCERATED I INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE PLACED.
OFFER MORE THAN FIVE DAYS AND A
SETTING OTHER THAN GENERAL
POPULATION HOUSING SUCH OF
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
OUGHT TO DO TO THE PERSON ARE
BEING AT RISK OF ASSAULTS OR
SEXUAL VICTIMIZATION.
I WILL REQUIRE THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
PROGRAMMING AND WORK
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PROVIDED TO
INDIVIDUALS.
AUDITOR HOUSED WITHIN THE
GENERAL POPULATION.
STOCK TODAY I'VE THERE ARE AYE --
VERY FREQUENTLY AYE TRANSGENDER
INMATES ARE PARTICULARLY TRANS
WOMEN ARE PLACED INTO SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT --
QUOTE UNQUOTE FOR THEIR OWN
PROTECTION NOT BECAUSE THEY'VE
DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
UP BECAUSE THEY ARE AT RISK OF
VICTIMIZATION THIS IS BECAUSE OF
A BROADER ISSUE WHICH WE'RE
WORKING ON FOR THE FUTURE.
ARE RELATING --
TO INAPPROPRIATE HOUSING OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
TRANS WOMEN WHO ARE.
ARE CLASSIFIED AS MEN HEALTH
WITH MEN AND FOR OUR NOT HAVING
DONE ANYTHING WRONG GET PUT INTO
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT OF FOR
THEIR OWN PROTECTION.
NOT A LOSE ACCESS TO SERVICES
ARE A UNDERMINES THE
REHABILITATION PROCESS AYE AND
WE NEED TO CHANGE US.
ALRIGHT SO THIS BILL I WILL
REQUIRE THAT IF THERE ARE PLACED
IN SOLITARY FOR FIVE MORE DAYS
NOT DUE TO THEIR OWN.
ON MISCONDUCT ARE THEY HAVE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO SERVICES ODD SO
IT'S BENIGN NINETY IS --
I THINK A PRETTY AYE BASIC AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD A CIVIL RIGHTS
OF A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
TRANSGENDER ALL LGBT BY
PARTICULAR TRANSGENDER INMATES
OF WILL BE TREATED WITH RESPECT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I KNOW YOU'RE
WITNESSES HUNG UP BETTER THAN
ANY OTHER WITNESSES WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM.
I'D SAY NOT AS THEIR OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SAYING NONE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS FROM.
THAT COMMITTEES AND I WILL NOTE
THAT.
SO EVER JUST GET REALLY STARTING
US FOR OUR HEARING TODAY.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
QUESTIONS FROM THE DIE --
SEEING NONE.
SENATE YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I HOPE ON THE HEARINGS CAN
BE LIKE THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES THANKS SO MUCH WE WILL TAKE
UP ONLY HAVE OR OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU.
AS WE COLLECT MEMBERS HOPE WE
WILL GET SOME MORE AUTHORS
[inaudible]
IN.
I WILL NOTE THAT.
I WILL KNOW THAT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS BEING PROPOSED TO BE
REMOVED MOVED.
I'M SORRY I NUMBER SIX IS BEING
MOVED TO THE CONSENT AGENDA.
ABSENT AN OBJECTION.
WE WILL TAKE THAT UP THAT IS
PART OF THE CONSENT AGENDA
.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR.
SENATE GLAZER YOU READY TO
PRESENT [inaudible]
LOVELY WHEREBY [inaudible]
HOW WILL?
DAYS.
IN EIGHT OR AM I SO THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE S. B..
THIRTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN READY TO GO BRED
TO GO I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
THIS BILL REGARDING IMMUNITY FOR
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
AND HELPING ANIMALS THE IN --
IN DIFFICULT SITUATIONS.
YOU BE SURPRISED IF YOU'RE THIS
BUT ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND PETS
DIE IN HOUSE FIRES EVERY YEAR IN
THE UNITED STATES.
FORTY THOUSAND AT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA FIRST
RESPONDERS TO PROVIDE FOR STATE
ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS. TO OUR
BELOVED PETS AT THE SCENE OF AN
EMERGENCY PRIOR TO TRANSFERRING
THAT ANIMAL TO A VETERINARY CARE
FACILITY.
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL PROTECTS
FIRST RESPONDERS BY MAKING IT
EXPLICIT.
THEY'RE NOT LIABLE FOR CIVIL
DAMAGES.
OR SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION OR PROFESSIONAL
DISCIPLINARY ACTION FOR
ADMINISTERING BASIC FIRST AID.
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT ALL
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AYE WHICH LIMIT THE BILL'S
PROTECTION FROM CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION TO ONLY THE
MISDEMEANORS ARTICULATED IN THE
VETERINARY MEDICINE PRACTICE ACT.
AND EXPAND CIVIL IMMUNITY TO
INCLUDE NOT ONLY EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL BUT ALSO.
A ORDINARY CITIZENS WHO
WITNESSED A PADDED KNEES.
THE EXPANSION OF CIVIL IMMUNITY
MAKES EXISTING LANGUAGE EXPLICIT
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA GOOD
SAMARITAN LA --
TODAY I'M JOINED BY JUAN RIVERA.
I WOULD DILLON POLICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICER WHOSE CANINE COMPANION
WAS INJURED IN THE LINE OF DUTY
THANK YOU FOR BEING HER ONE
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MATSUMURA BECAME AN
OFFICER FOR THE CITY OF WOODLAND.
WHEN A POLICE OFFICER FOR TWELVE
YEARS AND I CANNOT HANNAH
PREMIERES ON --
MAY. TWENTY SIXTEEN MY PARTNER
WAS -- PIECE
OF YOUR PRETTY SEVERE INJURIES
HAD A BROKEN BACK REFERENCE NOW
PUNCTURED A LUNG AND HE WAS
BLEEDING PROFUSELY.
I AM OUR PERSONNEL WHICH IS ONE
OF THE AMBULANCES THAT WE
CONTRACT WITH ARRIVED ON SCENE
AND WEBER TO GET HIM ON A
STRETCHER.
GIVEN STABILIZING ACTUALLY
PROVIDE OXYGEN TO HIM WITH AN
ACTUAL OXYGEN MASK FOR DOGS.
WE GET IN THE AMBULANCE THE
TRANSPORTING TO UC DAVIS MEDICAL
CENTER WHERE --
THEY TOOK OVER AND PERFORMED
EMERGENCY SURGERY ON A AFTER THE
SURGERY TALK TO THE DOCTORS AND
SURGEONS AND THEY SAID IF IT
WASN'T FOR A AND MARK THEY GOT
HIM ON A GURNEY AND STABLE
WHAT'S.
HE WANT TO SURVIVE.
ANY SURVIVORS ENTRIES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY HE DATA.
THAT'S RETIREMENT OF THE
INJURIES HE SUSTAINED.
SO IT WASN'T IF IT WASN'T FOR
THEM YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
RETIRE AND ONE FOUR FIVE WITH
OUR MR MEMBERS MIKE DILLON
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
TING NOTHING ABOUT COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISMANAGEMENT.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL --
HAPPY TO MOVE THAT ONCE WE GET A
A QUORUM.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE CENTER YOU MAKE LOVE
WELL I DON'T SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN HERE BUT I KNOW IS ST
BERNARD'S NAME JACKSON SO AND IN
HONOR OF JACKSON.
LIKE JAZZ FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU.
I A BIT OF SECRETS BUT THAT'S
GONNA [inaudible]
ARE.
THANK YOU BOTH WILL TAKE IT UP
WE GOT A CORE ALRIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH VEGAS AT YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING
.
SENATOR CATCH YOUR BREATH MEANS
EVERYTHING.
TIMING IS EVERYTHING.
SO YOU HAVE A COUPLE BILLS WITH
US TODAY HAVE A PREFERENCE A
EIGHT NINETEEN NIGHT THAT'S SO
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB.
EIGHT NINETEEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HINDER COLLEAGUES I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE AND FOR HIGHLIGHTING.
A CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
TWELVE OF THE ANALYSIS THAT
WE'RE ACCEPTING TODAY.
S. B. EIGHT NINETEEN INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S RATE PAYERS DON'T
PAY FOR UTILITIES NEGLIGENT
BEHAVIOR.
THIS BILL ACHIEVES THIS SIMPLY
BY CODIFYING EXISTING P. UC
PRACTICE MANDATING THAT FINES
PENALTIES ARE EXPENSES RESULTING
FROM UNREASONABLE BEHAVIOR ARE
NOT RECOVERABLE IN RATES.
WHO PAYS FOR DAMAGES SHOULD BE
BASED ON A UTILITIES CONDUCT?
THE P. UC DETERMINES UTILITIES
ACTED REALLY REASONABLY
RATEPAYERS WILL COVER THE COST.
BUT IF THE P. UC DETERMINES
UTILITY ACTED UNREASONABLY OR
IMPRUDENTLY RATEPAYERS SHOULD
NOT PAY.
THIS IS A CENTRAL AND
FUNDAMENTAL PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S RATE PAYERS SB
EIGHT NINETEEN ALSO ENSURES THAT
FOR APPLICATIONS WHERE A UTILITY
WAS REASONABLE IN PART.
THEN THE PEW SEE MAY AUTHORIZE
RECOVERY FOR THAT PART.
THIS IS BEEN TRUE FOR OTHER COST
APPLICATIONS IN THE PAST WHERE
THE P. UC ALLOWED SOME EXPENSES
PUT DISALLOWED OTHERS.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THE P. UC'S
AUTHORITY TO APPROACH A PORTION
COSTS UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
ALLOCATE NINETEEN IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RATE PAYER
PROTECTION MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU TENER.
ANYONE THIS IS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT.
IT'S A KNOWN AS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS [inaudible]
THE THREATS THE COMET SOMETHING
THAT YOU SAID.
CENTRAL AND FUNDAMENTAL
PROTECTION FOR RATEPAYERS I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE AND I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT THIS FORWARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SAID REMEMBERING.
OKAY YEAH TYPE PATIENT SPACES
OTHER QUESTIONS COME.
ALRIGHT SING NONE SENATOR YOU
MAKE LOVE RESPECT WE HAVE TRIBAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SP --
THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WILL REQUIRE HIGH
OCCUPANCY BUILDINGS THAT UNDERGO
RENOVATIONS TO BE EQUIPPED WITH
AN A E. D..
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST KILLS
NEARLY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE PER
DAY IN THE UNITED STATES INTENDS
THE LIVES OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ANNUALLY.
IT CAN HAPPEN TO ANYONE ANYTIME
ANYWHERE AND AT ANY AGE.
THE SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION DURING SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST IS THE USE OF AN
AUTOMATED.
EXTERNAL DEFIBRILLATOR IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE TOOK
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND HELP SAVE LIVES.
SB THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN BILLS
OFF THE SUCCESS OF EXISTING A E.
D. LAWS AND EXTENDS A E. D.
INSTALLATION REQUIREMENTS.
APPLICABLE TO NEW DEVELOPMENT TO
LARGE OCCUPANCY BUILDINGS AT
UNDERGO SUBSTANTIAL RENOVATIONS.
AND MINUTES WERE MADE IN SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND A NOW SUPPORT
THE BILL INSTALLING MORE AEDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
MEANS THAT MORE LIVES WILL
LIKELY BE SAVED FROM THOSE
SUFFERING SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST
THANK YOU MEMBERS APPRECIATED
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RELY BUT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE IS IN SUPPORT.
MADISON Y. ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS IN SUPPORT.
BOB MICHEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IT'S A KNOWN AS THEIR OPPOSITION.
THING NONE OF BRING ABOUT
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE SANITY MEZCLA
RESPECT WE HAVE TRAVELED AT THE
PROPER TIME WE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS APPRECIATED IT VERY MUCH.
BUT THIS IS TURNING OUT TO BE MY
FAVORITE COMMITTEE AT LIKE HNGN
[inaudible]
THANK
SENATOR GALGIANI.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR YOU.
SO WE WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER.
NINE S. B..
TWELVE FORTY NINE WELCOME SP
[inaudible]
TWELVE FORTY NINE YES.
THANK YOU MET MISTER CHAIR I
MEMBERS SP TWELVE FORTY NINE
PROHIBITS THE SALE OR
PROMOTIONAL GIVEAWAY OF ANY
COSMETIC PRODUCT IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAS BEEN TESTED.
ON ANIMALS AFTER JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY WITH LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS THAT I WILL OUTLINE
SHORTLY.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG HISTORY OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS
OF PROHIBITING ANIMAL TESTING
FOR COSMETIC PRODUCTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOR EXAMPLE
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST STATE
TO BAN THE PRACTICE OF USING
ANIMALS FOR TESTING COSMETICS.
HOWEVER THE LOS STAYED SILENT
ABOUT THEIR IMPORTATION AND SALE.
JUST FOUR YEARS AGO THE SENATE
UNANIMOUSLY AND THE ASSEMBLY
PASSED SJR TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
BLOCK URGING CONGRESS TO PASS
THE HUMANE COSMETICS ACT THAT
WOULD PROHIBIT THE SALE OF
COSMETICS.
TESTED ON ANIMALS NATIONWIDE
PARALLEL TO S. B. TWELVE FORTY
NINE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
SJR TWENTY TWO WE SEE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WITH SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE VOTING IN FAVOR
OF IT.
EVEN WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
COSMETIC COMPANIES IN SUPPORT OF
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION CONGRESS
HAS NOT ACTED.
SO TODAY I'M ASKING THIS
COMMITTEE TO DO WHAT WE HAVE
NORMALLY DONE WHEN CONGRESS DOES
NOT ACT AND THAT IS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MOVE FORWARD AND
LEAD.
WHILE IT MAY SEEM THAT
CALIFORNIA IS ON THE LEADING
EDGE IN FACT WE'RE ACTUALLY
FOLLOWING THE LEAD OF THIRTY
FIVE OTHER COUNTRIES THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD.
THAT HAVE ALREADY BANNED THE
SALE OF COSMETIC PRODUCTS TESTED
ON ANIMALS.
COUNTRIES AS DIVERSE AS BULGARIA
INDIA ISRAEL THE EUROPEAN UNION
AND EVEN THE TINY ISLAND OF
MALTA ALL BANNED THE SALE OF
COSMETICS TESTED ON ANIMALS.
SP TWELVE FORTY NINE SIMPLY
BRINGS CALIFORNIA'S HUMANE
STANDARDS AND LINE WITH THE
WORLD'S HIGHEST.
MY OFFICE HAS WORKED WITH
CERTAIN COSMETIC INDUSTRY
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE TAKEN
MANY SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS AND
WE'VE ALSO WORKED WITH THE MANY
MANY COMPANIES WHO SELL CRUELTY
FREE COSMETICS AND THE STATE.
AND COUNTRY AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
S. B. TWELVE FORTY NINE ALLOWS
TWO EXCEPTIONS TO THE BAN WERE
ANIMAL TESTED COSMETICS WOULD
STILL BE ALLOWED.
ANY THIRD EXEMPTION IS BEING
PROPOSED I MEAN ALICE'S.
THE FIRST EXEMPTION IS IN THE
EVENT THAT THE FEDERAL DRUG
ADMINISTRATION OR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL REQUIRES TESTING AND
THERE'S NO ALTERNATIVE AVAILABLE.
THE SECOND EXEMPTION ALLOWS
ANIMAL TESTING TO COMPLY WITH A
FORMAL REQUEST OF A FOREIGN
REGULATORY AUTHORITY.
THIS EXEMPTION WILL SUNSET AS OF
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS CAN
WITH GREAT CONFIDENCE KNOW THAT
THE COSMETIC PRODUCTS THAT THEY
PURCHASE ARE NO LONGER PRODUCED.
THROUGH UNNECESSARY PAINFUL AND
VERY AWFUL AND FULLY AVOIDABLE
ANIMAL TESTS THE THIRD EXEMPTION
ADDRESSES CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT
ANIMAL TESTING CONDUCTED FOR A
NON COSMETIC PURPOSE.
SUCH TESTING WHAT HAVE TO BE
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL STATE OR
FOREIGN REGULATORY AUTHORITY.
THE COSMETIC COMPONENT HAD.
ACTUALLY BE ANNA COSMETIC FOR AT
LEAST ONE YEAR AND THE TESTING
WAS NOT CONDUCTED BY ANYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE COSMETIC
MANUFACTURERS.
THIS WILL HELP PREVENT
SITUATIONS WHERE CHEMICALS ARE
ONE DAY TESTED FOR NON COSMETIC
PURPOSES FOR ANY REASON AND THEN
THE VERY NEXT DAY THAT SAME
CHEMICAL JUST SO HAPPENS TO NOW
BE CONSIDERED.
A COSMETIC COMPONENT.
LET'S NOT FORGET SP TWELVE FORTY
NINE GRANDFATHER'S END THOUSANDS
OF CURRENT COSMETIC INGREDIENTS
MANY TESTED ON ANIMALS UP UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY OUR
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE BILL'S
SPONSOR.
THANK YOU AND THERE ARE SOME.
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE PRESENTED IN
A MOCK UP JUST A CLEAR YOU'RE
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS GREAT
THANK THE WORLD ON THE SAME PAGE.
RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR --
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GO AHEAD HILLARY AND GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS HILARY PICKLES AND I AM HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING A LUSH
COSMETICS INCORPORATED ARE
UNITED STATES RETAIL BUSINESS.
UNLESS HANDMADE COSMETICS
LIMITED OUR CANADIAN RETAIL AND
MANUFACTURING BUSINESSES AND
LUSCIOUS HAPPY TO SUPPORT SP.
TWELVE FORTY NINE MANUFACTURING
AND SELLING CRUELTY FREE
COSMETICS AND TRANSPARENCY INTO
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN HAVE BEEN CORE
VALUES SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
LUSH IN NORTH AMERICA MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
AND THOSE VALUES HAVE ALLOWED US
TO GROW OUR BUSINESS
EXPONENTIALLY OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES WE NOW HAVE MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED STORES IN NORTH
AMERICA FORTY OF WHICH ARE DOING
GREAT BUSINESS YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND FIFTY THAT ARE LOCATED IN
CANADA.
LAST YEAR WE SAW MORE THAN FIFTY
MILLION PEOPLE COME INTO OUR
NORTH AMERICANSHOPS OVER THIRTY
FOUR MILLION UNIQUE VISITORS TO
OUR WEBSITE AND OVER SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION.
FOLLOWERS ACROSS OUR SEVEN
SOCIAL MEET SO WITH THIS GROWING
TREND ON THE CONSUMER MARKET AND
THE DEMAND BY THE CONSUMERS FOR
CRUELTY FREE COSMETICS.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
CREATING CRUELTY FREE PRODUCTS
HAS CONTRIBUTED GREATLY TO OUR
GROWTH AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE ARE NOT ALONE THERE ARE
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED COSMETICS
BRANDS IN NORTH AMERICA THAT ARE
CERTIFIED AS CRUELTY FREE.
AT LUNCH WE WROTE OUR COMPANY
NON ANIMAL TESTING POLICY TO
EXCLUDE SUPPLIERS NOT JUST
TESTING ON ANIMALS FOR COSMETIC
PURPOSES BUT TESTING FOR ANY
PURPOSE.
OUR POLICY ALSO EXCLUDES THE
TESTING OF ANIMALS CARRIED OUT
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD JUST TO
ELIMINATE THE THE DANGER OF
OFFSHORE TESTING.
THE THING IS WE DON'T WANT TO BE
ON THE WRONG SIDE OF HISTORY
HERE.
WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES DO WE
WANT TO BE A SOCIETY WHO DECIDES
TO HARM ANIMALS FOR THE
POTENTIAL USE OF AN INGREDIENT
IN A COSMETIC.
OR DO WE WANT TO BE KNOWN FOR
INVESTING IN ALTERNATES.
AND WORKING WITH REGULATORS AND
NOT BEING HUMANS WHO HARM NON
HUMAN ANIMALS FOR THE STATE OF
COSMETICS.
LAST WEEK IN CANADA A HUGE TRADE
PARTNER FOR THE U. S. THE
FEDERAL BILL AS TO FOURTEEN
WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT DOMESTIC
ANIMAL TESTING FOR COSMETICS AS
WELL AS THE SALE OF COSMETICS
THAT HAVE UNDERGONE ANY FORM OF
NEW TESTING.
JUST UNANIMOUSLY PASSED THE
SENATE.
IN CLOSING THE NEARLY FORTY
COUNTRIES WHO HAVE BANNED
TESTING ON ANIMALS FOR COSMETIC
PURPOSES.
ARE MAKING THE RIGHT DECISION
AND THE PUBLIC IN ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE LASH CAN APPLY PRESSURE BUT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT GOVERNMENT
PROVIDE THE PACE.
IT IT'S TIME TO AYE CALIFORNIA
TO THAT LIST AND PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA CRUELTY FREE
COSMETICS ACT THINK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JUDY MAN
CREW CELL AND I AM THE FOUNDER
AND PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION
SPONSOR COSPONSORED THE BILL.
I'D LIKE TO START BY TELLING YOU
WHAT YOUR YES VOTE MEANS TODAY.
OVER A HALF A MILLION ANIMALS
WILL NO LONGER BE TORTURED FOR
TESTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN TO BE
UNNECESSARY TO SHOW SAFETY.
YOU WILL SAVE THESE ANIMALS FROM
BEING TORTURED WHILE THEY ARE
ALIVE AND THEN THROWN INTO THE
TRASH LEFT TO SUFFOCATE WILD
WRITHING IN PAIN BECAUSE
CORPORATIONS DECIDED THAT THE
COST AND TIME TO EUTHANIZE THEM.
WOULD NEGATIVELY AFFECT THEIR
BOTTOM LINE WE WILL JOIN THE
EUROPEAN UNION AND DOZENS OF
OTHER COUNTRIES AND SUPPORTING
THE OVER THREE THOUSAND
COMPANIES GLOBALLY FROM SMALL
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES TO GLOBAL
LEAVE IT LEADERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY GONE CRUELTY FREE.
WE DIDN'T DELIVER THIS PACKAGE
TO ALL OF YOU OF THESE THREE
THOUSAND COMPANIES AND THEY ARE
FROM LIKE I SAID VERY SMALL
COMPANIES T. HUGE.
INCLUDING JOHN PAUL MITCHELL
SYSTEMS A CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANY WITH SALES OF OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR WHO
SUPPORTS S. B..
TWELVE FORTY NINE JOHN PAUL
MITCHELL SYSTEMS HAS BEEN
CRUELTY FREE FROM THEIR
INCEPTION OVER THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS AGO.
I ALSO MIGHT MENTION THAT THEY
SELL THEIR PRODUCTS IN CHINA AND
NEGOTIATE WITH THE CHINESE
REGULATORS TO CONTINUE TO BE
CRUELTY FREE BY USING
ALTERNATIVE TESTING.
WHEN YOU VOTE YES ON SB TWELVE
FORTY NINE YOU WILL BE
RESPONDING TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS
INCLUDING THE MILLENNIALS WHO
DEMAND CRUELTY FREE AND ARE THE
FUTURE OF OUR CALIFORNIA NOW THE
LARGEST FIFTH?
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD BY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL YOUR
ALLOWING US TO MAKE ANIMAL
TESTING A THING OF THE PAST
WHERE IT BELONGS.
LET SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY LEAD
AS IT HAS DONE IN SO MANY OTHER
AREAS CALIFORNIA WILL ONCE AGAIN
MAKE HISTORY.
ALLOWING US TO BE MORE HUMANE
REPLACING PAIN AND CRUELTY WITH
COMPASSION.
WE LOOK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
AND WE THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON I'M GONNA
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
STONE HERE CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU CHIU HOLDEN KALRA
[inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN HERE [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOU TO COME FORWARD GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
I MY NAME IS TWEET CONRAD I'M A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN AND I OWN
SPIRE GANNETT CO DAY SPA BUSY
DAY SPA IN THE BAY AREA ISSUES
BECAUSE WE HAVE IT QUIET IN HERE
THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT IF WE
ARE EVEN THE LEAST UNCERTAIN
WHETHER MANUFACTURED CHEMICAL
INGREDIENT IN A BECAUSE MEDICAL
BECAUSE THE SECOND DEGREE BURN
BLINDNESS OR EVEN DEATH.
WE SHOULD NOT BE PUTTING UP
PRODUCT ON OUR SKIN.
IT DOES NOT BELONG IN A COSMETIC
PRODUCT.
CRYSTALLINE I ABOUT NOT ADVOCATE
WE'RE NOT FEEL TAKE MORE
TESTIMONY SO IF YOU JUST GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
PLEASE BECAUSE SOMEONE ON BEHALF
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES AND OUR MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THAT.
ELIZABETH BAKER ON BEHALF OF
PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE TWO WE
REPRESENT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ODD PEOPLE NATIONWIDE SUPPORTING
EFFECTIVE AND ETHICAL PRODUCT
TESTING THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PATTY SCHENKER FROM
LOS ANGELES LET'S MAKE
CALIFORNIA EVEN MORE BEAUTIFUL
THANK YOU.
SOME ANDREAS LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA LET'S GO CRUELTY FREE
THANK YOU.
PIPER CROSS OWN BEHALF OF THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES AND A SENIOR DISTRICT
LEADER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
LISA CARLIN.
JANE UNCHAINED NEWS NETWORK
PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE AND SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
THE SPELL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ON THE TO STAND ON
THE COMMODE DEFENSE ATTORNEY IN
ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS EVERYONE
CAN IDENTIFY WITH PAIN AND
SUFFERING AND I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
I NEVER CLASS AND NEVADA
CALIFORNIA ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
AND MY RISKY LAB BUNNY WHO MADE
IT OUT ALIVE THINK YOU.
JANET MCCARTHY HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES VOLUNTARY
DISTRICT LEADER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JENNIFER KENNEDY AND MARK HERE
SUPPORTING OF THIS BILL WITH THE
HUMAN SIDE OF UNTED STATES VERY
PROUD CALIFORNIA LET'S GIVE US
HUMANE.
MAKE IT WRONG O. ELDORADO COUNTY.
JUST LOOK FOR PLEASE TAKE IT.
NO BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
WITNESSES NOTHING I MONICA ANGER
IT'S A NORTH AMERICAN CAMPAIGN
MANAGER FOR CRUELTY FREE
INTERNATIONAL IN SUPPORT.
AARON HOW THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES ON DISTRICT
LEADER DISTRICTS SIX VOLUNTEER
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GALA NASAL ARE FIRST STRONG
SUPPORT FROM A VOLUNTEER AT THE
BRACCIO SHELTER.
HI KRISTIN BAUER VAN STRATEN I'M
AN ACTRESS FROM LOS ANGELES I'M
HERE WITH PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE
FOR RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE AND
HUMANS AND ANIMALS PINKY.
BECAUSE UNDER SO STRONG FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND IT'S REALLY
TIME FOR THE WORLD'S HERBAL.
DENISE BAUBLE SAN MATEO COUNTY
BAY AREA THIS IS PROGRESS LET'S
DO IT.
CHRISTY VALLEY FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA I ASK YOU PLEASE VOTE
YES.
CHRISTY VANOC MARTIN FROM
ALBERTA CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
THIS BILL PLEASE VOTE YES FOR
THE ANIMALS.
BETSY WASSON I CAME FROM
WASHINGTON DC BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT JUST A CALIFORNIA ISSUE
IT'LL AFFECT THE ENTIRE UNITED
STATES PLEASE VOTE YES.
LESLIE DAVIES SAN DIEGO.
PLEASE VOTE YES I'M FROM SNAPS
BANG INTERACTION PROJECT.
RIGHT BETSY CHEN HARD FOR A PET
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION MAKING ME.
ARE THE HUMANE PRESENCE IN FIVE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
VOTE YES THINKING.
HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE MALINKE I'M
A RESIDENT OF PLASTER COUNTY I'M
ALSO A VOLUNTEER WITH THE ANIMAL
PLACING GRASS VALLEY CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE LARGEST FARMED ANIMAL
SANCTUARIES IN THE COUNTRY.
WE TAKE IN AND RESCUE ANIMALS
WHO HAVE BEEN TORTURED IN
LABORATORIES PLEASE VOTE YES.
BARBARA CONE FAIR OAKS ON HAVE
BEEN ANIMAL RESCUE REFER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MARY KATE STEWART FROM LAGUNA
BEACH CALIFORNIA AND NOBODY
WANTS TO PUT ANIMAL TORTURE ON
THEIR FACE.
SHELLY LIN FROM NEWPORT BEACH
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
ALSO WITH MANY RESCUES WE PLEASE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL THINK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CALEY BROOKS AND I
SUPPORT SP TWELVE FORTY NINE AND
I'M FROM NEWPORT BEACH
CALIFORNIA.
HI MY NAME IS LINDA MIDDLE
SOURCE WE HAVE FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN THE SACRAMENTO VEGAN
SOCIETY AND WILL SUPPORT THIS
BILL STOP THE CRUELTY PLEASE.
HELLO BETHANY DAVIS CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIALED TEACHER AN ADVOCATE
FOR HUMANE EDUCATION PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THINKING.
HI GLORIA BUTLER FROM LOS
ANGELES I'M HERE WITH SOCIAL
COMPASSION AND LEGISLATION.
AND AMONG THE HUMANE SOCIETY
NATIONAL COUNCIL ENERGY JUST TO
VOTE YES PLEASE THANK YOU.
I PACK OF YELLOW REPRESENTING
HUMANITY THROUGH EDUCATION A
CEMETERY COUNTY AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THING.
MY NAME IS JULIE ANA CUMMINGS
FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA --
I'M A STUDENT MIGHT VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL.
MITCHELL CREMEANS FROM ELK GROVE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M REPRESENTING
SACRAMENTO AREA VEGANS PLEASE
GAS.
KAREN GAYLE FROM SACRAMENTO LOVE
IS THE ANSWER PLEASE VOTE YES.
KATIE CLEARY PRESIDENT OF PEACE
RAMBLES ON WORLD ANIMAL NEWS AND
BOARD MEMBER OF SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION PLEASE
GO CRUELTY FREE.
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL JOURNALIST
AND AUTHOR FROM MARINA DEL REY
LET'S INVOLVED IT'S THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY THANK YOU.
IF YOU ANYONE ELSE SINCE PORT.
THE NUNS ARE OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SETH CHO CON ALL.
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH COVINGTON
AND BURLING IN WASHINGTON DC
IMPARTED TRAINING COVINGTON I
WORKED A FEW HASSOUN DRUG
ADMINISTRATION AS ASSISTANT
CHIEF COUNSEL THERE.
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
S. B..
TWELVE FORTY NINE IN CALIFORNIA
THE PERSONAL CARE INDUSTRY
EMPLOYS FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
AND CONTRIBUTES TWENTY I'M GOING
TO THE STATE'S GDP AND SEVEN
POINT TWO BILLION IN TAX REVENUE
ANNUALLY.
THIS BILL WOULD DRAMATICALLY
IMPACT THIS CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY.
AT THE OUTSET.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS INDUSTRIES BEEN
THE LEADER IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ANIMAL TESTING ALTERNATIVES FOR
DECADES.
NEARLY FORTY YEARS AGO INDUSTRY
FUNDED THE JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY CENTER FOR
ALTERNATIVES TO ANIMAL TESTING.
OR VALUABLE RESEARCH ON ANIMAL
TESTING ALTERNATIVES CONTINUES
TODAY.
THAT COMMITMENT ALSO EXTENDS
GLOBALLY INCLUDING WHERE IN
CHINA.
THE COUNCIL REGULARLY ENGAGE
WITH CHINESE REGULATORS
SCIENTISTS AND TRADE OFFICIALS
THE ADVOCATE FOR THE USE
ALTERNATIVES TO ANIMAL TESTING.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SEVERAL YEARS
AGO THE COUNCIL AS PART OF A
DIVERSE COALITION OF HEALTH
ANIMAL RIGHTS AND INDUSTRY
GROUPS.
CAME TOGETHER SUPPORT STATE
LEGISLATION THAT REQUIRES
INDUSTRIES NON ANIMAL TESTING
METHODS AND SUCH METHODS EXCESS.
WE'VE THREE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL AS DRAFTED.
FIRST ALL THE CURRENT DRAFT
INCLUDES AN EXEMPTION FOR ANIMAL
TESTING REQUIRED BY FOREIGN
REGULATORY AUTHORITIES.
THAT EXEMPTION WOULD SUNSET
THREE YEARS AFTER THE BILL'S
ENACTMENT.
THERE CURRENTLY ARE EXISTING
EXISTING FOREIGN TESTING
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE AND THE
SUNSET WOULD ONLY PROVIDE A
BRIEF.
AND QUITE FRANKLY AN UNREALISTIC
PERIOD OF TIME CHANGING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE PRODUCT
CATEGORY.
SECOND THE DRAFT INCLUDES AN
EXEMPTION FOR TESTING REQUIRED
BY FD A OR D. TSC.
BUT NO OTHER FEDERAL OR STATE
REGULATORY BODY AND ONLY UNDER
VERY LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
DO NOT APPEAR TO COVER ALL.
OR EVEN MOST OF THE FEDERAL AND
STATE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN
PLACE TODAY.
FINALLY THE BILL WOULD BAN THE
SALE OF PRODUCTS OF THOSE
PRODUCTS OR INGREDIENTS IN THE
PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN TESTED I AM
ON ANIMALS BY ANY ENTITY.
GLOBALLY INCLUDING TESTING
CONDUCTED BY ENTITIES ENTIRELY
UNRELATED TO THE MANUFACTURERS
OF THE PRODUCTS THEMSELVES.
IF ENACTED IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THE COUNCIL BELIEVES OF THE BILL
WOULD CREATE TRADE BARRIERS
PARTICULAR BETWEEN US AND CHINA.
WOULD INCENTIVIZE COMPANIES TO
MOVE CERTAIN OPERATIONS FROM
CALIFORNIA TO CHINA.
RESULTING IN LOSS OF JOBS AND
REVENUE IN CALIFORNIA AND COULD
ULTIMATELY BE ON THE CEILING
CALVET CALIFORNIA OF KEY.
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
CATEGORICALLY.
COSMETIC PRODUCTS ARE SOME
CALIFORNIA MUST COMPLY WITH THE
RANGE OF STATE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS I'M JUST GONNA HIGH
LATE.
BRIEFLY IF YOU THOSE RIGHT NOW.
THE FEDERAL LEVEL FDA'S
EXPLICITLY KNOWLEDGE THE ANIMAL
TESTING MAY BE NECESSARY TO
DEMONSTRATE SAFETY OF A PRODUCT
OR INGREDIENT.
IN EFFECT REQUIRE SUCH TESTING
FOR CERTAIN COSMETIC DRUG
PRODUCTS RIGHT NOW SUCH AS
TOOTHPASTE.
ON THE GLOBAL FRONT CHINA'S
COSMETIC HYGIENE MANAGEMENT
REGULATION MANDATES THE
COMPANIES ASSURE PRODUCT SAFETY
BITE HEARING TO STANDARDS THAT
REQUIRE TESTING.
INCLUDING TOXICITY TESTING ON
ANIMALS. THREE PERFORMING ORDER
FOR NEARLY ALL TYPES OF COSMETIC
PRODUCTS INGREDIENTS WE PLACE ON
THE MARKET IN CHINA.
THE COUNSELOR MEANS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TOLL FORTY
NINE DOES NOT ADEQUATELY ACCOUNT
FOR THESE LEGAL OBLIGATIONS.
AND IS ALSO VERY CONCERNED THE
SCOPE OF THE PROPOSED BAN IS
OVERBROAD AND MAYBE TRIGGERED BY
TESTING OVER WHICH MANUFACTURES
HAVE NO CONTROL.
OR WHICH THEY ARE NOT EVEN AWARE
NOT TO MENTION THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY INCENTIVIZE ANIMAL
TESTING.
FROM VARIOUS PURPOSES BY ANY
PERSON SEEKING DISRUPT THE SELF
COSMETICS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE ALL THESE ISSUES
COULD BE READILY ADDRESS WHILE
STILL ALLOWING FOR STATE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD MEAN
FLICKER TALE BECAUSE MANIC
COSMETIC ANIMAL TESTING.
PACIFIC LATER COUNCIL BELIEVES
THE FUNDAMENTAL CONCEPTS OF THE
EU'S COSMETIC REGULATION WHICH
SUCCESSFULLY PHASED OUT COSMETIC
ANIMAL TESTING IN THE EU WOULD
PROVIDE A MORE REASONABLE.
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK.
CRITICALLY THE EU COMMISSION AND
THE EUROPEAN COURT OF JUSTICE
THE HIVE HIGHEST COURT IN THE
YOU HAVE RECOGNIZE THE PRODUCTS
THEY ARE CANNOT BE BE AND IF
THEY'VE BEEN TESTED FOR PURPOSES
OF COMPLIANCE AND OTHER
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING THOSE OF CHINA.
PROVIDED THE ANIMAL DATA IS NOT
USED FOR COMPLIANCE THE EU
COSMETICS REGULATION.
IN SOME THE COUNCIL SUPPORTS THE
FOLLOWING ALIGNING CALIFORNIA
LAW THE CURRENT FRAMEWORK OF THE
EEO IS TAILORED TO US IN
CALIFORNIA LEGAL AND REGULATORY
SCHEME.
AND URGING CHINA TO ABOLISH
EXISTING ANIMAL TESTING
REQUIREMENTS AND GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT CONDUCTED ANIMAL
TESTING.
THE DIRECT ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATION RATHER THAN CREATING
ARBITRARY HARMFUL BARRIERS TO
TRADE.
UNFORTUNATELY S. B. TWELVE FORTY
NINE FAILED TO ACCOMPLISH THESE
GOALS.
AND WOULD UNFAIRLY NEEDLESSLY
PUNISH CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
WE ASK TO THE COMMITTEE REJECT
SP TWELVE FOURTEEN ON ITS
CURRENT FORM.
AND COLLABORATE WITH INDUSTRY
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON A
WORKABLE SOLUTION THAT SUPPORTS
THE ELIMINATION OF ANIMAL
TESTING REQUIREMENTS BOTH IN AND
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DON
KEPT KEY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
AND REGRETTABLE OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE FORTY NINE AND I DO SAY
REGRETTABLE AND WE HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY I LISTED SENATE
BILL TWELVE FORTY NINE HOURS A
MANUFACTURING BREAKER DUE TO ITS
IMPACTS ON INNOVATION.
AND INVESTMENT IN OTHER BECAUSE
MY FOR YEAH THAT COULD ALSO HAVE
RIPPLE EFFECTS EVEN BEYOND TO
ADOPT INDUSTRY BASED ON THE
INGREDIENT TESTINO HOW THAT MAY
BE CONDUCTED FOR COMPLETELY
UNRELATED PURPOSES AND IMPACTS
THERE'VE.
ADDITIONALLY --
THE BILL ALLIES A CONSTRUCTED
EVEN I WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS RESPECTFULLY TO NOT
ADDRESS IN FULL THE CHALLENGES
MANUFACTURERS WOULD AND BE
FORCED TO THE DEAL WITH.
AS THOUGH I DO OUT EXEMPTIONS
ARE VERY VERY I'M CRAFTED IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THEY ULTIMATELY
EXCLUDE I'M SOME COSMETIC
COMPANIES TO HAVE PERHAPS
DIFFERENT PRODUCT LINES.
AND AROUND KIND OF ANTI
MICROBIAL THOSE OTHER PRODUCT
LINES THAT MAY BE REQUIRED TO
OUT TO HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
TESTING HAVE FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS THAT ARE TESTED FOR
OTHER PURPOSES --
AND SO DISADVANTAGES MANY
COMPANIES THAT HAVE IT THAT HAS
NO BEARING ON THE COSMETIC I IN
IN QUESTION WHATSOEVER.
OF FURTHER THE CONCERNS BEING
THAT ON THE BROAD IMPLICATIONS
FROM THE TRADE PERSPECTIVE
CERTAINLY ARE NOT TO BE
DISMISSED.
I'M ULTIMATELY AND THE BILL
HAVING SUCH SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
WILL RESULT IN --
ESSENTIALLY A HUNGER GAMES
SCENARIO IF YOU WILL GIVEN THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THOUGH NEW
LANGUAGE WOULD REQUIRE A PRODUCT
TO BE ON THE MARKET FOR AN
ENTIRE YEAR.
AND BEFORE ANY INGREDIENT TO A
TESTING CAN BE CONDUCTED SO
SENSUAL YOU'RE STIFLING
INNOVATION ON FOR NEW PRODUCTS
AND AND DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
THINGS WERDEN NEW INGREDIENTS
ARE ULTIMATELY KIND OF PICKED
OFF ONE BY ONE BECAUSE THERE MAY
BE TESTING DEMOCRATIC FOR
UNRELATED PURPOSES.
BUT MAYBE YOU KNOW HAVE BEARING
ON NEW INNOVATION IN TERMS OF
THE USE OF THOSE --
ULTIMATELY AS AS JUST SECOND
FROM THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL NOTED AND THE E. U.
ALIGNMENTS IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS CA AND I
ITS MEMBER COMPANIES WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GET BEHIND.
CERTAINLY MOVES THE NEEDLE FOR
CALIFORNIA LAW MUCH FURTHER THAN
WHERE WE ARE TODAY WOULD BE
WORKABLE ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY WITH CHINA TO MOVE
THEM TOWARDS ALTERNATIVES TO
ANIMAL TESTING AND ELIMINATE
THAT BR ARE THE TESTING
REQUIREMENT.
BUT ULTIMATELY ONLY HAVE SO MUCH
ABILITY TO IMPACT THAT AND
CERTAINLY WE DON'T EXPECT THAT
THAT'S GOING TO CURRENT BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE BETTER DOING
SO YOU KNOW THAT ADVOCACY IN
EARNEST --
FURTHER THE FACT AND THAT THIS
WILL ULTIMATELY HAVE AN IMPACT
ON JOBS IN THE STATE AS WELL I'M
IN SPEAKING AT THE OUTSET.
AROUND WITH THE PROPONENTS THERE
WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT WAYS TO
AVOID THE CHINA TESTING
REQUIREMENT WHICH WAS ULTIMATELY
TO MOVE MANUFACTURING INTO THE
COUNTRY TO AVOID THAT.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE AS A
MANUFACTURING ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WRONG HEADED
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT JOBS
HERE IN THE STATE MANUFACTURING
HERE IN THE STATE OF THE
TORTILLA DECLINING NOT INDUSTRY.
SO THESE ARE JUST BUT A FEW OF
THE CONCERN I WOULD STRONGLY
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE ON THIS AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYWHERE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. TO COME FORWARD AND
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
TOM JACOB ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUCH.
I RIGHTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WERE CONCERNED THAT'LL HAVE --
JOB APPLICATIONS AND WE DON'T
THINK GO UNDER THE CURRENT
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE OF TESTING FOR ANY PURPOSE
THANKS THANK YOU.
MARIN HIGGINS REPRESENTING BILE
COME IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I THINK NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE SAID I WANNA THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES BETWEEN WHAT
THIS IS PROPOSING AND WHAT THE
EUROPEAN UNION IS DOING.
BUT FRANKLY.
THIS IS A PRETTY LARGE MARKET
CALIFORNIA.
AND IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO USE OUR
MARKET PRESENCE TO SHIFT POLICY
AT EVEN INTERNATIONAL POLICY WE
DO THAT FROM TIME TO TIME IN
THIS TO ME IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT TO MOVE AWAY FROM.
ALLOWING LONG STANDING.
AND TO ME OBJECTIONABLE
PRACTICES IN.
THIS INDUSTRY AND SO I THINK
THIS BILL REALLY ESTABLISHES
THAT THOSE CRITERIA WE WE WORK
TO TRY AND THEY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S.
OFFICE WORKING WITH US TO TRY
AND THREAD SOME OF THESE --
TWO TO A POINT BUT FROM MY
STANDPOINT I THINK THE BILL AS
AMENDED MEETS THIS.
STANDARDS FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND
I'M HOPING THAT WE WILL.
MOVE IT FORWARD.
KALRA THAT MR MAIENSCHEIN.
I THINK WAS SHARON THANK YOU
SENATOR HUB FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD --
THING YOU KNOW I THINK A THE
THING ABOUT COSMETICS YOU'VE
PEOPLE USE COSMETICS FOR A LOT
OF REASONS BUT I THINK UP OF THE
PRIMARY REASONS IS THESE
COSMETICS. TO LOOK GOOD AND FEEL
GOOD A AND I THINK IT IS HARD TO
DO THAT IF YOU KNOW THAT THE
PRODUCTS ARE USING HAD THE TEST.
I THINK THAT'S THE UNDERLYING
CONNECT THE M. AND M. EVEN AND
NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY
TO TALK TO THE FOLKS WHO SUPPORT
THE BILL BUT OPPOSITION AS WELL
AND I DON'T ANYONE DISAGREES
THAT.
ITS A POSITIVE GOAL --
INCLUDING INDUSTRY OF COURSE
HE'LL THAT INDEED MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION EVEN ON THEIR OWN TO
IN MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION SO I
THINK.
I DON'T THINK THAT.
AND ONCE.
BUDGET ISSUES KIND OF
INTERNATIONALLY AS WELL AS SOME
OF THE RESTRICTIONS ON I GET AND
I GET I ET THAT.
I'M BUT I DO THINK THAT.
AS TO THE CHAIR'S POINT LOOK.
IF IF CALIFORNIA THE FIFTH
LARGEST CALM THE WORLD --
JOINS FORTY OTHER NATIONS SUB IT
WOULD BE AMONGST THE LARGEST
NATION JOINING IN THAT
PARTNERSHIP --
IF YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT NO
ANIMAL TESTING IS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
THAT IS WHAT.
MOVES THE NATIONS LIKE CHINA AND
OTHERS THAT'S WHAT CREATES THE
MOMENTUM IN MY OPINION --
IT TO REALLY CREATE
INTERNATIONAL CHANGE ON THE
ISSUE.
A CRUELTY FREE COSMETICS ARE ARE
NOT A NOVELTY --
I THINK IT'S MORE MORE
UBIQUITOUS IN CALIFORNIA AND AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD --
AND AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR --
INCLUDING THE THE EXEMPTION TO
LIMIT EXEMPTS OF ANIMAL TESTING
FOR NON COSMETIC PURPOSES NOW MY
GUESS IS THAT A AND AND BASED
UPON THAT THE TESTIMONY THAT.
DOESN'T SAY SATISFIED OPPOSITION
BUT I DO THINK THAT'S A GOOD
FAITH.
I'M AMENDMENT ADMIT TO RECOGNIZE --
THAN THAT THE GOAL HERE AYE IS
NOT TO SHUT DOWN COMPANIES --
BECAUSE OF SOME CHEMICAL THAT
HAPPENS TO BE IN ONE OF THE
PRODUCTS IS BEING USED FOR
SOMETHING IN HIM THAT I THE IDEA
HERE IS RELATED TRIED NEARLY
FOCUS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
MY GUESS IS THAT THAT THE OPTION
BY BILLS COULD BE DONE THAT BE
MORE WORK DONE ON THAT AND
THAT'S PART OF THE PROCESS.
OF IS TO CONTINUE THE TO HAVE
DIALOGUE AND CONTINUE TO WORK --
AND NO LONG TERM.
IN TERMS OF THIS MOVEMENT AT THE
I DON'T BELIEVE THE GOAL IS TO
FIND A WAY TO COEXIST WITH
ANIMAL TESTED COSMETICS LONG
TERM THE GOAL IS TO ELIMINATE
ANIMAL TESTED COSMETICS ON THE
PLANET.
AND THAT HAPPENS WHEN I'M WITH
WHEN WE ARE BOLD ABOUT IT AND I
DO THINK THAT THE EU WAS BORED
WHEN THEY WENT FORWARD AND I
THINK THAT --
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THIS ISN'T AN
EVEN BOLDER STEP TO SOME EXTENT
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S A IT'S
IT'S GOING THAT FAR.
OF ONE OF FAR ALONG --
TO AB YOU ATTEMPT TO BE AS
DAMAGING TO THE INDUSTRY AS AS
THEIR AS THE FEARS THAT IT
DIDN'T.
OUTLINED OTHERS FOUR AND HALF
YEARS TO A TO WORK. TO TRY TO
MOVE CONTINUE TO MOVE CHINA IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION RATHER THAN
HAVING TO GET EXEMPTIONS BY
COMPANY BY COMPANY WHICH SEEMS
LIKE A VERY.
KIND OF INEFFICIENT WAY OF DOING
IT I THINK THAT THAT YOU CAN
HELP.
MORE THAN ANY NATION EVEN
ADOPTING IT GET GIVEN THE SIZE
OF THE MARKET.
IN MOVING CHINA IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I WANT TO THANK THAT
THE SENATOR --
I I WOULD BE HAPPY TO JOIN AS A
CO AUTHOR AND WORK WITH YOU AS I
TEND TO THE EXTENT YOU LIKE TO
WITH OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE.
TO HAVE THAT DIALOGUE TO MAKE
SURE THAT TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE WE CAN GET INDUSTRY AND
WORKS I DO THINK THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT.
INDUSTRY AND ITS HEART WANTS TO
BE YOU WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
BUT I I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
OBLIGATIONS THAT YOU HAVE ITS
AID TO THE TO THE COMPANY'S
REPRESENT AS WELL --
AND SO --
THANK YOU I'VE SENATOR ONCE
AGAIN A LITTLE THAT I LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION IS
THERE SECONDS.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU MISTER
BRAINCHILD OF THE MISTER GABRIEL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY -- I
THINK IT IT IT'S QUITE CLEAR TO
ME THAT THIS WILL NOT ONLY --
SAVE THE LIVES OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS BUT IT IT
WILL ALSO --
SAVE TORTURE A OF SO MANY MORE.
AND DATA.
HOW TELL YOU WHY I'M A SINGLE
DAD TO GIRLS SO WE ARE?
EVERYONE.
SAYS I NEED TO SAY ANYTHING IN
THERE ARE.
THE CROWDS LIKE WE NEED TO GIVE
HIM A HUG [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
NO AYE WE ARE JUST ENTERING THE
WORLD THAT HAVE MAKE UP
[inaudible]
I AND SO THAT'S INTERESTING BUT
BUT I HAVE TAUGHT HIM YOU KNOW I
OF THIS IS THAT THERE.
WHERE DO YOU SERIOUS BUT I WAS
JUST SO HAPPY WITH THAT RESPONSE
IT'S LIKE THAT IT CUT?
ITS A BIG MOMENT FOR ME --
YOUR SINGLE DAD YOU DON'T GET A
LOT OF FEET YOU KNOW NOT A PAN
THAT'S ON THE BACK --
BUT NO BUT WHEN WE YOU KNOW WHEN
WE ARE YOU KNOW I DO GO WITH
THEM TO GO TO GO SHOPPING FOR
THIS AND I HAVE TAUGHT THEM TO
LOOK FOR THE CRUELTY FREE LABELS --
I SPENT SOMETIME IN YOUR START
TO MAP.
A LOT.
AND THAT AND AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME
AS A AS A AS A VALUE TO TEACH
THEM.
AND I'LL AND I'LL TELL YOU AND I
ADMITTEDLY.
YOU KNOW THIS MY FIRST VENTURE
INTO THIS AREA BUT IT'S NOT LIKE
THERE'S NOT.
PRODUCTS AVAILABLE FOR THEM IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT LIKE THEY KEEP YOU
KEEP THIS CAN'T BE DONE THIS
ISN'T AN IMPOSSIBLE.
LEAP -- SO --
AND I THINK THIS IS A A A MUCH
MORE HUMANE IT MUCH MORE
COMPASSIONATE APPROACH I THINK
THERE PROBABLY ARE SOME YOU KNOW
SOME.
LANGUAGE IF SOMETHING'S AND
LANGUAGE THAT THAT PROBABLY
COULD BE.
CLEARED UP OR MADE MORE CLEAR IN
RESPONSE TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID AS WELL --
AND I NOTE THAT THE AUTHOR WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND MAKING
SURE THINGS ARE CLEAR --
BUT EVENTUALLY YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY IT'S GOING TO COME TO
POINT WHERE THIS ISN'T EVEN
GOING TO BE AN ISSUE --
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE MOVED NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND REALLY WORLDWIDE
PASSED THIS --
AND WON'T BE IT THIS THIS WON'T
BE A THING THAT IN TERMS OF
COSMETICS NEEDS TO BE TESTED ON
ANIMALS ANYMORE --
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT DAY
AND IN THE MEANTIME CERTAINLY
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS AT
THANK YOU TELL YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE.
FOR YOUR EMOTIONAL SUPPORT FOR
ME TODAY.
AND HAPPY TO TO SECOND THIS AND
SEE THIS MOVE ON THANK YOU
MISTER GABRIEL THE MISS
CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CENTER
I JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION I WANTED.
TO SUCH HIT MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF OUR CHAIRMAN I THINK
THIS IS AT A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO USE OUR MARKET
POWER IN THE WITH OUR VALUES AND
I THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE ADDED
OUR SELF TO THE LIST OF OF
NATIONS THAT HAVE GONE CRUELTY
FREE.
SO AND PLEASED TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS LEGISLATION AND I WOULD
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK ME OUT IT
IS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S GOING TO HELP.
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR A
LARGELY THE OPPOSITION ALTHOUGH
I THINK THAT CAN BE ADDRESSED BY
ANYBODY UP WITH RESPECT TO THE
IMPACT ON JOBS AT I'M STRUGGLING
WITH THAT PIECE OF IT BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE'RE IN AN ERA.
INTERNATIONALLY WERE WERE SORT
OF READ VISITING AND RE OPENING --
DISCUSSIONS WITH IN PARTICULAR
CHINA -- ON
ALL NUMBERS OF ALL MANNER OF
TRADE ISSUES.
RIGHT AND AS I UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATION THAT GIVES THE SORT
OF A FIVE YEAR PERIOD. FOR
BEFORE IT REALLY TAKES EFFECT IN
ANY SORT OF TOTAL BAN WOULD
WOULD.
WOULD TAKE EFFECT SO.
THAT SEEMS TO BE TO ME TO
MITIGATE THE POTENTIAL IMPACT ON
JOBS.
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT A PHASE IN
PERIOD ONE AND TWO IT GIVES US
FIVE YEARS TO MAYBE --
PUT THIS INTO THE THE
INTERNATIONAL RENEGOTIATION OF
TRADE ISSUES TYPE POTENTIAL USE
AS THE I CHAIR RIGHTLY POINTED
OUT USE ARE SIGNIFICANT MARKET
POWER IN CALIFORNIA.
TOOK PERHAPS PUSH --
THAT COUNTRY IN A CRUELTY FREE
DIRECTION SO COULD I JUST LIKE
MAYBE A RESPONSE FROM BOTH OF YA
ABSOLUTE AS A AT SOMEONE AND
THINK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
APPRECIATE THAT.
I THINK IT CONVERTS TO FULL NOT
ONLY RELATIVE TO THE CHINA
EXEMPTION AND SUNSET DATE THERE
BUT ALSO THE LANGUAGE AROUND THE
TESTING FOR ANY PURPOSE.
AND TRYING TO KIND OF ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
RELATIVE TO THE CHINA SUNSET
DATE WE HAVE A GUN NO ASSURANCES
THAT HOW CHINA WILL MOVE AWAY
FROM THE REQUIREMENTS AROUND TOO
YOU KNOW REQUIRING DOT COMPANIES
THAT WANT TO SELL INTO THE
CHINESE MARKET TOWN WILL TEST.
THERE'S NO DATE CERTAIN
CERTAINLY THE INDUSTRY IS
LOBBYING AND I'M TRYING TO
EDUCATE THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
AND PUSHING FOR THEM TO
ELIMINATE THOSE REQUIREMENTS
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THERE'S NO
CERTAINTY AND NOT FOR THESE
COMPANIES.
AND SO YOU KNOW WHEN COMPANIES
ARE FACED WITH THE KNOW THAT
DECIDING TO HAVE TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO SELL INTO THE CHINESE
MARKET.
ORINDA CALIFORNIA THE CHINESE
MARKET IS A LARGER MARKET THAN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT THAT'S IT A
CHALLENGING.
DECISION TO MAKE AND SO YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE FORCE WITH HAVING TO
MAKE THAT TYPE OF DECISION TO
SPECIFICALLY RELATIVE TO THAT
REQUIREMENT.
YOU KNOW IS IT DOES IT MAKE MORE
SENSE TO BE ABLE TO DO BOTH CHIU
UP AND MOVE YOUR JOBS INTO CHINA
TO AVOID THAT TESTING
REQUIREMENT IS CHINA. FOR THOSE
COMPANIES THAT ARE MANUFACTURING
IN COUNTRY VERY THEY DON'T HAVE
TO ABIDE BY THAT PARTICULAR
TESTING REQUIREMENT SO UPS AND
IT BASICALLY FORCES A
MANUFACTURER.
CHAPTER DECIDE TO MOVE THEIR
MENU.
FROM CALIFORNIA INTO CHINA TO
AVOID THAT TESTING REQUIREMENT
IT THAT TWENTY TWENTY THREE DAY
COMES AND GOES AND THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT HAVE ELIMINATED THAT
WERE TESTING REQUIREMENT IMPORT.
THAT'S THE PREDICAMENT
MANUFACTURERS WHO WHO SELL INTO
THE CHINESE MARKET WILL FIND
THEMSELVES AND RELATIVE TO THE
NEW LANGUAGE US AS PROPOSED.
AND THE CHALLENGE WITH THIS IS
THAT FOR SOME COMPANIES --
WHO MAY BE INVOLVED AND KIND OF
HAD MULTIPLE PRODUCTS SECTOR ON
A LINES I YOU KNOW SON YOU KNOW
MADE YOU ARE INTO YOU THROUGH
YOU KNOW I'M?
KIND OF LIFE SCIENCES WORK AND
SO IS PART OF THAT WORK WHETHER
BE YOU KNOW FOR PHARMACEUTICAL
DEVELOPMENT JUST ARE IN DE
RELATED TO YOU KNOW OTHER GREEN
CHEMISTRY RELATED PURPOSES.
ULTIMATELY IF THE IF A
MANUFACTURER A COSMETIC BECAUSE
THE COSMETIC LINE ALSO HAS A
SUBSIDIARY THAT'S ALSO DOING
KIND ARE IN DIFFERENT WITHOUT
WHATEVER YOU KNOW OTHER INDUSTRY
SECTOR PRODUCT PURPOSE.
THEY WOULD BE OF THEIR POT
COSMETIC PRODUCTS WOULD BE
BANNED UNDER THIS LANGUAGE
FURTHER IF A COMPANY YOU KNOW
PERHAPS HAS --
OTHER PRODUCT LINES THAT YOU
KNOW OUR DISINFECTANTS
DISINFECTANTS YOU KNOW THE TERMS
OF KIND OF HER CONSIDERED A
PESTICIDE BASED ON THAT THIS
ANTI MICROBIAL DISINFECTANT
PROPERTIES.
ARE REQUIRED AS PART OF THE USE
OF THOSE PRODUCTS TO CONDUCT
TESTING FOR THE PURPOSES OF
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
DISINFECTANTS ACTUALLY KILLED
THE THE BY TEARING OF THE
VIRUSES.
VETERAN QUESTION THAT'S THEIR
INTENDED PURPOSE SO ULTIMATELY
THAT TYPE OF COMPANY ALSO WOULD
HAVE THEIR COSMETIC SUBSIDIARY
AND THEIR PRODUCTS BEYOND
BECAUSE UNDER THIS LANGUAGE.
IT MEANS S. TO LIMIT THAT YOU
KNOW TESTING FOR ANY PURPOSE BUT
IT DISADVANTAGES THOSE COMPANIES
HAVE MAY HAVE SOME YOU KNOW
MULTI SECTOR LINES IN
MANUFACTURING OPERATIONS HERE IN
THE STATE.
SO THOSE ARE JUST A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES ABOUT HOW THEY'D THEY
WOULD HAVE TRUE CALIFORNIA JOB
IMPACTS TO AND THOSE ARE BUT
JUST A COUPLE OF OF EXAMPLES OF
OF REAL LIFE IMPLICATIONS.
COULD I GET A RESPONSE YET
PARTLY YES SO WHAT WHAT.
THESE ARGUMENTS WERE BROUGHT UP
DURING THE U. EUROPEAN UNION --
HEARINGS ALL THE SAME TYPE OF
ARGUMENTS AND WHAT HAPPENED WITH
JOBS IS JOBS GREW AND HERE'S
WHERE JOBS GROW WHICH WE LOVE IS
IN THE TECH INDUSTRY.
MEETING THESE REQUIREMENTS OF
ALL THESE NEW ALTERNATIVE TEST
AND OPENING IT UP WHEN I DID OUR
DUE DILIGENCE ON THIS BILL.
AND TALKING TO COMPANIES LIKE
LIFE AND JOHN PAUL MITCHELL
SYSTEMS JOHN PAUL MITCHELL
SYSTEMS LIKE I SAID THEIR
INCEPTION THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AGO
CRUELTY FREE.
THEY WANTED TO BE IN CHINA RIGHT.
AND SO THEY SAID HOW.
AND THE CHINESE REGULATORS
WORKED WITH THEM.
ON A TEST THAT'S OUT OF BOSTON
THAT COMPANY IS CALLED MAY TECH.
AND THAT CHINESE REGULATORS SAID
THE SOUL SATISFY OUR
REQUIREMENTS THEY NOW.
ARE MOVING ALL THEIR SKEWS YES
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS YES IT WAS A BY DEFAULT
BUT WHEN JOHN PAUL MITCHELL
SYSTEMS SAID HEY.
WE WANT TO STAY CRUELTY FREE THE
CHINESE REGULATORS MADE IT
HAPPEN SO YOU GROW JOBS BECAUSE
A WILL BE THE LEADER AND CRUELTY
FREE.
SO OF COURSE MORE COMPANIES WILL
FLOURISH BY CHANGING THEIR
PRODUCT LINES THEY'RE GONNA SELL
MORE PRODUCT BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT
TO BUY CRUELTY FREE.
AND THEN THE TECH SECTOR ALL
ALSO GROWS WITH THIS SO YOU KNOW
YES THERE'S TEST ON THE MARKET
YES WE HAVE PLENTY TO USE THAT
ARE SAFER THAN THE ANIMAL TESTS.
BUT THAT MARKET WILL GROW AND IT
WILL KEEP MOVING SO YOU KNOW WE
FIND THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF RED
HERRINGS A THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED.
AND THAT WE CAN'T JUSTIFY THESE
ARGUMENTS AND THESE ARGUMENTS
WERE MADE ONCE UPON A TIME YEARS
AGO WITH THE EUROPEAN UNION AND
THEY HAVE BEEN FLESHED OUT.
SO THAT IS MY RESPONSE --
AND ALI BABA HOW SORRY ONE MORE
THAT YOU WANT TO COVER ALI BABA
AND I THINK BUT WHO THE HECK.
I THINK THAT DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION OR TO EXPLORE THAT
FURTHER PAGES LOTUS IF YOU HAD.
AND A BRIEF ADDITIONAL YEAH
BRIEFLY I WE WERE JUST GOING TO
MENTION THAT THERE THE ON THE
LARGEST ONLINE RETAILER ALIBABA
DOT COM COMPANIES CAN UTILIZE
THAT TO REACH THE ENTIRE CHINESE
MARKET AS WELL.
AND HONG KONG ALSO HAS AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT SET OF
REGULATIONS AS THE REST OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND ANY YOU
COULD HAVE.
A STOREFRONT IN HONG KONG
UTILIZED THAT A LARGE PART OF
THE CHINESE MARKET WITHOUT EVER
HAVING TO CONDUCT ANIMAL TESTING
AND IT'S A MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR
MARKET AND WE LEFT THE DOCUMENTS
IN THE TWENTY YEAR OFFICES SO I
JUST AS WELL NOT IF YOU HOLD ON
HOLD ON MISTER.
CUNNINGHAM HAS GOOD LORD I DON'T
WANT FOLKS TO JUMPING IN THIS IS
NOT.
A FREE FOR ALL.
APPRECIATE THE PASSION.
COULD I JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT ON
THE YEAR AND AS I NOTED IN MY
TESTIMONY WHAT'S INVOLVED IN THE
U. IS IN IT AT CARVE OUT FOR THE
TESTING REQUIRED IN CHINA FOR
SOME OF THE REASONS THAT WE
DISCUSSED TODAY AND SO THESE
ISSUES WERE CONSIDERED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE EU LEGISLATION BUT THE
CURRENT STATE OF THAT IS THAT
DOES NOT APPLY.
THE TESTING THAT'S DONE IN
REQUIRED RENT IT FOR CHINA UP
PURPOSES SUCH HUNTINGTON MAKE
THAT CLEAR.
LUCAS DRESS AND THEN MISTER
KILEY.
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON SOME
OF THE COMMENTS FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
YOU DID SAY THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING. TO USE FOR THE USE OF
ALTERNATIVES TO ANIMAL TESTING
[inaudible]
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND THAT --
YOU YOU DO SUPPORT A STOP TO
ANIMAL TESTING IN AND OUT OF
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THAT.
THE BILL ITSELF THEN.
PUTS US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
I RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO MAKE
SURE GET YOUR YOUR COMMENTS ARE
WELL TAKEN ABOUT THE JOBS I
THINK THE RESPONSE --
TO MISTER CUNNINGHAM'S QUESTIONS.
ARE ALSO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION
THAT WE NEED TO SEE THAT.
WE MAY NOT HAVE THAT IMPACT THE
JOBS THAT MAY BE EXPECTED
[inaudible]
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WE ARE
LOOKING TO BE AT A POINT WHERE
WE ARE NO LONGER.
DOING ANIMAL TESTING FOR
COSMETICS IT'S I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD START I THINK THAT GIVING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME --
TO FOR THE ADJUSTMENT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THAT I THE
THE OBJECTIONS THAT ARE STILL
THERE I KNOW THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
AUTHOR WILL BE ABLE TO WORK.
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO SEE WHAT
OTHER AMENDMENTS NEED TO BE
TAKEN BUT I THINK THAT WE'RE
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY --
DEFECT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
DISCUSSION ON THIS AND AND
CERTAINLY I APPRECIATE ALL THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE COME IN SUPPORT
OF THE OF THE BILL IT'S ALWAYS
GREAT TO SEE.
SO MANY PEOPLE ENGAGED
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S FOR SUCH A
GOOD BECAUSE AS I TO QUESTION
SENATOR ABOUT SORT OF WHY YOU
CHOSE -- TO
STRUCTURES THE WAY YOU HAVE
WE'VE HEARD THAT YOU REGULATIONS
SERVICE CITED ON BOTH SIDES IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND DIE IN THE
BILL'S GENERATE A LOT OPPOSITION
NOT JUST FROM THE COSMETICS
INDUSTRY BUT ALSO FROM --
ORGANIZATIONS --
THAT MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS THAT
WE MIGHT CONSIDER NOT MERELY
AESTHETIC AND BUT MORE VITAL --
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO BUILD --
YOU MIGHT STILL BE ABLE TO BUILD
A BROADER CONSENSUS IF YOU MORE
CLOSELY ALIGN OUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN
THE EU SO HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT.
DOING THAT IS ONE OF WHY YOU
DECIDED TO GO ABOUT THIS.
YES WE HAD AN AND THAT.
YEARS WE WERE SEEKING TO MOVE
THE BALL FORWARD A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
AND WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TAKEN ON
THREE MAJOR AMENDMENTS AS WE SEE
THEM UP TO TRY TO WORK TOWARD --
ACCOMMODATING THE SITUATION THAT
IS IN CHINA AYE THAT'S WHY WE
HAD THE EXEMPTION AND TELL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT IT WILL FOLLOW THE
LEAD WHEN THEY SEE THAT
CALIFORNIA AND THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE ABLE TO DO IT.
AND THAT THAT TECHNOLOGIES OUT
THERE IS AVAILABLE AND WHEN THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY ARE WORKING
WITH PAUL MITCHELL SYSTEMS AND
THAT.
WITH THOSE PRODUCTS THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE ANIMAL
CRUELTY FREE.
A WE BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL
FOLLOW CALIFORNIA'S LEAD WERE
GIVING FIVE YEARS TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT --
WERE WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
ON OTHER AMENDMENTS AS WELL AND
THIS IS BETTER OF OF WORK IN
PROGRESS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
BRING TWO DIVERGENT SIDES.
WHO I BELIEVE REALLY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR ULTIMATELY A
BUT WE WE HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS
ON HOW TO GET THERE?
AND ON THIS BEFORE YOU TODAY AS
A STEP FORWARD ON EVEN MORE
PROGRESS THAN WHAT'S BEEN DONE
IN THE E. U. BUT GETS A WORK IN
PROGRESS WERE TRIED TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE A QUESTION
AND MAYBE BEST RESPONSIBLE ALSO
FOR THE AUTHOR AND DOWN.
I'M JUST TRYING --
TO YOU KNOW I I THINK ONE OF THE
ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE A VERY
COMPELLING ON YOUR SIDE I'M
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT --
THE ETHICS OF ANIMAL TESTING AND
SO WHAT KIND [inaudible]
FAR AS WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE IS
EVER APPROPRIATE IS IT ONLY
APPROPRIATE FOR SOME PURPOSES AS
OPPOSED TO OTHERS.
WE HAVE THE A SCIENTIST WITH US
TODAY ELISABETH BAKER FROM
PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE SHE IS ALSO
A CO SPONSOR.
AND HER JOB ACTUALLY IS MARION
UP THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY --
TO REPLACE ANIMAL TEST OUTSIDE
OF COSMETIC SO I THINK THE SHORT
ANSWER AND I'M NOT THAT
SCIENTISTS BUT I KNOW A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT ELIZABETH DOES
FOR A LIVING.
IS PHASING OUT WHERE YOU CAN --
I ALSO SIT ON THE BED MARY
MEDICAL BOARD AND I'VE BEEN ON
THE BOARD FOR EIGHT YEARS AND
ONE OF THE VETERINARIANS THAT
SITS NEXT TO ME MY SEAT MATE.
IS DR JAMIE NOBLE WHEN AND SHE
IS WITH OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND DAVIS.
AND IT'S OVER ANIMAL SCIENCES
RIGHT.
AND SO I VAST YOU AMY YOU KNOW
HEY WHEN YOU GUYS GONNA DO AWAY
WITH ANIMAL TESTING AND SHE SAYS
YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE'VE REPLACED WHERE THERE'S AN
ALTERNATIVE WE USE IT.
SO THAT'S THE ANSWER IS AS
PLEASE TEST COME FORWARD.
AND THEY ARE AS GOOD OR BETTER
IS THE REAL ANSWER THEN THE
ANIMAL TEST.
THE EMERALD HAS GOT TO GO AWAY.
THERE'S NO REASON TO KEEP IT
ANYMORE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE ANSWER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SENATE I FOR ONE WOULD HAVE BEEN
RATHER DISAPPOINTED IF THIS.
JUST WENT BACK TO WHAT THE E. U.
DEAD AND DOESN'T ADVANCE THE
THIS THE STATE OF WHERE WE NEED
TO GO RESPECT ANIMAL TESTING I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE S..
B. A LITTLE.
EVEN STRICTER IF IF POSSIBLE BUT
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO NAVIGATE
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT AND AND
AND DO SOMETHING THAT THAT
ADVANCES THE STATE OF WHERE WE
ARE.
BUT ALSO IS GOING TO GET OUT OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN AND GET TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK SIDE I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE.
THAT YOU DOING THERE AND HELPING
TO CREATE AND USING OUR
LEGISLATIVE POWER IN OUR MARKET
POWER. TO DRIVE RESULTS.
INTERNATIONALLY WE CAN WE CAN DO
THAT.
FORCING MORE CALIFORNIA'S HAVING
TO STEP IN EVEN WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS KIND OF
BACKING OFF SO I THINK THAT.
THE SPOTLIGHT IS ON CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A RESPONSIBLE MOVE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT AND
WITH THAT HE MAKE CLUBS.
THANK YOU I THINK WHAT WE REALLY
SEE HERE IS TWO DIVERGENT SIDES
WHAT WE'RE TRYING --
TO AS YOU SAY MOVE THE BALL
FORWARD --
AND MAKE PROGRESS.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DONE IN THE EUROPEAN UNION
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
BOTH SIDES.
I APPRECIATE THE THE WORDS OF
SUPPORT HERE TODAY IN THE
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO THE WE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN I MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES.
REYES AYE GABER [inaudible]
GABRIEL I THANK YOU.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU.
SO WE WILL NOW MOVE PULLED A
HOLD AYE WE GOT BUSINESS TO DO
SO.
GO CELEBRATE OUTSIDE THANK YOU.
SO LET'S SEE SENATOR HUESO LET'S
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE AND WHILE
WE'RE CLEARING LET'S JUST TAKE A
A BRIEF MOMENT I'LL TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA AND
THE CONSENT AGENDA ALSO INCLUDES
ITEM NUMBER.
SIX SUIT THANK YOU WOULD YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THANK
YOU KALRA PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM
AYE CHAU.
CHIU HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAINTAIN AYE REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I THOSE BILLS ARE OUT
THAT IS S. B.. ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE MORRELL S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX JACKSON AND S. B.
NINE OH FOR WHITE HOUSE SKI.
CENTER HUESO WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SO MEMBERS --
I DO NOT A CENT ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS A BILL THAT SEEKS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS BY EXPANDING
LANGUAGE ACCESS SERVICES.
WITHIN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OUR FIRST I'D LIKE TO ASK THANK
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE TO AND
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. TO DROP
AMENDMENTS TO SEE PROVIDE
GREATER PROTECTION FOR LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
LITIGANTS.
I'M I'M ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
A GIVEN PROPOSED AND THEY'VE
MADE MAKE THE BILL BETTER AND
THEY HELP US.
GET TO OUR ARE TARGETED GOAL.
FIRST OF ALL.
THANK YOU THERE IS A MOTION SIR
SECONDS.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU UP.
FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANT TO STAY
IN I'VE BEEN.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE SINCE TWENTY
TEN AND THAT YEAR WE WERE
ENTERTAINING.
ENORMOUS CUTS TO THE BUDGET THAT
TOOK OUR OUR OUR STATE GENERAL
FUND FROM ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS TO EIGHTY FIVE
BILLION. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DID IN THAT BUDGET WAS
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR EDUCATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT EDUCATION
DIDN'T SEE ANY CUTS.
THE THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT WAS
THAT EVERY OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WOULD WAS WAS UNDERFUNDED.
DRASTICALLY ONE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT REALLY TOOK A
HARD HIT.
WAS THE JUDICIAL BRANCH AND THE
COURTS AND I REMEMBER.
HAVING TO STAND UP AND YOU KNOW
IN THE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND BE
ONE OF THOSE VOICES STANDING UP
FOR NOT CLOSE SEEN.
OUR OUR COURTROOMS AND I'VE
FOUGHT REALLY HARD TO KEEP.
A LOT OF OUR OUR THE COURTS OPEN.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD AT CLOSED
SOME IN SOME PARTS OF THE STATE
AND THAT HAD --
A VERY DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON
GETTING ACCESS FOR PEOPLE IN
THOSE AREAS.
AND WE'VE STILL BEEN TRYING TO
CORRECT THAT AND WE ARE NOT
WHERE WE NEED TO BE IN FUNDING
THE COURTS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THAT HAS HAD AFFECTS
SERVICES IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
THE JEWISH BE JUDICIAL GOT
COUNSEL A CONVENED.
AND FOUND A WAY --
TO THEY THEY THAT THEY WERE THEY
FORMED A WORKING GROUP.
THAT -- HAS
SOUGHT TO CREATE THE MOST
EXPENSIVE POLICY POSSIBLE UNDER
THE FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
WE CAN PROVIDE LANGUAGE THE
INTERPRETATION AND LANGUAGE
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE.
IN THE SMALL CLAIMS AREA OF
DIGITAL JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
THIS IS PART OF A GREATER
PROGRAM.
TO GET CHIU 1100% ACCESS TO A
LANGUAGE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST DIVERSE
STATE IN THE UNION WE HAVE MORE
THAN TWO TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT LANGUAGES AND DIALECTS.
SPOKEN IN THE STATE --
WE WE HAVE. SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS JUST THAT'S THAT
SAY THEY CANNOT SPEAK ENGLISH
WELL OR PROFICIENTLY.
AND AS THEY NAVIGATE --
THE COURT SYSTEM YOU KNOW WE'RE
FINDING IF YOU HAVE 44% OF THE
RESIDENTS TO SPEAK.
A LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT
HOME THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A
HARD TIME WHEN IT COMES.
TO INTRANET COURTROOM AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAVE.
THE THE IT'S REPUTATION SERVICES
TO ENSURE.
THAT THEY CAN MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS AND IN THE PROCESS OF
ACHIEVING JUSTICE.
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL I
HAVE JOINED --
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE MEDINA
FULLER INTO NO QUALIA WHO CHAIRS
THIS WORKING GROUP.
WHO HAS --
COME UP WITH A A SOLUTION WITHIN
THE WORKING GROUP.
THAT IS IS PRACTICABLE THAT IS
ACHIEVABLE.
AND THAT IS A IMPLEMENTABLE.
UNDER THE CONSTRAINTS OF FACING
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM IN FORCE BY
THEM BY THE BY THE BUDGET CUTS
THAT.
WE HAVE HAD OVER THE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
GOING BACK AS FAR AS TWO
THOUSAND NIGHT.
A S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE ADOPTS
LANGUAGE ACCESS TAX WARS RECENT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
US SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL MAKE
SMALL CLAIMS OFFICIAL
PROCEEDINGS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ALLOWING THE COURT TO APPOINT A
CERTIFIED OR REGISTERED
INTERPRETER.
IT AUTHORIZES THE COURTS TO
POINT CERTIFIED REGISTERED.
OUR INTERPRETERS IN SMALL CLAIMS
PROCEEDINGS IT PROVIDES JUDICIAL
OFFICERS WITH DISCRETION TO
ALLOW A LITIGANT TO OPT FOR THE
USE OF A TEMPORARY INTERPRETER.
IF AN ATTEMPT TO SECURE A
CERTIFIED REGISTERED OR
PROVISIONALLY QUALIFIED
INTERPRETERS NOT SUCCESSFUL.
AND ESTABLISHES STANDARDS BY
WHICH TEMPORARY INTERPRETERS
COULD BE UTILIZED AND SMALL CAME
CLAIMS PROCEEDINGS.
I HAVE --
SOME WITNESSES.
UP UP WANT ONE THING BEFORE WE
GO THE WITNESSES UP.
I JUST WANTED TO STATE THAT THE
THE PROCEDURAL AND RICK
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL SUNSET.
IN A JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH IS AN AMENDMENT.
THAT WE ACCEPTED BUT IT'S ALSO
SOMETHING I I THINK WILL ALLOW
US TO REACH OUR GOALS IN THE
INTERIM.
BY THEN I THINK THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WILL WILL.
NOT ONLY IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM
THAT'LL GIVE THEM TIME TO EXPAND
IT AS WELL AND GET THE
INTERPRETERS INTO THE SYSTEM
THAT CURRENTLY ARE NOT THERE.
IT'LL TAKE AWHILE BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE WILL NEED
WHAT WE'VE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS.
IT'S PROGRAM IS FULLY IN PLACE
[inaudible]
SO -- WILL
GO GO TO OUR MISTER CHAIR --
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE --
TO KEY WITNESSES OUT TO WATCH
THIS BILLS --
THAT THE NEED FOR THIS BILL WE
HAVE ANDY LIPPMAN BOMB.
REPRESENTING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
HAVE LEXI HOWARD.
THE ARE THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA JUDGE
ASSOCIATION HERE TO SPEAK ON THE
MERITS AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE ALRIGHT MY NAME IS ANDY
LEVON VON THANK YOU OF MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I A WORK FOR JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US TODAY.
UNDER CURRENT LAW AS SENATOR WAS
SO SAID THERE REALLY ISN'T
CLARITY WHETHER SMALL CLAIMS ARE
ACTUALLY PROCEEDINGS FOR THE
PURPOSES.
OF A INTERPRETER SERVICES AND SB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD CLARIFY
THAT.
THIS LACK OF CLARITY HAS
RESULTED IN A PATCHWORK OF
INFORMAL AN INCONSISTENT
PRACTICES IN THE ARENA OF
INTERPRETERS FOR SMALL CLAIMS
LITIGANTS.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE PROVIDES
A STATEWIDE CONSISTENT APPROACH
TO PROVIDING INTERPRETERS TO
SMALL CLAIMS LITIGANTS.
CURRENTLY THERE'S AN UNFORTUNATE
SHORTAGE OF INTERPRETERS
ESPECIALLY IN LANGUAGES OTHER
THAN SPANISH.
SO S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD
ENSURE THAT A QUARTER UNDERTAKES
DUE DILIGENCE TO FIND AN
INTERPRETER IN ANY LANGUAGE.
AND PROVIDES A SENATOR WAS SO
SAID A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
FOR THAT LITIGANTS.
IF AN INTERPRETER CANNOT BE
FOUND.
BUT THAT LITIGATE WOODS.
WOULD SUFFER UNDUE HARDSHIP IF
THE PRECEDING HAD TO BE DELAYED --
OUR EXPERIENCE IS UP
UNFORTUNATELY THAT MANY
LITIGANTS AREN'T GOING TO RETURN
TO COURT IF THEIR DAY IN COURT
IS DELAYED.
WHILE WE AT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ON THROUGHOUT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH WOULD LOVE TO SEE FULL
AVAILABILITY OF LANGUAGE
INTERPRETATION IN ANY LANGUAGE
FOR ANY NEED THAT A LITIGANT
WOULD HAVE COMING TO COURT.
WERE CERTAINLY JUST NOT THERE
YET SO THE COUNCIL IS PROPOSING
SB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE AS AN
INCREMENTAL STEPS SO THAT WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE THAT AND GET CLOSER
TO IT IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT US WEST
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS LEXI
HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THIS IS THE COURTS WORKING HARD
TO GET THIS RIGHT RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS DRIVE UP.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SING THAT OPPOSITION.
TWENTY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KEVIN BAKER FOR THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION OF
CALIFORNIA --
YOU KNOW IT'S AN ARTICLE OF
FAITH FOR THOSE OF US WHO WORK
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT
WE DON'T MAKE THE PERFECT THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL IS
NOT THE GOOD AND I WANT.
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND ON
THE DEDICATION OF COMMITTEE
COUNSEL NICOLETTE QUE FOUNDED
AMENDMENTS MAKE IT HARDER FOR
THE COURTS. TO DENY AN
INTERPRETER BUT THEY DON'T
PROHIBIT THE COURTS FROM DENYING
INTERPRETER AND THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE ANYONE WHO HAS LOOKED AT
THIS BODY OF LAW [inaudible]
AGREES.
THAT AN INTERPRETER IS REQUIRED.
ALL COURT PROCEEDINGS.
AND THERE'S REALLY NO DISPUTE
ABOUT THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ITSELF.
HAS --
ACKNOWLEDGED.
THAT THAT'S ITS OBLIGATION
[inaudible]
AND THE ACTIVITY ANALYSIS I
THINK REFLECTS THAT LAW SO IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK THAT THE MOOD
IN A JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS OPTED
TO SPONSOR A BILL THAT CONFLICTS
WITH THAT VERY CLEAR OBLIGATION.
ON TEN YEARS AGO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL KILLED EFFORTS --
TO ENACT --
I INTERPRETER EXPANSION AND IN
CIVIL CASES IT USED THE VERY
SAME ARGUMENTS THAT IT'S USING
TODAY.
CATCH IT WOULD BE TOO COSTLY THE
INTERPRETERS AREN'T THERE EXCEPT.
FOR WHAT IF PHONE.
UNDER THOMPSON PRESSURE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE UNDER
BECAUSE THAT INVESTIGATION IS
ONGOING IS THAT IN FACT IT COULD.
AND IN FACT 80% OF THE SMALL
CLAIMS COURTS INDEED ARE ALREADY
PROVIDING.
INTERPRETERS IN SMALL CLAIMS
COURT HAS OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO
SYZYGY DOCUMENT FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL INDICATING THAT
AS OF DECEMBER --
OF TWENTY SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AGO ON THE COURTS WERE
ALREADY PROVIDING --
INTERPRETERS IN SMALL CLAIMS
CASES AND 80% OF THE COURTS SO
THIS ACTUALLY SETS US BACK.
BY SAYING THAT THE COURTS DON'T
HAVE TO DO WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING -- THE
ALLEN.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT.
IT IS CENTER DOESN'T MATTER.
WHAT WE DO WITH THIS BILL THE
LEGISLATURE CAN ENACT ON THIS
STATUTE TO SAY THAT INTERPRETERS
ARE NOT REQUIRE THAT THE
DISCRETIONARY?
ON THAT ON THEY THEY MAY NOT BE
NECESSARY BUT THAT WILL NOT
CHANGE THE STATE'S OUR
OBLIGATIONS --
THE STATE STATUTES CANNOT STAND
IS AN IMPEDIMENT TO COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL CIVIL RIGHTS LAW
WE'VE LEARNED THAT FIFTY YEARS
AGO WHEN SOME OTHER STATES WERE
SLOW TO CHANGE OTHERS OF CIVIL
RIGHTS STATUTES.
AND ARMED WITH ITS IT IS STILL
THE CASE NOW.
ALLEN BUT IT WILL BE UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE I THINK IT SENDS A
MESSAGE [inaudible] TO THE
COURTS ARE NOW DOING THE RIGHT
THING THAT THEY NO LONGER HAVE
TO AND IT SENDS A MESSAGE TO ARM
OUR LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
POPULATIONS THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT SENATOR HUESO SPOKE.
TO ARM WHO WILL NOW --
BE FALSELY TOLD MISLED THAT.
INTERPRETERS ARE NOT REQUIRED
WHEN IN FACT UNDER FEDERAL LAW
THEY ARE --
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT --
AND ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE THE
BILL AS OPPOSED BY --
MANY CIVIL RIGHTS IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS ARE.
DISABILITY RIGHTS DOWN AND LABOR
GROUPS AND WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
NOT NOBLE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
CHRIS RESPONSE WILL ENSURE THAT
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITE.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE INTENT.
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
SO WE CONSIDER YOUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CARE CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS WELL AND I JUST LIKE TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
STAKES.
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN SMALL
CLAIMS COURT ARE SIGNIFICANT FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND PARTICULARLY
THOSE WITH THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
A LANGUAGE CHAU LIMITATIONS FOR
COURT AND SO THE ISSUES THAT
COME BEFORE --
SMALL CLAIMS COURT READ IT FOR
LOW INCOME.
AND INDIVIDUALS CAN BE --
QUITE DEVASTATING --
TO TO THEIR INTERESTS
[inaudible]
THE SUPPORT FULL ACCESS --
TO INTERPRETERS IN SMALL CLAIMS
COURT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SINGLE BRING IT BACK TO
THAT COMMITTEE SO SENATOR AND
AND YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF THAT
THE CONCERNS.
WE'RE I THINK THIS IS IN A POINT
WHERE.
I WAS FOR YOUR BILL TODAY I AM
GONNA LEAVE IT TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO FOR FIGURE OUT WHAT
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO ON THIS.
ON THIS BILL [inaudible]
THAT.
BY PASSING THE STATUTE WE DO NOT
AT ALL UNDERMINE THE OBLIGATION
TO HAVE INTERPRETERS IN
COURTROOMS AND THAT THAT IS.
AS A CIVIL RIGHT BUT WHAT I'M
HOPING THIS BILL DOES IS PROVIDE
A BIT OF A FRAMEWORK FOR COURTS
TO BE ABLE.
TO NAVIGATE THE SITUATION THAT
THEY HAVE BECAUSE THEY THEY THE
COURT'S ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE INTERPRETED INFORMATION IS
AS ACCURATE.
AS IT CAN BE AND UNTIL THE POINT
WHERE WE HAVE SOARED BY COURT
REPORTERS WHICH IS THAT THE
IDEAL IN EVERY COURT INCLUDING
SMALL CLAIMS ACROSS THE BOARD.
WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED OR OR OR
ASK?
FOR I THINK WE NEED TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT FLEXIBILITY TO THE
COURTS HAVE BEEN STANDARDS TO
FOLLOW ENSURING THAT.
INTERPRETIVE SERVER SERVICES ARE
HAPPENING AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
SORE TRIED OF THREAD THIS AS
CAREFULLY AS POSSIBLE AND THAT'S
WHY I'M IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL
TODAY.
BUT THE OPPOSITION RAISES SOME
SOME SIGNIFICANT ISSUES AND THAT
IS HOPEFULLY SOMETHING THAT
THROUGH APPROPRIATE FUNDING AND
THROUGH APPROPRIATE STANDARDS WE
CAN GET.
TO AT SOME POINT AND I THINK WE
ALL NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S HAPPENING
WHEN WE DEAL COURTS FUNDING IT'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT.
AS THIS BODY HAS BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR A LONG IME FOR COURTS
FUNDING AND AS YOU YOURSELF
DISCUSSED.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS SEEN A REAL
INTEREST IN THAT.
FORTUNATELY WERE OFTEN IN A
POSITION WHERE WE FUND THE
COURTS WERE LITERALLY THROWING
MONEY OVER THE WALL HOPING THE
COURTS YOU CAN DO THE RIGHT
THING.
WE DON'T AS A SEPARATE COLECO
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT WE DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE.
CONTROL OR THE REPORTING BACK OF
OUR EXPECTATIONS WHEN WE FUNDS.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE.
SEVERAL BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
SOME ALSO BE THOUGH COURTS WILL
WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH US ON THE
STANDARDS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS VERY INTERESTED IN.
HOW THE COURT FUNDS THE SERVICES
THAT ARE THERE ENSURE THAT WE
ARE GETTING?
GETTING AS MUCH COVERAGE FOR FOR
INTERPRETERS THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF OTHER CATEGORIES THERE AS
WELL SO THAT THEY COURT PROCESS
IS AS PREDICTABLE.
AS SUPPORTIVE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
APPEAR BECAUSE IS STEPHANIE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE ISSUE BEFORE
THEM.
AND ARE ABLE TO THAT TO TRULY
RESOLVE THE JUSTICE PROBLEMS
THAT THEY HAVE THAT THE
COMMUNITIES NEED US. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE.
SO EITHER DRESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AS A AS A PRACTICING ATTORNEY OF
THIRTY FIVE YEARS I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SITTING AS A JUDGE
PRO TEM.
AND COUNTLESS SMALL KID CLAIMS
COULD A CASES.
AND HAVE HAD.
MANY PEOPLE COME BEFORE ME.
WITH THEIR CHILDREN SERVING AS
INTERPRETERS OR THE BROTHER OF
THE SISTER --
I'VE HAD THE OCCASION TO HAVE TO
CORRECT [inaudible]
THE TRANSLATION.
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THE
LANGUAGE.
BUT IF THERE'S SOMEBODY IN
CHINESE OR ANY OTHER LANGUAGE I
WOULD HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT THE
TRANSLATION IS ACCURATE.
I I HAVE TO SAY THAT I AM SO
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED [inaudible]
IN OFFICE IN THIS BUDGET.
THAT WE ARE ALLOWING
[inaudible]
A SEGMENT OF OUR SOCIETY. TO NOT
HAVE EQUAL AND ADEQUATE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE.
IT'S JUST CONTINUES TO HAPPEN WE
HAVE COUNTIES LIKE SALMON A DINO
AND RIVERSIDE WHERE THE
COURTROOMS ARE CLOSING DOWN AND
WE'RE REQUIRING PEOPLE TO DRIVE.
OR TAKE THE BUS OR TO TRAIN FOR
AN HOUR AN HOUR AND A HALF TO
HAVE ACCESS THAT'S NOT EQUAL
ACCESS TO JUSTICE [inaudible]
I WHEN I FIRST SAW THE BILL I
THOUGHT THIS IS WONDERFUL --
FINALLY SMALL CLAIMS.
LITIGANTS WERE ARE GOING TO HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE AN
INTERPRETER --
AND THEN WHEN I READ IT FURTHER
AND BUT REACHED OUT.
TO TO THE PROPONENTS TO YOU
REACHED OUT TO OPPOSITION.
I REALIZE THAT THERE WERE SO
MANY PROBLEMS [inaudible]
WITH.
SORT OF A THE BANDAID APPROACH
SOMETHING THAT'S REQUIRING
SURGERY EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE AN
INTERPRETER. FOR GORE TO GIVE
THEM ACCESS THEY SHOULD HAVE AN
INTERPRETER.
SO.
IT MAKES IT.
EVEN EVEN MORE MORE DIFFICULT I
TELL YOU THE ONE PART.
A OF THE BILL AT THE END AND
IT'S IN THE ANALYSIS THE TOP OF
PAGE --
THREE G..
SO SO THE COURT WILL GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS OF TRYING TO FIND
AN INTERPRETER --
IF THEY DON'T FIND AN
INTERPRETER THEN THEY WILL TRY
TO FIND SOMEONE WHO'S JUST AS
GOOD AS AN INTERPRETER.
BUT THEN SHE SAYS.
IF NO INTERPRETERS APPOINTED THE
COURT SHALL FIND AT THAT
PROCEEDING WITHOUT AN
INTERPRETER.
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE FAIR
ADMINISTRATION [inaudible]
OF JUSTICE [inaudible]
IT'S FRIGHTENING.
THAT WE'RE SAYING THAT THERE IS
A GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT THAT
JUDGE WHOEVER THAT JUDGE MAYBE
SOMETIMES WE HAVE GOOD GOOD
PLAYERS SOMETIMES WE DON'T.
THAT JUDGE IS GOING TO DECIDE
CAN GET YOUR INTERPRETER BUT I'M
DECIDING THAT WE DON'T NEED AN
INTERPRETER LET'S GO FORWARD.
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU SAY
I CAN UNDERSTAND YOU WON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M SAYING.
BUT I WILL IN MY INFINITE WISDOM
DECIDED THIS IS THIS IS JUSTICE
WITH GO FORWARD [inaudible]
I I I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER
IS I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER IS I KNOW THAT --
IT'S IT'S IT'S DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTING --
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN THIS
POSITION --
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTING.
THANK YOU WHAT ELSE [inaudible]
RIGHT SEEING NONE.
SKINNER WAS SO YOU MAY CLOSE
THANKS VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND
FIRST OF ALL --
MISTER CHAIRMAN I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ONE OF THOSE
PROPONENTS THAT WORK HARD.
SUBMITTING LETTERS AND WORK IN
THE BUDGET TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP
OUR COURTS OPEN I'VE BEEN ONE OF
THOSE MEMBERS AS WELL AND IT'S
BEEN.
A HANDFUL OF LEGISLATORS THAT
HAVE TAKEN THAT POSITION NOT ALL
AT AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S WHAT
BRINGS US TO THIS.
THIS POINT TODAY [inaudible]
BAD UP.
I UNDER ALSO UNDERSTAND
[inaudible]
THAT.
SOLUTIONS ARE REALLY HARD TO
COME BY.
AND I KNOW WHY WE EVEN WORK AND
WITH WITH MISTER BAKER --
TO THROUGHOUT THE THE THE THE
THE BILL.
AND HE WAS ON THAT WORKING
COMMITTEE THAT ACTUALLY PROPOSED
CEASE AND THESE [inaudible]
THIS THIS --
THESE--
FIXES [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
I'M OPEN TO AMENDMENTS I'M OPEN
TO SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO MAKE
THIS WORK IN A WAY THAT'S NOT
GONNA BRING OUR COURTS TO A HALT.
HE HIMSELF ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THERE ARE MANY.
SMALL CLAIMS PROCEEDINGS SAID
DON'T HAVE --
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE INTERPRETER
SERVICES AND SOME ARE AT 80% BUT
THAT'S NOT A 100% OUR GOAL IS TO
GET A HUNDRED TO A 100%.
WITHIN THE QUICK CONSTRAINTS
THAT WE HAPPEN.
AT AND I'M I'M OPEN TO
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO GET THERE.
BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE FEW
AND FAR BETWEEN AND WE NEED TO
WE NEED A POLICY AND AND THAT WE
CAN'T HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
SOME HAVE ZERO AND SOME HAVE.
EIGHTY WE WE NEED TO GET TO AS
CLOSE TO A 100% AS WE CAN UNDER
UNDER THE UNDER THAT THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAVE
[inaudible]
BUT SHORT OF FUNDING THEM
APPROPRIATELY WHAT ELSE CAN WE
DO.
SO THIS I THINK MOVES THE BALL
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IT'S GOING TO GET US TO A 100%.
BY BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THAT WE WERE ABLE.
TO WORKING GOOD FAITH TO PROVIDE.
I TOOK BURGER SERVICES WITHOUT
NECESSARILY HALTING OUR SYSTEM
OR CREATING ADDITIONAL.
LITIGATION WITHIN THE SYSTEM
THAT COSTS OF COURSE THE COURTS
MORE MONEY THAT THEY DON'T HAVE.
SO I I APPRECIATE.
BUT YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
TO CHECK A PRAGMATIC APPROACH
AND WORK WITH ME ON THIS BUT I'M
I'M OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS AND WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THEM UP TO UP
TO NOW.
TAX AND THAT'S THE THE THE THE
REAL SHAME.
THAT IF.
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO US.
WHICH WE SHOULD GET THOSE THOSE
SUGGESTIONS IN INTO THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD WITH WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
ON BRIDGING THAT GAP BUT THE THE
THE SOLUTIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
PROPOSED.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SUPPORT MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHIU HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES
[inaudible]
GABRIEL.
THAT HAS FORCE WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL HANK.
AND WERE OUT OF AUTHORS.
YOU LET THE REMAINING SENATORS
KNOW THAT.
BE HAPPY TO HEAR THEIR BILLS
.
RIGHT SENATOR LARA.
WELCOME.
YOU HAVE THREE BILLS WITH US
TODAY.
WHAT WOULD BE OUR PLEASURE SO WE
START WITH --
SIX SIX NINE ONE SIX NINE ONE
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE IT'S NINETY ONE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS S. B. SIX I WANT
EXPLICITLY INCLUDES IMMIGRATION
STATUS OF THE PROTECT THE CLASS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA EQUITY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION ACT --
THIS MEANS ALL PERSONS IN A HAVE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
ENTITLED TO EQUAL RIGHTS AND
FREEDOM FROM SKIMMING NATION THE
BASIS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS DISCUSSING
COMMUNITIES CLARIFY THAT
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS UNLAWFUL
IN POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S SUPPOSED
LANGUAGE TO MAKE CLEAR THAT.
NOTHING IN THE ACTUAL BE
CONSTRUED TO REQUIRE A
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS OFFER
ADMISSION OF OR STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID TO A CERTAIN NOT
IMMIGRANT FOREIGN STUDENTS.
AND WILL TAKE BILLS --
IN COMMITTEE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
WORKED TO ENSURE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO ATTAIN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IN THE SAME WAY OTHER
RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
SO.
OBSTETRICIANS OF HIGHER LEARNING
SHOULD BE AS INCLUSIVE AS
POSSIBLE AND COMMITTED TO THE
EDUCATION OF ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION.
AND YOU KNOW --
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS ABILITY HERE
JUST BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN AFTER ALL THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE CERTAIN --
STAFF FOR ADMISSIONS COUNSELORS
THIS IS THE WAY TO A DISSUADE
STUDENTS FROM ACTUALLY AND
ROLLING UP PARTICIPATING CERTAIN
SERVICES --
OR CERTAIN DEGREE PROGRAMS AND
OUR UNIVERSITY SO THIS BILL WHAT
ABOUT PROHIBIT THAT AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WINS SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
STONE AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARRIED TO ONE I'M THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ASSOCIATE
FOR THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
WHICH REPRESENTS THE NEARLY HALF
A MILLION CSU STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
LARA FOR THE WORK THAT HE'S DONE
ON S. B. SIX NINETY ONE WHICH
WOULD GUARANTEE EQUAL RIGHTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE
HAS HAD A MAJOR IMPACT ON CSU
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
HAVE EMIGRATED TO OUR COUNTRY
DOCUMENTED OR OTHERWISE.
INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO JUST
FOCUS ON SCHOOL THOSE STUDENTS
HAVE HAD TO COPE WITH THE
UNCERTAINTY OF FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW AND CONSISTENT
ATTACKS.
FROM THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
EDUCATION.
HIGHER EDUCATION IT'S THOUGHT OF
AS BEING THE GREAT EQUALIZER A
TOOL THAT MAKES SOCIAL MOBILITY
POSSIBLE.
THIS BENEFIT IS NOT JUST FOR
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS AND ALUMNI
BEFORE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HAVING EDUCATED WORKFORCE IS
WHAT PUTS CALIFORNIA OF ALL
OTHER STATES.
WHICH A STATE HAVE DECIDED
THEY'RE PASS LEGISLATION THAT
THIS BENEFIT SHOULD BE EXTENDED
TO OUR IMMIGRANT.
BUT JUST TO OUR IMMIGRANT
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WE WANT
THEM TO THRIVE IN COLLEGE JUST
LIKE OUR OTHER STUDENTS.
BUT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TASK TO
EXPECT ANY STUDENT.
AND IN THIS CASE ARE IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS TO THRIVE IF THEY'RE
WORRIED.
ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
S. B. SIX NINETY ONE GIVES THE
STUDENTS THE PEACE OF MIND TO
KNOW.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL DO WHAT IT CAN TO PREVENT
THEIR DISCRIMINATION.
AS I'VE MENTIONED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS
LEGISLATION IN PLACE THAT
ENSURES EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
STAY EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
BY PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION
AND GETS PROTECTED CLASSES OF
INDIVIDUALS.
LAST YEAR.
A. B. SIX NINETY NINE BY
SOMEBODY MEMBER O'DONNELL
AMENDED VARIOUS OBJECTS.
VARIOUS EDUCATION CODE
PROVISIONS TO PROHIBIT
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND KATE
THERE TWELVE SCHOOLS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CALIFORNIA'S
EQUITY AND HIGHER EDUCATION ACT
PROVIDES THAT THE STATE WILL
ENSURE EQUAL RIGHTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES AND POST SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
REGARDLESS OF DISABILITY GENDER
GENDER IDENTITY GENDER
EXPRESSION NATIONALITY RACE OR
ETHNICITY RELIGION OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
S. B. SIX NINETY ONE WOULD TAKE.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT COMMONSENSE
AND SIMPLE STEP.
OF ADDING IMMIGRATION STATUS TO
THIS ACT AND CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS AND CATER TWELVE
SCHOOLS AS IT RELATES TO THE
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED NON SUCH
SINGED STUDENTS.
JUST TO SAY IS AN ACTIVE
ADVOCATE FOR ALL CSU STUDENTS
INCLUDING OUR IMMIGRANT
POPULATIONS WE ARE DEAR AYE BUT
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WHILE
WE PRIMARILY PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND THE K.
TWELVE HOUR ARENA.
WE ALSO HAVE CHILDREN WHO
PARTICIPATING CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS AND STUDENTS
WHO ALSO ATTENDS SCHOOL AT SOME
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES SO FOR THESE REASONS.
WE ARE JUST SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR HIS WORK IN THIS AREA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M CATHY RAVEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA ON
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
HOUSE SECOND IT'S QUESTIONS FROM
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
THE STATE AND FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD ERICA [inaudible]
IF YOU SENATE REALLY CLOSE THANK
YOU AGAIN IN THIS DO HIGH
ENVIRONMENT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROTECT OUR DOCUMENTS
INSIDE CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
INVESTED SO MUCH.
I AM AGAIN MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT.
ARE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
ARE ABLE TO APPLY AND ACCESS
SERVICES JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
UP ACCORDING TO THE MEAN TO GET
AND THAT MEANS THAT ARE ABLE TO
APPLY BEYOND AND THAT IS THE
CORE OF THE ISSUE HERE SO
ABSURDLY ASTRID I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE MOST IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS POVERA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU CHIU HOLDEN KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL.
THAT THOSE TWO ZERO CURRENTLY
WILL PUT IT OFF BECAUSE IT GIVES.
ALRIGHT SO S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMENDMENT AND
AMENDMENTS IN CONCEPT DISCUSSING
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ARE.
A RESULT OF SEVERAL ROUNDS OF
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THAT PROPOSED LANGUAGE.
IN THE MOCK UP AMENDMENTS AS
OPPOSED TO BE AMENDED S. B. A
TWENTY FOUR WILL PROHIBIT AT
ENSURE.
FROM CANCELING OR NOT RENEWING
THE HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE POLICY
FOR ONE YEAR AFTER DECLARED
STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR PROPERTY
LOCATED WITHIN A FIRE PERIMETER.
AS DETERMINED BY CAL BY CAL FIRE
WELL WITHIN THE ZIP CODE
ADJACENT TO THE FIRE PERIMETER.
AFTER MASS DESTRUCTION FROM THE
WELFARE OF RE EXAMINE THEIR
EXPOSURE TO RISK IN THOSE AREAS
HER EXTENDING THE ONE YEAR
RENEWAL REQUIREMENT TO HOMES.
IN THE MEDIA THAT SURROUNDING
DISASTER AREAS WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT HOMEOWNERS WHO MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE DAMAGED IN THE DISASTER.
DO NOT HAVE TO STRUGGLE WITH THE
FLAT AND NOT RENEWAL OR
CANCELLATION IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THE EVENT.
THE ONE YEAR RENEWAL REQUIREMENT
PROPOSED A BY THIS BILL CAN ACT
AS A BUFFER TO EXTEND COVERAGE
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL AND MUCH
NEEDED TIME FOR HOMEOWNERS TO
CONSIDER LOOKING. FOR
ALTERNATIVES S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. TO
CONDUCT THE DATA CALL ON ENSURE
LOSS RELATED TO FIGHTERS AND
WILDFIRES THIS WILL BE DONE ON A
PER --
POLICY BASIS TO INFORM US ABOUT
THE GROWING WILDFIRE RISK AND
ANY BEARING THAT HAS ON THE
AVAILABILITY AVAILABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY OF HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE. TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY AND OF THE POLICY IN.
FOR PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF THIS
POLICY INFORMATION AYE THIS BILL
DEEMED --
THAT THE DATA CONFIDENTIAL AND
PROHIBITS DEPARTMENT OF STE
DEPARTMENT STAFF FROM RELEASING
THE INFORMATION AS PART OF A
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
REQUEST AND IN THAT TED HAD
TESTIMONY READ IT TO THE REPORTS
IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS THAT THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE ABOUT.
DEPARTMENTS AVAILABILITY TO
TESTIFY IN CIVIL ACTIONS IS TOO
BROAD S. B. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
CLARIFIES THAT THE PROHIBITION
ON TESTIMONY WILL BE LIMITED TO
TESTIMONY REGARDING TO THE
CONTENTS OF THE REPORTS ONLY.
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
CONDUCTED BY THE SENATE AND
INSURANCE SENATE INSURANCE AND
THE COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND MARCH.
HIGHLIGHTED THE IMMENSE LACK OF
CONCRETE DATA ON WILDFIRES AND
THEIR IMPACT ON RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY INSURANCE.
THIS PROPOSED IN THE CAR IS A
SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
BUT SUPPORT MS CHAIRMAN AND
OTHER MEMBERS PAUL YOU'RE
SHUDDERING IT'S GONNA BE HALF OF
THE SPONSORS PLUS A COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT FOR THE NAPA COUNTY
BOARD SU REGS AS ONE THINKS
THEY'RE LARA.
PRODUIT BILL THAT'S GOING TO
HELP HOMEOWNERS HOMEOWNERS IN
LITERALLY EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALSO AND I
THINK -- THE
OPPOSITION MIGHT BE LOGGED TO DO
THAT BUT THEY'VE BEEN TRYING
HARD I THINK TO GET THERE ON
THIS BILL AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT.
NOTRE DRIVE VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
ROBERT CORRAL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
TYPICALLY FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS WE'VE BEEN AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN ALL THE
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS WANNA
THANK -- THE
SENATOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP HERE --
ECHOES --
WITHOUT SAYING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
A BLAZE YET AGAIN --
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
EVACUATED AS OF THE LAST FEW
DAYS AND SO --
ANYTHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN DO BETWEEN NOW AND IN THE
NEXT TWO MONTHS BEFORE YOU
ADJOURN FOR THE YEAR TO HELP --
FIRE VICTIMS AND FIRE SURVIVORS
OF MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE --
AT WE AGREE WITH THE SENATORS --
AND THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT NARROWING OF THE ISSUE
ON THE DATA CALL AND DRIVE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT PEAK
US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
NUMBERS I'M AARON EVANS ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES PLACE TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL FIX.
JERRY MEMBERS ROSS BUCKLEY WITH
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THE LANGUAGE AND WITH
AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED WILL BE
ROBERT OPPOSITION [inaudible]
IF YOU.
NEARLY DONE WITH MAKE YOU
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF
DOMESTIC INSURANCE COMPANIES
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE.
IN THINKING I THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
AMENDMENTS AND WILL BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR MONTHLY SHALLOW BAD FOR THE
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS WERE
REMOVING OPPOSITION JUST ENTERED
LARA AND STAFFING COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
ISRAEL YES I DO WANT TO THANK
THE THE THE AUTHORS SENATOR LOTT
I THINK THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT INSURANCE ISSUES VERY
SPECIFICALLY --
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT WE HAVE
LEADERSHIP THAT WE LOOK TO THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ISSUES REGARDING
THEIR COVERAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE TREATED --
IT IN A WAY THAT TAKES AWAY
THEIR COVERAGE --
THAT LEAVES THEM WITHOUT ANY
PROTECTION AND I THINK AGAIN
WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE INSURANCE
ISSUES I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
ON THE ISSUE THANK THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LIKE TO MOVE THAT BILL SINCE WE
HAVE THE OPTION.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION
I'LL SECOND IT.
THE MOTION SECOND SENATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE LIKE LAST FOR ABOUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE THOUGH THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
DON'T AYE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU CHIU HOLDEN
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL.
THAT IS TWO ZERO WE WILL PUT
THAT BILL LONG CALL.
AND YOUR THIRD ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B. FORTINO TO
THANK YOU MITCHELL MEMBERS MORE
THAN 40% OF U. S. SHIPPING
CONTAINER.
TRAFFIC FLOW THROUGH THE PORTS
OF LONG BEACH --
ALLEY AND OAKLAND --
PORTRAITS TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE
SOME OF THE HARDEST AND MOST
IMPORTANT JOBS IN OUR ECONOMY
HOLLY THOSE GOODS AWAY FROM
PORTS TO CONTINUE THEIR JOURNEY
TO STORES ACROSS AMERICA.
BILL OF THESE JOBS ARE MORE ARE
MADE EVEN HARDER BY THE MISS
CLASSIFICATION OF EMPLOYEES AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WAIT
STAFF ANY LEGAL DEDUCTIONS THAT
LEAVE PORTRAYS DRIVERS IN THE
CYCLE OF POVERTY.
THE EXPLOITATION IS SO RAMPANT
[inaudible]
FREE THE STATE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS WON MORE THAN
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
JUDGMENTS FOR MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED DUCK DRIVERS NO HIGHER
COURT HAS EVER OVERTURNED ANY OF
THESE AWARD APPEALS.
YET THESE JUDGMENTS RARELY
MATERIALIZE AND WORKERS RARELY
MADE WHOLE AND THIS IS IN PART
BECAUSE PORTAL AGE MORE CARRIERS
QUITE A BUSINESS. TO AVOID
PAYING THEIR OBLIGATIONS AND
TURN UP UNDER A NEW NAME.
S. B. FOURTEEN THE TO ORDER THAT
OUR DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT. TO CREATE A LIST OF
COMPANIES WITH FINAL JUDGMENTS
FOR LABOR VIOLATIONS INCLUDING
WAIT STAFF PHILLY FAILURE TO PAY
TAXES ANY LEGAL DEDUCTIONS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA
TO HOLD RETAILERS AND SHIPPERS
LIABLE WHEN --
THE USE OF MOTOR CARRIERS ON
THIS LIST AFTER MUCH WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION I HAVE MADE
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS.
THAT ADDRESS OPPOSITIONS
CONCERNED ALLOWING FOR A NINETY
DAY PERIOD FOR A CUSTOMER TO
TERMINATE AN EXISTING AGREEMENT
WITH THE COMPANY ON THE WEBSITE.
OR THE END OF THE CONTRACT
WHICHEVER IS SHORTER THIS
INSURERS INSURERS DELIVERIES ARE
NOT AFFECTED --
DURING BUSY SHIPPING TIMES AT
ALSO ESTABLISHING A REGULAR
REGULAR FREQUENCY OF UPDATES OF
THE WEBSITE BY THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT. TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR CUSTOMERS
WHEN THEY EXECUTE CONTRACTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU WINSTON SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS VERY BROAD
AND BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
ON AS THE OLD SAYING GOES
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED [inaudible]
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT IN THE PORT AREA THIS IS
BEEN A PROBLEM FOR DECADES.
SO LARGELY IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE
ADEN THAT ARE TOLD THAT THEY ARE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THEY
DON'T GO INTO THE TRUCKING.
THEY DON'T HOLD OPERATING
AUTHORITY THEY DON'T HAVE
BUSINESS LICENSES THEY DON'T
HAVE THEY OWNER THEY OWN A TRUCK
[inaudible]
TRACTOR ITSELF THAT OFTENTIMES
THE LEAST FROM THESE TRUCKING
COMPANIES CREATING A KIND OF
DEBT BONDAGE ACTUATION IT'S
REALLY BAD [inaudible]
BOB.
YEAH I WAS SENATOR POINTED OUT
THERE HAVE BEEN.
HUNDREDS OF JUDGMENTS AGAINST
THESE COMPANIES THERE'S AT LAST
WE LOOKED TWO HUNDRED AND SIX
TRUCKING COMPANIES WITH UNPAID
UNSATISFIED FINAL JUDGMENT
[inaudible]
ON THE OWING FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S GONE UP A LITTLE
AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
AMOUNT IS [inaudible] FOR
JUDGMENTS TEEN BY PRIVATE
COUNSEL.
ON OR JUDGMENTS THAT ARE OWED.
TO THE STATE AS TAX LIENS FOR
FAILURE TO PAY UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TAX ETCETERA.
FAILURE TO PROVIDE WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND SO FORTH SO IT
COULD BE MUCH BIGGER.
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT CREATES A
SITUATION WHERE TRUCKING
COMPANIES THAT ARE TRYING
[inaudible] TO TO TO ARM TO
ADHERE TO THE LAW CANNOT COMPETE.
IT AND SO THE COMPETITION IS A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
ILLEGALITY.
ON WHAT WE REALIZED IS THAT WE
HAD TO INVOLVE THE SHIPPER.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT.
TROLL FOR TRANSPORTATION.
AND IT'S BEEN TOO EASY FRANKLY
FOR THEM TO JUST.
LOOK THE OTHER WAY OUT OF SIGHT
OUT OF MIND WAS SHOCKED SHOCKED
THAT SUCH CONDUCT IS OCCURRING.
NO GAMBLING IS OCCURRING IN OUR
CASINO THAT SORT OF RESPONSE AND
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE IT'S NOT
THEIR BUSINESS IN A IN A CERTAIN
SENSE BUT IT'S WHAT WE NOW HAVE
TO DO IS MAKE IT.
THEIR BUSINESS [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
CREATES JOINT LIABILITY.
ONLY AND I I WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND HOW HARD YOU WOULD
HAVE TO WORK AS A SHIPPER TO GET
JOINT LIABILITY.
A TRUCKING COMPANY APPEARS ON
THIS LIST WITH A FINAL ON
APPEALABLE JUDGMENT.
IF YOU THEN.
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS WITH
THAT TRUCKING COMPANY.
AND ONLY THEN IF THE TRUCKING
COMPANY VIOLATES THE LAW
SUBSEQUENTLY NOT FOR THEIR PAST
CONDUCT BUT SUBSEQUENTLY WHILE
THEY ARE.
CARRYING FREIGHT FOR YOU.
YOU ARE LIABLE FOR THE PERIOD OF
TIME JOINTLY LIABLE FOR THE
PERIOD OF TIME.
THAT YOU CARRY THAT FREIGHT SO
ANY SHIPPER.
WITH A SHIPPING CLERK THAT LOOKS
AT THIS THIS LIST ONCE A MONTH
CAN AVOID COMPLETELY AVOID JOINT
LIABILITY BY TELLING A TRUCKING
COMPANY WERE TERMINATING OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOU.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HIRE YOU I TO
GET YOURSELF OFF THE LIST
MAGNITUDE ROCCA I'M SORRY SO --
THE BILL FOR US I APOLOGIZE.
HE'S A MUCH ANYWAY WE URGENT YE
VOTE WE THINK THIS IS UNFAIR
BILL WE REMOVE THE OPPOSITION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION.
WE WORKED WITH THE OPPONENTS AND
ON WE URGE DRIVE UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT HIS PLEASE.
YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CLARK HERMAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE TOLL GROUP --
TOLD GROUP OPERATES A
COMPREHENSIVE GLOBAL LOGISTICS
THAT WORK ACROSS TWELVE HUNDRED
LOCATIONS IN MORE THAN FIFTY
COUNTRIES.
WERE SUBSIDIARY OF JAPAN POST --
WE GLOBALLY RECOGNIZED THAT OUR
MOST VALUABLE ASSET IS OUR
EMPLOYEES AND WE TAKE THE SAME
APPROACH HERE IN THE U. S. --
WHERE WE OPERATE EXTENSIVELY ON
BOTH THE EAST COAST AND WEST
COAST PARTICULARLY IN THE PORTS
OF LONG BEACH AND LOS ANGELES --
WE HAVE --
WE OPERATE IN THE TRADE MARKET
IN THAT WAY IT WON'T REACH FOR
OVER TEN YEARS WE CURRENTLY
EMPLOY OVER EIGHTY DRIVERS WERE
TRYING TO SIGNIFICANTLY GROW OUR
BUSINESS.
CONSISTENT WITH OUR CORPORATE
VALUES WE OPERATE AN ASSET
BUSINESS MODEL WITH EMPLOYEE
DRIVERS WE ALSO HAVE ADOPTED A
SET OF CORPORATE PRINCIPLES.
THAT INCLUDES WORKING
COOPERATIVELY WITH TRADE UNIONS
OF THE COUNTRIES WHERE WE
OPERATE.
IN THE U. S. WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
CONSTRUCTIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS.
THE TRADE MARKET IS VERY VERY
COMPETITIVE AS THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED. EIGHT HUNDRED
COMPANIES AND ACTS ACCESO A
HUNTER COPPED A COMPANIES
OPERATING JUST IN THE PORTS OF
LA LONG BEACH.
IT IS A VERY CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT IN NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE CHALLENGES ARE MADE EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT WHEN WE MUST
COMPETE WITH A VAST ARRAY OF
TRUCKING COMPANIES THAT DO NOT
ABIDE BY THE SAME RULES.
UNFORTUNATELY IT SEEMS THAT MANY
COMPANIES WE COMPETE AGAINST-OPERATE UNDER AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR BUSINESS MODEL THAT
RUNS AFOUL OF CALIFORNIA LABOR
LAWS.
RESULTING IN UNACCEPTABLE
WORKING CONDITIONS FOR MANY PORT
DRIVERS WHO CANNOT EARN A LIVING
WAGE.
IT ISN'T THIS HEARTENING THAT
THERE SEEMS TO BE SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS FOR THAT YOUR AGENT
HISTORY TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE
WITH CALIFORNIA'S LABOR LAWS.
WE DO NOT MISS CLASSIFY OUR
DRIVERS WE OPERATE WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THE CONFINES
OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
WHAT TOLL AND OTHER COMPANIES
WITH AN ASSET BASE MODEL WHO
EMPLOY DRIVERS IN THE JURY'S
INDUSTRY WANT AND WHAT THE
MARKETS WANT?
IS A FAIR AND LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD.
WHERE THE RULES ARE CLUES PARA
CLEARLY DELINEATED WITH THE
REFEREES ARE CONFIDENT AND WHERE
WE KNOW THAT THE GAME IS NOT
RIGGED?
THE PLAYING FIELD IN THE TRADE
INDUSTRY IS CURRENTLY CURRENTLY
OPERATING ON A DISTORTED SLOPE
WHERE COMPANIES LIKE TOLLS ARE
AT A LOSS BLOWOUT LOWER AND
STRUGGLING TO CAN MEET.
AGAINST ARTIFICIALLY LOW LABOR
COSTS IN SPITE OF OUR BEST
EFFORTS THE STATE CANNOT ENFORCE
THE CURRENT REGULATORY SCHEME.
THE SLACK OF ENFORCEMENT IN A
FACTORY IT'S AN ILLEGAL SUBSIDY
TO COMPANIES THAT OPERATE
OUTSIDE THE LAW.
AND RELEVANT COURT DECISIONS
THIS IS.
POSITION IN OUR VIEW.
THERE IS LABOR INSTABILITY IN
THE PORTS IN THE FORM OF CLASS
ACTION LAWSUITS INFREQUENT WORK
STOPPAGES.
DUE TO THE FACT THAT HUNDREDS OF
COMPANIES ARE CONTINUING TO
OPERATE ILLEGITIMATELY IN THE
DRAINAGE MARKETPLACE.
THIS INSTABILITY PREVENTS
LEGITIMATE DRAINAGE COMPANIES
SUCH AS TALL FROM OPERATING ITS
BUSINESSES EFFICIENTLY.
WE AN OTHER DRAINAGE COMPANIES
SUPPORT THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY
ASK TO SEE.
THE STATE TO ADOPT THIS
LEGISLATION WHICH CREATE A
BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH
THE TRADES INDUSTRY IS
CHARACTERIZED BY LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD.
IN WHICH ETHICAL COMPANIES SUCH
AS TALL ARE ALLOWED TO COMPETE
EFFECTIVELY IN THE PORTS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
GOOD MORNING TURN NUMBERS
NUCLEAR CREDIT WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN NO TO
ALL BE BRIEF.
AN RTC STANDS AT THE THOUSANDS
OF MISCLASSIFIED PORT RAGE TRUCK
DRIVERS NOT ONLY TO CORRECT THIS
AGREE JUST PRACTICE OF LABOR
EXPLOITATION.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR AIR QUALITY IN THE SOUTH
COAST.
ENERGY THROUGH BEEN WORKING TO
CLEAN UP DIESEL ANOTHER
POLLUTION AT THE PORTS OF LA AND
LONG BEACH SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TO PORTS AND THE
THOUSANDS OF TRUCKS THAT SERVE
THEM REMAIN ONE OF THE LARGEST
SOURCES OF SMOG FORMING IN
PARTICULAR POLLUTION IN THE
REGION.
AND WHILE WE'VE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN BOTH EMISSIONS AND
HEALTH RISKS IN THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES.
TRUCKS THAT WERE BOUGHT NEW AND
THREE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
EVENTUALLY WEAR OUT AN UNDERPAID
DRIVERS ARE UNABLE TO REPLACE OR
REPAIR THE EMISSION CONTROL
SYSTEMS.
IN THEIR VEHICLES WE BELIEVE S.
B. FORTINO TO AS BOTH CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL LAW AND HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BRING MARKET FORCES
TO BEAR.
AT HELP STOP THE DANGEROUS
UNDERPAYMENT PORT TRUCK DRIVERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
CLEAN PORTS AND SUSTAINABLE JOBS
GO HAND IN HAND AND WE STAND AND
WHAT ARE AYE LABOR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS TODAY AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT HONESTY FORTUNATE TO
THINKS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT YOU
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MAX PARA MATHIS CITY OF LONG
BEACH IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ONE
COSPONSORED BUILD A STRONG
SUPPORT.
KRIS CONNOR OBSERVED THE OWNER
OPERATOR INDEPENDENT DRIVERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
.
MORNING CHAIRMEN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME FLOOR CURTIS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE I'M OUR CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL WE OBVIOUSLY
DON'T HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
POLICY WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AS BUT OUR
OVERALL CONCERN IS FOR THE
RETAILERS ARE TO BE.
UTILIZING THESE PART TRIED
INDUSTRY MOTOR CARRIERS OF FOR
THEIR NOTICE --
ABOUT INDIVIDUALS ON THE LIST SO
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT WOULD
REQUIRE ANY RETAILER ANYONE
REALLY USING A PARTRIDGE TO GO
ON TO THE WEBSITE AND CHECK ONCE
A MONTH OR MORE OFTEN.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ENTITY
TO ISN'T ON THE LIST HOWEVER.
THESE RETAILERS USE BROKERS THE
USE AGENTS THEY USE FREIGHT
CARRIERS AND IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE WHO IS THEY'RE GOING
TO USE AS A MOTOR CARRIER THE
THINGS HAPPEN QUICKLY I'M IN
CASE SOMEONE CAN'T CARRY THEIR
CARGO AND SO THEN THEY HAVE TO
FIND SOMEONE ELSE IN A QUICK
MATTER. TO DO THAT AND SO THAT'S
WHERE CONCERN IS IS REALLY IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHO THEY'RE UTILIZING
BECAUSE THESE INDIVIDUALS AS THE
OTHER TESTIFIED GO UNDER
DIFFERENT NAMES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
I'M SO REALLY THEY DO HAVE THE
PRIOR KNOWLEDGE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE AND
UTILIZING THESE COMPANIES THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE UTILIZING THESE
COMPANIES THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH NOT UTILIZING THESE
COMPANIES.
BUT THEY REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT SOMEHOW
SURPRISED I AM I KNOW THAT THE
OTHER SPONSORS AND OTHERS HAVE
DISCUSSED A BILL OF LADING THEN
AND OTHER ISSUES TO HOOK ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE THIS NOTICE.
AND HOWEVER AGAIN THERE'S THAT
WE'RE STILL LOOKING INTO HOW
QUICKLY THAT IT'S PROVIDED TO
THE ENTITY CITY REALLY CAN GET
OUT OF THE THINGS IN AN
EFFICIENT MATTER BECAUSE A LOT
OF THESE RETAILERS ARE UNDER
TIGHT TIMELINES FOR EXAMPLE OVER
THE HOLIDAY SEASON AND THINGS
LIKE THAT WHERE.
THEY'RE FINDING PEOPLE LAST
MINUTE TO CARRY THESE RATES AS
WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE FROM PROPER NOTICE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'VE BEEN
ALLTOMORROW BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION.
BOMB WE ARE ALIGNING OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE CHAMBER
MISS CURTIS JUST PROVIDED --
AT WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
IN THE BILL UP TO THIS POINT BUT
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS THAT --
THAT THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER HAS
EXPRESSED YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
KURT BLACKBURN ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN STATES TRACK ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SINGLE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THERE IS THE I WILL SECOND THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR YOU MAKE LOVE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN A
RETAILERS HAVE PLAYED --
UNDER VERY IMPORTANT PART AND
USE OUR INFLUENCE IN THE GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN. TO ADDRESS SHOOK
SWEATSHOPS AND LABOR IN OTHER
COUNTRIES THEY CAN USE OUR
MARKET POWER TO COMBAT POVERTY
WAGES HERE IN AMERICA.
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS
TO DO ACTUALLY WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK THE RETAILERS.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE --
BEEN WORKING WITH US THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR ONE OF THE HEALTH ONE
SO I DON'T WANNA.
ADD JUST --
FORGET THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SO
THEY'VE COME TO THE TABLE HAVE
BEEN -- BEEN
ABLE TO WORK WITH DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE GETTING AT SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AIBO.
THANK YOU MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU CHIU HOLDEN KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL.
I GUESS STAYS HERE A LITTLE OVER
A LONG CALL [inaudible]
IF YOU.
I SAW SENATOR JACKSON COME
THROUGH SHE'S CLOSE BY.
HE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
[inaudible]
SENATOR JOHN [inaudible]
WELCOME.
ELECTION GOING ON PART OF I CAN
WELL IMAGINE.
YOU HAVE A FEW OF JUST A FEW
BILLS TODAY DO I TWO YEARS
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO PRESENT
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE WEBSITE TO START IF I
MAY WITH A TWENTY SIX THAT WORKS
THAT'S OUR ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THERE'S A MOTION I WILL SECOND
THAT THANK YOU --
WITH THE MOTION AYE WONDERS AYE
MY GETTING A MESSAGE I SHOULD
MAKE IT SHORT AND SWEET --
BUT LET ME JUST.
INDICATE TO YOU AND TO THE
MEMBERS.
WELL I THINK IT'S JUST A JUST A
FEW OF US ARE RIGHT NOW
YESTERDAY SO --
BUT FOR FOR ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE
INTERESTED THIS IS.
A I THINK A A REALLY.
CRITICAL TIME I IN A CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY --
TO START OPENING UP ONE OF THE
LAST BASTIONS OF WHITE MALE
DOMINATION AND THAT IS THE C.
SUITE.
AND OUR CORPORATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND TO AND IN THIS COUNTRY --
THERE ARE OTHER NATIONS WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY REQUIRE WOMEN ON
CORPORATE BOARDS.
THEY DO SO BECAUSE WOMEN ADD
TREMENDOUS A BENEFIT TO
COMPANIES IN TERMS OF
PROFITABILITY PRODUCTIVITY
INNOVATION.
A WORKPLACE --
OF HARMONY IF YOU WERE.
AND THE RESEARCH IS VERY CLEAR --
THAT. FOR WHATEVER REASONS AND I
KNOW THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT CAUSATION AND WHAT HAVE
YOU BUT CLEARLY HAVING WOMEN
HAVING 52% OF THE POPULATION
REPRESENTED ON CORPORATE BOARDS
WHEN WOMEN REPRESENT. 70% OF THE
CONSUMERS I IS A GOOD THING AND
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE NOT.
OF BEEN ABLE TO MOVE THAT A
NEEDLE AT ALL.
WITH THE RESOLUTION I DID A FEW
YEARS AGO URGING COMPANIES ARE
TO ADD WOMEN TO THEIR CORPORATE
BOARDS AND WE MADE.
A NO PROGRESS WITH THAT THIS IS
A MEASURE THAT WILL REQUIRE.
THAT -- IF A
BOOK BY TWENTY NINETEEN THE
BOARD HAS TO HAVE A WOMAN ON IT
IT BEING STUD THAT YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY KICK ANYBODY OFF
THAT YOU WILL ADD A POSITION WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT.
SATISFIES FROM THE
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION --
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHERE THIS WOULD
OR WOULDN'T GO BUT I THINK IT'S
A WORTHY ENOUGH LEGISLATION THAT
WE SHOULD.
A FORCE OF FORCED THE A
DISCUSSION AND IF IT DOES END UP
IN THE CALL COURTS MAKE THAT
DECISION BUT CLEARLY WOMEN HAVE
BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN
CORPORATE AMERICA FOR FAR TOO
LONG.
AYE IT'S TIME WE CHANGE THAT WE
KNOW THAT WHEN YOU ADD WOMEN TO
PORTS THAT THE CULTURE CHANGES
AND IT IS TIME WE CHANGE THE
CULTURE WHETHER IT'S FOR
PROFITABILITY WHETHER IT IS TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT --
WHETHER IT IS --
TO IMPROVE THE INNOVATIVE --
QUALITIES AVE PARTICULAR COMPANY
THIS IS A WAY TO GET THEIR AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A MEASURE --
THAT WILL MOVE THE BALL FORWARD
AND BE BENEFICIAL NOT ONLY IN
TERMS OF EQUITY BUT IN TERMS OF
ECONOMICS AND TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
AT THANKS TO HOSPITAL MORNING
BETSY BURKE OF WORK READ AIR I
AM PAST PRESIDENT OF NOVEL
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS I OWN A
RETAINED EXECUTIVE SEARCH FIRM
IN LOS ANGELES.
WHERE WE'VE DONE MANY BOARD
SEARCHES OVER THE YEARS AND I'M
ALSO CEO OF TWENTY TWENTY WOMEN
ON BOARDS WHICH IS A CAMPAIGN TO
ENCOURAGE AND COLLABORATE WITH
COMPANIES TO HELP THEM FIND MORE
WOMEN? FOR CORPORATE BOARDS THE
ISSUE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH HERE IS THE PROBLEM OF
SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
THERE ARE MANY IN FACT THOUSANDS
OF QUALIFIED WOMEN NOT ONLY
EXECUTIVE EXPERIENCE WOMEN BUT
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN CERTIFIED BY
UCLA BY STANFORD AND OTHER OF
THE INSTITUTIONS OUTSIDE OR
CALIFORNIA BORDERS.
BUT WHO HAVE BEEN CERTIFIED AS
QUALIFIED FOR SERVING ON
CORPORATE BOARDS AND THEY ALSO
PAID BUT THE SIGNIFICANT MONEY
FOR THAT CERTIFICATION.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THERE ARE
TOO FEW SEATS.
ON CORPORATE BOARDS AND THE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OPENINGS ARE
RARE A CORPORATION MIGHT HAVE A
AN OPENING EVERY FIVE YEARS
DOESN'T HAPPEN OFTEN.
BUT THERE'S A WAVE OF
RETIREMENTS CHO BECAUSE BABY
BOOMER MEN AND WOMEN WHO'VE BEEN
ON PORTS FOR TWENTY THIRTY FORTY
YEARS ARE RETIRING AS WE KNOW
BABY BOOMERS ARE RETIRING IN
DROVES.
RIGHT NOW IN IN ALL IN NO
INDUSTRIES AND FUNCTIONS SO THE
FACT THAT THERE WILL BE OPENINGS
WE WANT TO WITH THIS BILL MAKE
SURE THAT THE OPENINGS ARE.
A ALLOWED TO BRING IN WOMEN.
AND ALSO THE PROBLEM WITH THE
BUCK CORPORATE BOARD SEATS AS
YOU MAY KNOW.
THAT -- AND
WE KNOW IN THE SEARCH BUSINESS
THAT THE CANDIDATES CONSIDERED
IF THERE'S NOTA COMPETITION
LIKE A JOB.
LINED UP FOR YOU LINE UP THE
BEST CANDIDATES IN THE BEST ONE
IS CHOSEN THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT
WORKS.
THE BOARD'S NOMINATING COMMITTEE
GIVES US SEARCH FIRMS A LIST OF
FIVE TO SEVEN POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES THEY KNOW AND LIKE
AND FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND THEN THEY HAVE SEARCH FIRMS
WEATHER'S KORN FERRY SPENCER
STUART BURKE AMER CLAYTON THEY
HAVE SEARCH FIRMS VET THOSE
CANDIDATES ABOUT THEIR
BACKGROUNDS AT CEDRAS.
AND ABOUT THE OF ANY ERA BOARDS
THEY'VE SERVED ON IN THE PAST
ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED AND THEN
WE BRING A REPORT BACK TO THE
NOMINATING COMMITTEE AND THEY
DECIDE WHICH ONE PERSON.
THEY'RE GOING TO INTERVIEW THEY
DON'T INTERVIEW THREE OR FOUR
THE ONLY INTERVIEW ONE AND IF
THAT IF ALL WORKS OUT IN AREN'T
ANY CONFLICTS OF DATES.
THAT PERSON IS BROUGHT ON THE
BOARD IT'S AMANDA AND MOST
LIKELY OF NOAH ANGLO MAN BECAUSE
THAT IS WHO THE OTHER CEOS ON
THE BOARD ALREADY KNOW AND TRUST
AND FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH.
SO IT'S JUST A ILLOGICAL THING
THAT HAS ENDED UP WITH SORT OF
DE FACTO DISCRIMINATION.
SO FOR YOUR JUDICIARY PURPOSES
WE'VE HAD DATA INPUT BY LEGAL
COUNSEL AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
IN THE COURTS AND HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE RAPPER.
I SHALL THAT WE NEED TO PROVE
AND WE KNOW WE CAN A COMPELLING
INTEREST FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO PROVE THAT THE
INTERNAL AFFAIRS DOCTRINE DOES
NOT MATTER COUNT IN THIS AREA.
AND NUMBER THREE THAT FOR
CONSTITUTIONALITY AND EQUAL
PROTECTION BY THE LAW THAT
WEEKEND APPROVE STRICT SCRUTINY
WITH ALL OF THE OTHER --
EFFORTS THAT WE'VE TRIED TO
BRING FORWARD FOR THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO IMPROVE
INCLUDING THE RESOLUTION THAT
THE SENATOR PUT FORWARD FIVE
YEARS AGO.
AND THAT WE CAN PROVE THAT THE
THAT THE SELECTION PROCESS AND
THE THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
NARROWLY TAILORED.
SO THAT IT'S NOT JUST GENDER
THAT IS THE QUALIFIER FOR
PUTTING THOSE THAT CANDIDATE
WOMEN ON THE BOARD IT IS ALL THE
OTHER OF EXPERIENCE THAT THEY
HAVE IN FUNCTIONAL CATEGORIES
THAT ARE NOT ON THAT CORPORATE
BOARD.
SO WITH THAT I SAY THANK YOU
SENATOR AND I ALSO WANTED TO
COMPLEMENT YOUR STAFF BECAUSE
THEY DID A GREAT JOB ON A VERY
COMPLICATED TOPIC.
A OUTLINING WHAT THE POTENTIAL
ISSUES MIGHT BE THANK THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR AND MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU --
FOR HEARING US TODAY MY NAME
DALY SAID BARRETT I'M A
PROFESSOR OF CORPORATE
GOVERNANCE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO AND I HAVE CONDUCTED
RESEARCH ON CORPORATE BOARDS IN
ADVISED CORPORATE BOARD MEMBERS
AND INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS ON
BOARD EFFECTIVENESS IMPORT
COMPETITION FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS NOW.
I CONDUCTED THE STUDY OF
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES AND THE
PREVALENCE OF FEMALE DIRECTORS
ON THOSE BOARDS AND I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH ANY STATISTICS
THAT YOU MAY BE INTERESTED IN
AND ASKING ABOUT --
THE OVERALL GIST IS THAT --
25% OF THE COMPANIES
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE NO WOMEN ON THEIR BOARDS
AND AMONG ALL THE CORPORATE
DIRECTORS SERVING ON THE BOARDS
OF CALIFORNIA CORPORATIONS ONLY.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN POINT 5% OF THEM
ARE FEMALE COMPARED 216% ACROSS
THE NATION SO WHERE BEHIND THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY ON THIS
ISSUE -- AND
WE HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA WILL
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD ON
THIS ISSUE INSTEAD --
THIS BILL IT'S IMPORTANT TO TO
POINT OUT I FEEL THAT THE BILL
AND APPLIES ONLY TO PUBLICLY
TRADED COMPANIES AND COMPANIES
THAT HAVE.
GONE THROUGH THE INITIAL PUBLIC
OFFERING PROCESS AND TAKEN ON
CAPITAL FROM THE INVESTING
PUBLIC.
IN TURN HAVE AN OBLIGATION.
THEY HAVE OBLIGATIONS THAT ARE
ESTABLISHED BY CORPORATE LAW
INCLUDING DISCLOSURE BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE OBLIGATIONS TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION.
THE NEEDS OF THE INVESTING
PUBLIC OF THEIR EMPLOYEES AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
IN WHICH THERE CAN THEIR COMPANY
OPERATES AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS --
AND SO I CAN GO INTO MANY
DETAILS ON ANY POLICIES AND
PRACTICES BUT I WON'T IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME.
BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
REGARDING STATISTICS PORT BOARD
PRACTICES AS WE GO THROUGH
DISCUSSION THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND PLEASE.
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
LOOKED THANK YOU BLESSEDNESS
WAYS.
THANK YOU OF KAREN AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS AND STAINS I AM
PRESIDENT OF NOVEL CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT THE TWELVE CHAPTERS OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND A BY PROXY THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS ACROSS THE STATE NOVEL IS
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
AND IT IS BECAUSE WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE QUALIFIED --
THERE ARE MANY MANY WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
QUALIFIED TO SERVE ON BOARDS BUT
THE DOORS ARE CLOSED FOR EVEN
CONSIDERATION FOR THE MOST PART
AS YOU'VE SEEN --
THE PROOF IS IN THE PUDDING
THOUGH THE I'M THE AND BILL THAT
WAS PASSED OR VIA.
WHAT IS ILLUSION THE RESOLUTION
THAT WAS PASSED HAD NO EFFECT
AND IT IS TIME THAT WOMEN BE
CONSIDERED FOR THESE ROLES?
IF YOU EVEN CONSIDER THAT 1% OF
THE WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA COULD BE QUALIFIED --
THAT WOULD BE WELL MORE THAN
WOULD BE NEEDED TO FILL THE SUN
EVEN A HALF OF A PERCENT.
A WOULD BE WELL MORE THAN WOULD
BE NEEDED SO WE URGE YOUR VOTE
PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
FEEDSGIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION YES ARC AFTERNOON
GORE GOOD MORNING LAURIE CAMERON
BEHALF OF SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA'S FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS INCLUDING MANY MANY
WOMEN WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE MUST BURKE WITH CLOUDY
CALIFORNIANS DRUGS.
GOOD MORNING MAUREEN LANE OWNER
OF OUR STRATEGIES A CONSULTING
FIRM HERE IN SACRAMENTO ON IT ON
THE BOARD OF NOT BOTH SACRAMENTO
VALLEY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
THANK YOU IN ON US IN SUPPORT.
SING NONE THEIR OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE HERE
AND IN OPPOSE POSITION ON S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY SIX WHILE WE DO
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WHICH IS TO
CREATE MORE DEBATE.
DIVERSITY I AM FOR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WE DISAGREE IN THE
MANNER IN WHICH AB ARE S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY SIX AND SIX TO
ACCOMPLISH ITS GOAL GENDER IS AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF DIVERSITY.
AND W. M. WHILE WE WANT TO
PROTECT OTHER CLASSIFICATIONS
RECOGNIZED UNDER THE LAWS AND
REGARDING DIVERSITY AND WE FEEL
THAT THIS BILL WOULD POTENTIALLY
PUT GENDER.
AND ELEVATED AS A PRIORITY OVER
OTHER ASPECTS OF DIVERSITY AND
CALIFORNIA CONCEPT EDITION WE
HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES ON
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION STATES
THAT A PERSON MAY NOT BE
DISQUALIFIED FROM ENTERING OR
PURSUING A BUSINESS.
PROFESSION VOCATION OR
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF SEX RACE
CREED COLOR NATIONAL ORIGIN OR
ETHICS.
AND AND ARE CONCERNED WITH THIS
IS THAT IT COULD POTENTIALLY
DISPLACED WELL WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS ALLOWED FOR
ADDITIONAL SPACES TO BE ON
BOARDS AND IT DOES REQUIRE THAT
ALMOST 50% FOR A REPORT WOULD
HAVE.
OF 50% OR MORE OF WOMEN ON THE
BORDER SORRY AND IF THERE'S
THREE THEN AT LEAST I'M ONE AND
AND THAT IF THEY'RE SAD FOR THE
AT LEAST.
TWO SO IN SOME INSTANCES 50% AND
ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL BOARD
PLACEMENT AND WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH THE DISPLACEMENT OF
QUALIFIED MALES I'M AND OTHER M.
ETHNIC ENTITIES THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE HAVE OF UP A PLACE AT
THE BOARD.
AND ADDITIONALLY BY WAY OF
EXAMPLE I'M HERE TODAY THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ALONE
ARE NOT 50% FEMALE AND AGAIN
THIS IS BY WAY OF EXAMPLE JUST
TO SHOW HOW HARD THESE KIND OF
THINGS ARE.
AND WE WOULD BE IMPOSING
SOMETHING ON THE PRIVATE
ENTITIES THAT AND THE
LEGISLATURE THEMSELVES CAN ON IT
AND ATTAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
STEPHANIE MORAL ON BEHALF OF BIO
COME IN OPPOSITION.
DRAW COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE REGRETFULLY
OPPOSE.
KATIE HANSON OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WERE HERE
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ISRAEL WILL SAY THAT UNTIL MY
COLLEAGUES RETURNED I WE WERE
50% FEMALE YEAH [inaudible]
TEMPORARY [inaudible]
OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE SENATOR.
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
AGREES THE ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT
THERE ARE SOME POTENTIAL.
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES BUT YET
PART OF OUR ROLE IS TO PUSH THE
DIALOGUE FOR DEBT CERTAINLY THIS.
BILL SHOULD PASS AND I HOPE IT
DOES WOULD RECEIVE STRICT
SCRUTINY BUT I THINK THERE'S
DEFTLY COMPELLING STATE INTEREST
IN THIS.
AND FOR THE COURTS TO TAKE A A
VERY CLOSE LOOK IT IS.
THEY WILL NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OVERCOME WHAT HAS
REALLY BEEN LONG STANDING
DISCRIMINATION THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS THAT'S PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PUT
OPPORTUNITIES FORWARD TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE IN FACT ADDRESSING.
DISCRIMINATION AS WE SEE IT AND
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT. TO RE
INTERPRET THE CONSTITUTION AS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
GOALS AS A STATE ARE MATT AND SO
I FEEL THAT THIS IS BILLS
ABSOLUTELY WORTHY OF OUR SUPPORT
TODAY.
I HOPE THIS COMMITTEE WILL PASS
IT OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CUSHION WITH THAT [inaudible]
JERRY MIKLOS.
I WILL ADOPT THE STATEMENT OF
THE CHAIR AND WITH THAT ASKS FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
KALRA PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
CHIU HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL.
CURRENTLY THE VOTERS THREE TO
ONCE WILL PUT THAT BELONG CALL
[inaudible]
YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU TENDER.
SO ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR GOOD MORNING
STILL I THINK AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
I AM PRESENTING TODAY S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR WHICH IS A A
BILL TO FIGHT PAY DISCRIMINATION
[inaudible]
WITH DATA.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO PAY
EQUITY YOU CAN'T FIX WHAT YOU
DON'T KNOW.
AND A FEW YEARS AGO RECOGNIZING
THAT PAID DISCRIMINATION IS HARD
TO DETECT AND ADDRESS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED A
REVISION. TWO A DEMOGRAPHIC
REPORT THAT LARGE EMPLOYERS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTING FOR MORE THAN
FIFTY YEARS.
THE EMPLOYER INFORMATION REPORT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE E. OUT.
ONE AND IT TO ARE CALLED UPON --
OR ADDED TO A WAS ABOUT TO ADD
TO THIS --
REPORT OTHER REPORTING A PAY
DATA BY RACE AND GENDER
BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PUT A HALT TO
THIS IMPORTANT PAY DATA --
BECAUSE SO THAT THAT EMPLOYERS
BY THE WAY WERE ALL PLOY HOUSTON
PREPARED TO START REPORTING.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS HAVE A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES OR MORE IN CALIFORNIA.
TO SUBMIT A PAID DATA REPORT
ANNUALLY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS OUTLINING
THE COMPENSATION IN HOURS WORKED
OF EMPLOYEES BY GENDER RACE
ETHNICITY AND JOB CATEGORY.
NOT INDIVIDUALLY BUT BY CATEGORY.
AND THE GOAL IS TO ENCOURAGE
EMPLOYERS TO ANALYZE THEIR OWN
PAY PRACTICES AND ALLOW FOR SELF
CORRECTION.
PUT A MIRROR IN FRONT OF YOUR
FACE AND SEE WHAT YOU ARE AND
WHAT YOU'RE DOING THAT IS THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL THAT IS THE
GOAL.
A IT IS NOT TO SHAME --
IT IS TO SIMPLY REQUIRE A SHELF
OF VALUATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT YOU ARE.
A DISCRIMINATING AND OFTENTIMES
I BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF THAT
DISCRIMINATION IS UNINTENDED YOU
JUST DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T LOOKED MAYBE
DON'T WANNA LOOK BUT THIS WILL
REQUIRE THAT YOU DO LOOK AND IT
WILL ALSO ALLOW --
DIR INDIA FEE H. TOGETHER
IMPORTANT DATA THAT ALLOWS HIM
TO SEE IT PATTERNS OF WAGE
DISPARITIES AND IF THEY NOTICED
DEVIATIONS OR OUT LIARS TO
INVESTIGATE FURTHER.
SO AS I MENTIONED THIS IS NOT A
BILL ABOUT PUBLIC SHAMING THAT
WAS A BILL THAT.
WE HEARD AND ACTUALLY WENT TO
THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR A BECAUSE
AT THAT IS NOT WHAT MY GOAL IS
MY GOAL IS TO GET PEOPLE TO
COMPLY IS TO GET COMPANIES TO
COMPLY.
AND WE'VE EVEN EXEMPTED A THIS
DATA FROM BEING ACCESSED THROUGH
A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT TO CONFIRM
THAT THIS IS NOT AN ATTEMPT TO
SAY HEY I GOTCHA.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO GET
COMPANIES TO COMPLY.
SO I HAVE WITH ME TODAY SHANNON
SMITH CRAWLEY WITH THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
AND RICO YOSHIHARA WITH
CALIFORNIAN PLACEMENT LAWYERS.
A TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MICHAEL YOSHIHARA WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO
COSPONSOR THIS BILL ALONG WITH
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN A YOU
W..
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH SENATOR
JACKSON A LOT OF OTHER MEMBERS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO
TACKLE THE GENDER AND RACE WAGE
GAP.
ON THAT BUT DESPITE ALL THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE AND
STRENGTHENING OUR EQUAL PAY LAWS
THE GENDER AND RACE WAGE GAP OR
JUST NOT CLOSING FAST ENOUGH.
AND ONE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE WAGE DISPARITIES IS NOT
JUST NOT JUST ABOUT COMPARING TO
WORKERS DOING THE SAME JOB AND
THEY'RE DIFFERENT GENDERS ARE
DIFFERENT RACES --
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION WHERE WE'RE SEEING
HIGHER CONCENTRATIONS OF WOMEN
AND MINORITIES MINORITIES AND
LOWER PAID JOBS.
AND THIS CAN BE THE RESULT OF
UNFAIR PAY BE THE RESULT OF
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS DISCRIMINATORY
HIRING APARTMENT PROMOTION
PRACTICES.
ON BUT WE ALSO SEE OF THE
OFTENTIMES EMPLOYERS ARE JUST
UNAWARE THAT THESE WAGE
DISPARITIES EXIST OR THAT THERE
IS THIS OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT
THE GRANULAR PAY DATA OR THE
HIGH LEVEL.
PATTERNS WITHIN WITHIN THEIR
WHOLE THEIR OWN PAY AND WITHIN
THEIR OWN PAY DATA.
AND THIS IS WHY THAT YOU'RE ONE
OF THE EEOC UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED THIS
REVISION TO THE EO ONE REPORTS
OF THAT THEY GET.
HOW THESE EMPLOYERS COMPILE ALL
THIS DATA HOW ABOUT HIGH LEVEL
LOOK TO SEE IF THERE ARE?
PAY PATTERNS THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED --
AND IT'S WORTH NOTING IN
EMPHASIZING THAT THE EEOC
ADOPTED THIS --
THIS REVISED FORM AFTER OVER TWO
YEARS OF A RIGOROUS AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS INCLUDING A
PUBLIC HEARING A PILOT STUDY A
VOTE BY THE EEOC COMMISSIONERS
TWO ROUNDS OF NOTICE AND PUBLIC
COMMENT.
CONSULTATIONS WITH EMPLOYER
REPRESENTATIVES AGE ARE EXPERTS
AND NUMEROUS STUDIES --
SO THROUGH THIS EXTENSIVE REVIEW
OF THE EEOC DETERMINED.
A A METHOD OF PAY DATA REPORTING
THAT WAS SIMPLE.
AND WOULD NOT UNDULY BURDEN
EMPLOYERS WHILE STILL PROVIDING
INFORMATION THAT COULD AGAIN
UNCOVERED THESE UNFAIR PAY
PRACTICES.
I SENATOR JACKSON POINTED OUT
THIS WILL HELP EMPLOYER SELF
CORRECTING AND IT WILL ALSO HELP
OUR STATE AGENCIES WITH TARGETED
ENFORCEMENT OF OF OUR PAY
DISCRIMINATION LAWS.
AND ALSO OUR STATE AGENCIES TO
LOOK AT DIFFERENT PAY PATTERNS
WITHIN AND ACROSS DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES AND ACROSS AND WITHIN
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHICAL
[inaudible]
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH --
TO JUST CONTINUE FOLLOWING THIS
IMPORTANT WORK THAT THE EEOC WAS
DOING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
STRONGLY URGE DRIVE THOUGH.
CHAIRMAN SMITH CROWLEY
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
A CO SPONSOR.
OF THE AND LIKE TO LYING MYSELF
WITH OF THE COMMENTS OF THE CALL
MY COLLEAGUE --
ONE REASON WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT TO KEEP COMING BACK
WITH A DIFFERENT BILLS THAT WE
COME UP HAD OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
IS THAT ACTUALLY THE PAY GAP IS
WIDENING.
UP UNTIL THIS YEAR WE THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO TAKE FIFTEEN YEARS
TO CLOSE.
THE CURRENT DATA SAYS A HUNDRED
AND ONE YEARS.
SO WE NEED TO HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT TOOLS IN OUR ARSENAL.
THIS ONE ACTUALLY MIGHT MIND.
I'M CHANGING YOU KNOW WATCHING
THAT I USE BEFORE I'M ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT THIS IS.
THE SCREENING MAMMOGRAPHY.
SCREENING MAMMOGRAPHY DOES NOT
TELL YOU WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE
CANCER.
IT TELLS YOUR YOU KNOW WHAT WE
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT THAT AREA
A LITTLE MORE CLOSELY DO SOME
MORE INVESTIGATION.
AND DEPENDING ON WHAT YOU FIND
TO LOOK AT ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF
OF TESTING.
SO REALLY IT'S IN AS THE SENATOR
SAID.
GIVING PEOPLE GIVING
ORGANIZATIONS A CHANCE TO EVEN
RECOGNIZE THEMSELVES.
OF WHAT THEY'RE ISSUES --
THAT THEY MAY HAVE A PROBLEM
THEY MAY HAVE A PROBLEM IT
DOESN'T SAY THEY DO.
IT MAY BE SOMETHING LIKE JOB
SEGREGATION --
DATA SHOW REPORT SHOW ONLY ABOUT
612%.
OF THE PAY DISPARITY IS BASED ON
BIAS OR DISCRIMINATION.
SO THE REST OF IT IS THE STATUS
QUO THEY'RE USED TO DOING THIS
THEY HAVEN'T CHECKED IN SO THIS
IS GOING TO BE A VALUABLE TOOL
AND WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THE BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
APPROACH STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
AND MY CHILD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING LORD CURTIS SUMMING
UP FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
SP TWELVE EIGHTY FOREIGN IT'S
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE JOB KILLER BILL THIS
YEAR.
OUT WE DO UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
OF THE BILL AGAIN AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
SUPPORTED THE FAIR PACKED IN THE
AND BEFORE AND WAS PASSED AND WE
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH THE
AUTHOR.
ON THAT BILL IN ORDER TO TRY AND
ACHIEVE AND PAY QUALITY OTHER
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL ARE AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT IT MAY NOT BE
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT BUT LOOKING
AT THE PLAIN LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL.
THERE IS STILL PUBLIC SHAMING
ASPECT WE HAVE ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHOR AND
HAVE PROVIDED AMENDMENTS TO PART
WHICH IF ADDRESSED OUR WHICH IF
TAKEN WE BELIEVE WELL I AM ALLOW
FOR THIS TO NO LONGER BE SUCH AN
ISSUE.
BUT THE PLAIN LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL SAYS THAT IT WOULD BE
UNLAWFUL FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
RELEASE THE SLIP AT THIS --
INFORMATION PRIOR TO LITIGATION
WHICH MEANS AGAIN WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
INTENT BUT ONCE A FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS FILED IN THIS
INFORMATION COULD BE TURNED OVER
SO WE ASK THAT THAT BE TIGHTENED.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'VE
ADDED THE PRIVATE RIGHT OR ACT
EXEMPTION WE APPRECIATE THAT BUT
WE HAVE BIG CONCERNS ABOUT --
FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION BEING FILE
BECAUSE WE DO KNOW HOW LITIGIOUS
CALIFORNIA'S AND ADDITIONALLY
THIS GOES STILL TO THE
INFORMATION I AM SHOWING WAGE
DISPARITY RIGHT I MEAN YOU HAVE
YOU CAN HAVE LAWFUL WHICH
DISPARITY INDIVIDUALS CAN MAKE.
DIFFERENT AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND
HAVE.
BECAUSE IT'S BASED ON BONA FIDE
FACTORS AND WE'RE CONCERNED THIS
AGGREGATE DATA IS SIMPLY GOING
TO SHOW WHICH DISPARITY THAT
MIGHT NOT BE UNLAWFUL AND AGAIN
IF THIS INFORMATION BY ANY MEANS
AS PER AS ALLOWED TO BE PUBLIC.
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT THE HEADLINES WHERE THIS
COMPANY IT DOES NOT PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES FAIRLY AND THAT'S OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN WITH THAT ISSUE
AND ADDITIONALLY IT'S GOING TO
HAVE SOME IF IT THIS INFORMATION
ANYWAY WERE TO GET OUT THERE
COULD BE SOME POTENTIAL THAT.
INDIVIDUAL'S PRIVATE INFORMATION
IS NOW OUT THERE FOR EXAMPLE I'M
JUST TO GIVE A VERY BROAD AND
HYPOTHETICAL IF YOU SAW THAT THE
JOB TITLE WITH QUARTERBACK AND I
KNOW THIS ISN'T ONE ON THE E.
ONE FAR BUT IF YOU SAW THAT JOB
TITLES QUARTERBACK AND YOU KNOW
THAT.
THEY'RE PLAYING FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO FORTY NINERS YOU CAN
PROBABLY AN AND IDENTIFY WHO
THAT INDIVIDUAL IS SO THE UP ONE
INDIVIDUAL UNDER ONE JOB TITLE
AND THIS INFORMATION OR TO GET
OUT THE NOT INDIVIDUALS PRIVATE
PAY I'M INFORMATION WILL BE OUT
THERE FOR THE WORLD TO SEE.
SO THOSE ARE CONCERNS AND AGAIN
WE WE APPRECIATE WORK AND THE
OTHER ON THIS BUT AS THE BILL
STANDS TODAY AND IS A CONCERNS
BILL FOR US IN A JOB KILLER FOR
CALVERT CHAMBER COMMERCE.
MISTER CHAIR CHRIS MCKAY WE ON
THE OTHER COUNTY AND CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION WE DID
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH SENATOR
JACKSON HONOR SENATE BILL. THREE
FIFTY A DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
SUBDIVISION J. WHICH MISS CURTIS
REFERENCE WHICH IS THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT --
EXEMPTION.
THE CLAUSE IN SUBDIVISION I A
ONE OF THE TWO ITEMS THAT --
CONTINUES TO BE OF CONCERN AND
THAT IS THE LANGUAGE ABOUT
MIDWAY THROUGH.
PRIOR TO THE INSTITUTION OF ANY
PROCEEDING --
AND HOPEFULLY THAT ISSUE CAN BE
ADDRESSED I WOULD NOTE THAT IN
YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AT THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE FIVE AND TOP OF
PAGE -- SIX
OUR CONCERN IS REFERENCE THEN I
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
RECOMMENDED AND AN AMENDMENT.
IN THAT REGARD THE OTHER ITEM --
TO MENTION IS THAT WE WOULD
PREFER TO SEE THIS LANGUAGE IN
THE GOVERNMENT CODE IN FEE AYE
AS OPPOSED TO A NEW SECTION OF
THE LABOR CODE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING --
MICROBES HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN STAFFING ASSOCIATION IN
THE CALIFORNIA STAFF WITH
PROFESSIONALS.
I'M WORK OR NOT.
PROPOSED UNLESS AMENDED WE'VE
BEEN TALKING CENTER JACKSON
ABOUT A SPECIFIC AMENDMENT WE'VE
WE'VE SUBMITTED IT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I'M IN AND I THINK THAT I'D
BE OKAY TO SAY THAT I WE WE'VE
HAD FAIRLY GOOD DIALOGUE I THINK
I'M WE COULD WE COULD COME TO
SOME RESOLUTION.
I'M I JUST WANNA EXPLAIN THE
AMENDMENT IF IT IF IT'S OKAY --
I'M JUST IT HISTORICALLY
[inaudible]
AN INDUSTRY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
REPORTING ANY DATA TO THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION AND THAT'S BECAUSE
I'M IT'S CERTAIN INDUSTRIES.
TEMPORARY STAFFING SEASONAL WORK.
IN THINGS LIKE THAT AND YOU KNOW
THE DATA COLLECTED WOULD BE
USELESS BY THE TIME IT'S ANALYZE
SO SO FOR FOR FOR FOR EVER THAT
SH.
THAT THOSE INDUSTRIES HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM REPORTING IN AND
WE'D SIMPLY JUST ASK THIS BILL.
I'M MIRRORED THIS THE SAME
EXCLUSION THAT EXISTED IN
FEDERAL OFF YOU KNOW FOR ALL
THOSE YEARS INCLUDING THROUGH
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND AND
YOU WOULD.
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT
AND CONTINUE WORKING WITH CENTER
JACKSON ON SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD ACCOMPLISH THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
MADISON Y. ON BEHALF OF THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
OUR MATTHEW ON WESTERN GROWERS
ALSO OPPOSED. TO DEFUSE THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SEAN LOS THE NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF IN A BUSINESS OPPOSITION
THINKING.
KITTY HANDSOME AT THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION.
ROBERT THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE THE PLUMBING HEATING
HITTING A PAVING INDUSTRY UNITED
CONTRACTORS TURNED OPPOSITION
TODAY.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES ARE
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS.
MISTER KALRA FIRST AND MISTER
HOWARD THANK YOU.
THAT THINK MISS CHAIR OF NEW.
OF I I WANT TO ONCE AGAIN.
THANK THE CENTER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AYE AYE SOUGHT
IN A PREVIOUS COMMITTEE --
AND YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT --
FIRST OF ALL HE THE PR
EXEMPTION I THINK AS A CLEAR
SIGN OF THE INTENTION.
THAT IT'S NOT YOUR INTENTION --
THAT TO HAPPEN.
SHAMING AND IN FACT --
I THINK YOU SAID IT NOW IN A
NUMBER OF OCCASIONS DRIVE USING
IT MORE AS PUTTING A MIRROR UP
TO ONE SOUTH.
AND I THINK THAT AS IT APPLIES
TO GENDER INEQUITY IN PAY AYE
THAT IS SO IN FACT IN EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR ECONOMY.
THAT WE HAVE TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY INTENTIONAL IF
WE REALLY WANT TO READ IT OUT
AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I KNOW A NUMBER OF THE COMPANIES
CERTAINLY COMING FROM SILICON
VALLEY THAT ARE TAKING THE ISSUE
REALLY SERIOUSLY.
ARM AND AND AND I UNDERSTAND
THEIR CONCERN.
OF A OF HAVING PUBLIC DISCLOSURE
I'M HOWEVER I WILL SAY THAT
[inaudible]
DODD LEADING.
A THAT THE MARKET TO ITS OWN
DEVICES HAS NOT WORKED AND IT
WILL NOT WORK I I THINK THAT THE
US.
OF A BUT I THINK THAT BY ITSELF
IS NOT GOING TO WORK I THINK
THAT THAT WERE THE CASE.
AYE WE WOULD HAVE WE WOULD SEE
FAR GREATER STRIDES THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE LAST TWO THREE
DECADES ONLY SEEN MUCH MORE
ATTENTION BEING PAID. TO THE THE
GENDER GAP.
ABA IN TERMS OF SECTION AYE --
I'M I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION AND AND I AM
CONFIDENT THE SENATE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK.
ON THAT ISSUE AGAIN --
REMEMBER AS APPLIES TO THAT AS
WELL AS THE TEMPORARY STAFFING
ISSUE WHICH I THINK WE CAN COULD
ALSO BE RESOLVED THE WORRY WOULD
JUST BE LIKE INTENDED NOT CREATE
ANOTHER LOOPHOLE AND SO I THINK
IN BOTH CASES IF THEY'RE GOING
TO BE FURTHER AMENDMENTS.
THAT HE TO BE RELATIVELY TIGHT
NARAL TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
CONCERN AND I KNOW THAT --
SENATOR JACKSON HER STOP AS WAS
COMMITTEE STOP HERE --
HAD THE ABILITY TO DO THAT AND I
WOULD CERTAINLY SUPPORT
AMENDMENTS THAT TIME HELP TO
ALLAY SOME OF THE THE CONCERNS.
I'M.
ALTHOUGH I AYE AGAIN AS WAS
DISCUSSED LAST WEEK I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE.
I'M YOU KNOW I JOIN TO OF OUR
COLLEAGUE AB SUMMER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ON A BILL THAT WAS MUCH
BROADER.
LAST YEAR --
THAT REALLY DID AT THE THE
INTENTION OF USING HOW THE
PUBLIC --
DISCLOSURE AS PART OF THE
STRATEGY OF OF MOVING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR A THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS BILL DIES --
AND AYE AYE HOWEVER I THINK THIS
BILL IS A REALLY IMPORTANT STEP --
PLAYED IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
COMPANIES HAVE A BETTER SENSE
AND AGAIN SOME AGREED ON THEIR
OWN RIGHT NOW BUT COMPANIES HAVE
A BETTER SENSE OF WHERE THEY ARE.
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE AND THEY
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE THE THE DATA
TO GET THEM THERE AND SO WITH
THAT IT CERTAINLY WAS?
NOT YOU AS A SECONDARY MOTIONAL
SUPPORT THE BILL AND CONSTRUCTED
AMENDMENTS GOING FORWARD AS WELL.
MORNING SENATOR JACKSON'S HYATT
SOAMES TO COLOR I THINK BRINGS
UP A GOOD POINT ABOUT HAVING
THAT CLARITY WITH ANY AMENDMENTS
CAN FORCE ON THIS ISSUE OF THAT --
STOPPING ANOTHER HIGH TURNOVER
INDUSTRIES I I KNOW THAT THERE'S
ALREADY I CAN EXCLUSION FROM THE
DEFINITION OF EMPLOYEE OUR COMES
THE EO ONE REPORTS THAT.
I DOESN'T EXIST WITH RESPECT TO
THE DATA YOU'RE SEEKING HERE AND
MAYBE THAT WAS --
NOT INTENTIONAL BECAUSE I THINK
IT MIGHT ACTUALLY EVEN CAN ASKEW
THE DATA THAT YOU'RE --
TRYING TO GET FROM THE SO WOOD
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU WANTED IT
IS WE'VE BEEN WORKING AND I
THINK WE WERE VERY CLOSE ON ON
THE PASS WAS MENTIONED A NUMBER
OF THE AMENDMENTS.
KEEPING IN MIND THE GOAL WHICH
WAS PROBABLY BETTER ARTICULATED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA THAN
MYSELF --
AND AND THE THINGS I DON'T WANT
TO DO -- I
THINK THAT.
OF WHEN WE ACHIEVED THAT AND
AGAIN TAKING THE TAKING OUT THE
A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT IS AN
EXAMPLE OF HIM.
A I THINK AN ILLUSTRATION OF MY
MY GOAL HERE IS TO GET COMPANIES.
TO BE MORE INTROSPECTIVE AND NOT --
TO PUBLICIZE HIS TO THE WORLD I
THINK WE'RE VERY CLOSE TONIGHT
AND WHAT I AM.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE A OPPOSITION ON COMMITTED TO
GETTING I I WOULD I LOVE TO GET
THEIR OPPOSITION OFF THE BILL OF
COURSE I WOULD BUT UMMM TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN COMMENDATION
THAT REDUCES THEIR ANXIETY.
OVER THIS I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
DO THAT WHILE KEEPING THE MAIN
GOAL WHICH IS FOR COMPANIES TO
SEE.
AND I YOU KNOW.
THE NOTION THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A LONG TIME FOR US TO GET
TO PARITY UNLESS WE REALLY.
OF A LOOK IN THE MIRROR AND
REALIZED THAT THOUGH.
THERE ARE NO EXCUSES THAT WE ARE
NOT HAVE REACHING THAT LEVEL.
OF EQUALITY OF OPPORTUNITY IT
WHICH HAS AN ECONOMIC BENEFIT
FOR TO THE STATE OF COURSE AS
WELL --
THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE GOAL OF
THE BILL AND I'M COMMITTED TO
BOTH THE GOAL AND TO ALSO DOING
EVERYTHING SO THAT WE ARE NOT
SHAMING PEOPLE BUT THAT WE ARE
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO COMPLY.
THANK YOU THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR
SAID YOU ON YOU THINK THE
EXISTING EXCLUSIONS FOR
TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES UNDER THE
SORRY WHAT'S IT CALLED THE E. --
<c.green> NO ONE REPORT UKIAH</c>
PROVIDE A GOOD BASIS --
FOR WHO SHOULD BE ACCEPTANCE
LEGISLATION WELL THERE'RE UP I
WILL TELL YOU THERE A COUPLE OF
OTHER GROUPS THAT HAVE STEP
FORWARD WANTING THAT SAME
EXEMPTION AND I DON'T WANT TO
ACCEPT MYSELF OUT OF THE BILL.
SO -- WERE
CAREFULLY TRYING TO CRAFT --
YOU KNOW RESOLVE THEIR CONCERTS
THANKS.
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS THERE
HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
HOW I'M SORRY.
BUT SHOWS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE CHURCH JUST BRIEFLY --
AGAIN OF WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT
LAWSUITS EVEN FRIVOLOUS ONES NOT
ALL LAWSUITS A FRIVOLOUS SO
EVERY TIME I HEAR THE TWO WORDS
TOGETHER I HAVE TO DISCONNECT
THEM.
BUT THE GOAL HERE ISN'T
LITIGATION THE GOAL IS
COMPLIANCE AND THAT'S WHY WE
GIVE THE AUTHORITY TO DIR --
TO TAKE A LOOK AND THEN TO
FOLLOW UP IF THERE ARE PATTERNS
AND THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE ANY
WAY TO IDENTIFY AN INDIVIDUAL
BECAUSE CERTAIN CATEGORIES.
SO I THINK THOSE CONCERNS ARE OR
ARE NOT WELL PLACED BUT AGAIN I
I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS SO THAT WE CAN MOVE
THAT PAUL FORD AND AND THIS
LEVEL OF DISCRIMINATION.
AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
WITH THAT I'D ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL STONE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU CHIU HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL.
THE COUNTESS TO TO THAT BILLS ON
CALL AND SENATOR IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR NEXT BILL WHICH
AT LEAST FILE ITEM --
ELEVEN SP THIRTEEN COMPASS
BICU THIRTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU
.
ALRIGHT IT'S STILL GOOD MORNING
SO GOOD MORNING THE MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS [inaudible]
MEMBER [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
BUT TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT S.
B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED FIRST FALL I
WILL ACCEPT AS AN AUTHORS
AMENDMENT.
THE TECHNICAL CORRECTION AND
CHANGE OF THE WORD PLAINTIFF TO
EMPLOYEE IN SECTION QUE OF THIS
BILL.
IF WE HAVE LEARNED ANYTHING FROM
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT IT IS THAT
PREVENTING AND RESPONDING
EFFECTIVELY TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
IS ABOUT MORE THAN HOLDING
PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE THOUGH
THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT ENSURING THAT
OUR LAWS OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
OUR WORKPLACE CULTURES ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO ENSURE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IN THE WORKPLACE.
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT VICTIMS IN A
NUMBER OF KEY WAYS.
FIRST THIS MEASURE PROVIDES
GUIDANCE TO THE COURT ON THE
SEVERE AND PERVASIVE LEGAL
STANDARD WHICH IS A HIGH
STANDARD.
THAT I BELIEVE AFTER HAVING HELD
TO A DIFFERENT HEARINGS ON THIS
ISSUE IS WORKING.
IT IS A A A STANDARD THAT IS
VALUABLE --
THERE IS CASE LAW AND DIRECTION
BUT THAT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
WE NEED TO GIVE DIRECTION TO THE
COURT.
AND TO BE ABLE --
TO EXPLAIN AND GIVE GUIDANCE TO
WHAT THIS LEGAL STANDARD IS.
SO THAT WE CAN ENCOURAGE HIM TO
APPLY THE LAW THROUGH THE LENS
OF THIS QUESTION.
DID THE BEHAVIOR IN QUESTION
FUNDAMENTALLY DEPRIVE SOMEONE OF
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED.
THAT IS THE ISSUE.
NUMBER TWO SP THIRTEEN HUNDRED
STRENGTHENS WEEKLY IMPLORE YOUR
ACCOUNTABILITY EXISTING LAW
ALREADY REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO
TAKE ALL REASONABLE STEPS
NECESSARY TO PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION FROM OCCURRING.
BUT ILL LOGICALLY.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IN EMPLOYERS
DUTY TO PREVENT THAT IT
HARASSMENT ONLY KICKS IN ONCE
THE HARASSING CONDUCT HAS
REACHED THAT HIGH BAR OF SEVERE
AND PERVASIVE OR PERVASIVE.
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED AFFIRMS
THAT EMPLOYERS CAN'T SIT ON
THEIR HANDS WHEN THEY LEARN OF
UNWELCOME DISCRIMINATORY CONDUCT
BUT MUST TAKE ALL REASONABLE
STEPS TO RESPOND. THREE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED STRENGTHENED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
REQUIRING TRAINING FOR ALL
WORKERS NOT JUST SUPERVISORS AND
FOR ALL EMPLOYERS OF FIVE OR
MORE.
AND INCLUDES BYSTANDER
INTERVENTION TRAINING WHICH WE
KNOW.
IS VALUABLE BUT IT'S ONLY USED
IF THE BYSTANDER WISHES TO USE
IT IT'S NOT COMPELLING IT'S JUST
GIVING THEM THE TOOLS.
AND THE SKILLS TO INTERVENE IF
THEY SO CHOOSE.
AND FOR THIS CLOSEST LEGAL
LOOPHOLES PROHIBITING EMPLOYERS
FROM REQUIRING WORKERS TO SIGN
AWAY THEIR ABILITY TO SPEAK OUT
OR THEIR RIGHT TO FILE A CLAIM
AGAINST AN EMPLOYER.
AS A CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT.
OR OF CONTINUED EMPLOYMENT OR
FOR WAGES OR BONUS OR A BONUS
WHAT IS OFTEN REFERRED TO THIS
PRACTICES OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
NON DISPARAGE.
NON DISPARAGEMENT AGREEMENT WERE
SNEAKY RELEASES.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXTRA TWENTY
CENTS PER HOUR IF YOU AGREE THAT
YOU WON'T.
I TALKED BADLY OR DO ANYTHING TO
SUE FOR THE MISBEHAVIOR THAT YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCED OR SEEN AT THE
WORKPLACE PREVIOUSLY.
RESEARCH JUST.
NOT ACCEPTABLE THEY ARE --
THEY'VE THEY CREATE PROBLEMS
WHEN WE'RE TRYING --
TO DIG OUT AND CORRECT THE
BEHAVIOR IT BASICALLY SILENCES
PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO SPEAK
OUT IN THE US FURTHER
VICTIMIZING THOSE WHO ARE GOING
TO BE THE SUBJECT OF THAT
BEHAVIOR --
AND WITH THAT I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY -- TN
SORREL.
SO TIGHTLY AND I'M SO SORRY
TIENEN THAT WITH HER ATTORNEY
LESLIE LEAVING.
AS WELL AS PAMELA LOPEZ TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WITH THE
BILL [inaudible]
SEC.
AND TO WERE ALSO TO WITNESS
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY.
MY NAME IS LESLIE LEVY I'M A
PARTNER LEVY VINIK PARRAL HYAMS
AND OAKLAND LAW FIRM THAT
SPECIALIZES IN REPRESENTING
EMPLOYEES AND DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT CASES.
ACCORDING TO RECENT RESEARCH
BETWEEN NINETY AND 95% OF WOMEN
WHO HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY HARASSED
EXPERIENCE EXPERIENCE
DEBILITATING STRESS REACTIONS.
INCLUDING ANXIETY DEPRESSION
SLEEP DISORDERS AND LOWERED SELF
ESTEEM I'VE SEEN THESE DAMAGES
AGAIN AND AGAIN IN MY DECADES OF
EXPERIENCES IN LITIGATING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CASES.
ALTHOUGH IT'S IN THE ECONOMIC
INTERESTS OF BUSINESSES TO TAKE
ALL REASONABLE ACTIONS TO
PREVENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT GIVEN
THAT A CAUSES ABSENTEEISM LOW
PRODUCTIVITY AND STAFF TURNOVER.
THE CHOICE TO LEAVE PROTECT
PREVENTION TO THE MARKETPLACE
HAS NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL. FOR THE
BENEFITS OF EMPLOYEE BENEFIT OF
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS AND SOCIETY
AS A WHOLE.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE ENACT
LAWS THAT REQUIRE ALL REASONABLE
STEPS TO BE TAKEN TO PREVENT
HARASSMENT BEFORE IT REACHES.
THE LEVEL OF LITIGATION.
I'M GOING TO SLEEP THE REST OF
THE REMAINDER OF MY TIME TO TIE
ANSWER RAIL. TO TALK ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCES AS A SURVIVOR OF
WORKPLACE SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
BUT I'LL BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT HOW OUR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT LAWS.
WORK AND OFTEN FAIL IN OUT IN
PRACTICE.
MISTER ROWE WAS REPRESENTED BY
MY OFFICE IN A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CASE AGAINST A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION.
UNFORTUNATELY HER STORY IS ONE
OF MANY THAT REFLECT THE DAMAGES
CAUSED WHEN AN EMPLOYER.
FAILS TO TAKE APPROPRIATE ACTION
PARTICULARLY EARLY ON DAMAGES
THAT COULD AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED.
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY.
IN SUPPORT OF US SENATE BILL.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED I NEVER FORGET
THE MORNING MY YOUNGEST CHILD
AWOKE EXCITED ABOUT THE PLANS WE
MADE TO CELEBRATE HIS BIRTHDAY.
NEITHER HE NOR I WAS GOING TO
THINK ABOUT THE RECENT AND
PAINFULLY VENTS THAT OUR FAMILY
WAS TRYING TO WORK THROUGH FROM
WHAT IT OCCURRED ON MY PLACE OF
WORK.
WE'RE GONNA RIDE ROLLER COASTERS
INTO OBLIVION.
BUT THAT MORNING MY STORY HIT
THE PRESS.
I ADJUSTED MY EMPLOYER A
PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITY FOR
FAILING TO PREVENT AND
ADEQUATELY RESPOND TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BY YET ANOTHER DEAN
OF THE INSTITUTION.
THE CAMPUS COMMUNITY WAS
RIGHTFULLY ENRAGED AND MOST WERE
JUST LEARNING FOR THE FIRST TIME
ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
CONFESSIONS.
THE INVESTIGATIVE FINDINGS AND
INAPPROPRIATE RESPONSES BY THE
UNIVERSITY ALL OF WHICH THAT IT
BEEN NEATLY TUCKED UNDER THE RUG.
PEOPLE WANTED ANSWERS BECAUSE IT
HAD BEEN NEARLY A YEAR.
THAT ALL THE INCIDENTS THAT HAD
OCCURRED.
I REMEMBER LOOKING AT MY BABY
SIGN.
I HELD HIM CLOSE AND I SAID I'M
SO SO SORRY BABY.
I WILL MAKE THIS UP TO YOU BUT
MOMMY NEEDS TO POSTPONE YOUR
SPECIAL DAY TODAY.
HE PUTS LOW HEAD DOWN.
SWALLOWED MY BURDEN.
CALMLY SAID THAT'S OKAY MOMMY I
UNDERSTAND.
AND WHILE I'LL REGRET THAT DAY
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE I WILL
NEVER REGRET COMING FORWARD
ABOUT THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT
I WITH THE ONE MY JOB.
BEFORE I BEGAN WORKING AT THE
UNIVERSITY MY FAMILY AND I WE
WERE HEALTHY WE WERE HAPPY.
AND AS A BUSY MOTHER OF FIVE
CHILDREN I WAS CONFIDENT
COMPETENT MY WORK.
AND I CONTINUE TO GROW AND
THRIVE IN BOTH MY PROFESSIONAL
AND MY PERSONAL LIFE.
AFTER WORKING FOR PREVIOUS
DEAN'S WITHOUT INCIDENT A NEW
DEAN TOOK OVER HE BEGAN TOUCHING
ME IN INAPPROPRIATE WAYS THAT
MADE ME FEEL EXTREMELY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
I DID EVERYTHING TO DENY WHAT
WAS HAPPENING TO ME I REMEMBER
MY BODY JUST FREEZING UP.
I WOULD TRY TO PHYSICALLY
MENTALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
SEPARATE MYSELF FROM THE MOMENT.
I SHARED SOME OF THESE
EXPERIENCES WITH A COUPLE OF
SUPERVISORS AND THEY BOTH AGREED
THAT THE DEANS BEHAVIOR WAS
HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE.
BUT I WAS STILL TOO AFRAID TO
TELL THEM DIRECTLY.
OVER TIME I GREW ANXIOUS AND
THEN DEPRESSED.
MY BODY WAS EXPERIENCING SO MANY
DIFFERENT SYMPTOMS I CAN'T EVEN
NAME THE DEAN WAS INDEED IN A
POSITION OF POWER AND I WAS HIS
SUBORDINATE.
SO I WAS VERY AFRAID TO TELL ON
THE STOCK BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT
WOULD COMPROMISE MY EMPLOYMENT.
MY FAMILY WAS DEPENDING ON ME S
WAS MY EMPLOYER SO I DID WHAT I
COULD TO COLD.
THE WHOLE ORDEAL BECAUSE MANY
SLEEPLESS NIGHTS AND I WAS
PHYSICALLY EXHAUSTED.
I FOUND MYSELF CRYING ALL THE
TIME EVEN THOUGH I TRIED TO BE
AS STRONG AS I COULD.
BUT SOMEHOW I FOUND THE COURAGE
IF ONLY IN MY DESPERATION AND
ANGER TO CONFRONT WHAT HE HAD
BEEN PUTTING ME THROUGH.
AND WHEN I TOOK THE REST TO
ADDRESS THE VIOLATIONS I CAN
ONLY DESCRIBE THE UNIVERSITY'S
RESPONSE IS OUTRAGEOUS.
I WAS TOLD THAT I WAS NOT
FEELING WELL.
AND THAT I SHOULD USE MY OWN
HARD EARNED SICK AND VACATION
TIME TO GET BETTER.
EVERY ACTION OF MY EMPLOYER THAT
FOLLOWED SIR TO PROTECT AND
SUPPORT THE PROFESSIONAL STATUS
OF MY HARASSER AS WELL AS THE
REPUTATION OF THE INSTITUTION.
SO THERE WAS IT WAS ON MEET TO
MAKE THIS ALL WORK AND CONTINUE
TO COLD.
SALLY AS I WAS NOT THE FIRST
KNOW WHAT I'D BE THE LAST TO GO
THROUGH THE PAINFUL EXPERIENCE
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY EVENTUALLY I HAD TO
TAKE LEGAL ACTION.
I HAD TO FIGHT THE UNIVERSITY
CULTURE THAT TOLERATE IT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND ALLOWED IT TO GO
UNCHECKED.
MY EXPERIENCE HAS SHOWN ME THAT
ARE HARASSMENT LAWS HAVE FAILED
TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT WOMEN LIKE
ME.
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING UP OUR
CURRENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT LAW
INCLUDES THE GOAL OF PREVENTING
OR AT LEAST REDUCING THE
INCIDENCE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
WHILE PROVIDING CLEAR STANDARDS
OF RECOURSE IN Y. DISEMPOWERED
VICTIMS TO HAVE THEM BE FORCED
TO SILENCE.
AND WHY HAVE OUR LAW ALLOW FOR
GENEROUS TOLERANCE FOR SEVERE
AND REPEATED OCCURRENCES OF
HARASSMENT.
I DON'T KNOW OF A RESULT PERSON
WHO WOULD WANT TO EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND PERHAPS WITHOUT ANY
ACCESSIBLE REMEDY.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS VERY
SERIOUS AND DAMAGING PROBLEM
THAT LEAVES PEOPLE LIKE ME AND
OUR FAMILIES TO WORK TIRELESSLY
TO PIECE OUR LIVES BACK TOGETHER
AGAIN.
THIS IS WHY PASSING SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN HUNDRED IS SO IMPORTANT.
THIS WILL HELP STRENGTHEN THE
LAWS SO THAT WORKERS LIKE ME ARE
NOT FORCED TO TOLERATE REPEATED
OCCURRENCES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SO I URGE YOU.
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE EVERY
CALIFORNIAN DESERVES TO WORK IN
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS FREE OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
[inaudible]
Q..
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF
OF WORK ACT.
WHICH SEEKS TO EMPOWER THE
VOICES OF SURVIVORS IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND I WILL BE BRIEF AS I AND MY
FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS OF WORK
EQUITY HAVE TRAVELED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO MEET WITH WOMEN AND
EVEN MEN WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THEY HAVE SHARED SOME VERY
VALUABLE ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN OUR WORKPLACE TO STOP
THIS BEHAVIOR BEFORE IT BEGINS.
I CANNOT SAY ENOUGH HOW
IMPORTANT BYSTANDER INTERVENTION
TRAINING IS FOR SURVIVORS WE
WANT TO FEEL LIKE OUR COWORKERS
TO WHO WANT TO HAVE OUR BACKS.
KNOW HOW THEY CAN HAVE OUR BACKS
IT IS ALSO SO IMPORTANT TO
PROTECT OUR ABILITY TO TALK
ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCES NOT ONLY
IS TALKING ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCES
A PART OF THE HEALING PROCESS.
BUT IT IS A WAY THAT A SURVIVOR
CAN CONTRIBUTE IN VERY
MEANINGFUL WAYS AS WE ARE SEEING
TODAY TO THE FIGHT AGAINST AYE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND FINALLY IT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO FOCUS ON PREVENTING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THE MOMENT THAT WE
SEE SOME INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR
OR BEHAVIOR THAT MAKES A PERSON
FEEL VERY UNCOMFORTABLE AT WORK.
I BEGAN AND SO WE THANK THE
SENATOR FOR INCLUDING --
INTERVENTION BEFORE --
HARASSMENT REACHES THAT LEVEL OF
SEVERE OR PERVASIVE THANK YOU
SENATOR I WORK EQUITY
APPRECIATES YOUR WORK.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT YOU CAN GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION PUT
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AMERYKAH
YOSHIHARA WITH CALIFORNIA
PLUMMET LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
AND EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EMILY CHILD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
SEAMUS WITH GROWING ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN PART OF
STRONGER CALIFORNIA COALITION
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
DENNIS SEATON ON BEHALF OF THE
CHURCH THAT COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SAY NONE OPPOSITION.
IT'S YOU EXCIMER WITH THEIR
POSITION PLEASE THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MORE CREDIT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO S. B. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED AND THIS IS A JOB KILLER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND AND I JUST WANTED
TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS I'VE.
EMPLOYERS DO HAVE AN AFFIRMATIVE
DUTY TO PREVENT HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION AS SOON AS A
COMPLAINT IS MADE AND THE
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY KICKS IN FOR
EMPLOYERS TO PREVENT HARASSMENT
AND DISCRIMINATION IN THE
WORKPLACE AND THEY ALSO HAVE.
THAT DUTY THROUGHOUT THAT TO
PROVIDE POLICIES NOTIFICATIONS
TO EMPLOYEES OF THEIR RIGHTS AND
ALL SORTS OF OTHER AND ISSUES
ARE I MEAN ALL OTHER SORTS OF
REGULATIONS.
AND ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
ALREADY HAS POLICE POWER OVER
PREVENTING HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION THEY CAN SEEK ANY
NON MONETARY REMEDY SO THEY CAN
SEE CONJUNCTIONS ANYTHING
AGAINST AN EMPLOYER.
WHO IS NOT PROPERLY PREVENTING
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION WE
FEEL THAT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
IN ORDER TO PREVENT HARASSMENT
OR DISCRIMINATION AND UTILIZE
THIS ENFORCEMENT RATHER THAN
CREATING A NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION THAT ALLOWS AN EMPLOYEE
TO SUE FOR HYPOTHETICAL SCENARIO?
I'M OUR UNDERSTANDING IS IS THAT
THE APPLY TO EMPLOYEES HOWEVER
CONCERN STILL IS THAT NOW THE
COURTS WILL BECOME THE HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ANY SORT OF EMPLOYEE DISPUTE
REGARDING THE ALLEGATIONS OF
SURROUNDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CAN NOW BE BROUGHT TO COURT
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT THESE ARE
NECESSARILY SUCCEED IN COURT
DEPENDING ON ALLEGATIONS
THEMSELVES.
BUT THEY WILL BE OLD ENOUGH TO
SAY TO ME AND PROVIDE A DEMAND
LETTER TO THE EMPLOYER AND
REQUIRE THAT A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
SETTLEMENT I'M VALUE IS GIVEN TO
THE EMPLOYER IN ORDER.
TO AS SETTLE THIS KIND OF CLAIM
SO OUR BIGGEST CONCERN AGAIN IS
THAT THIS IS A SKIRT AROUND THE
SEVERE PERVASIVE STANDARD WHY
WOULD ANYONE ACTUALLY SUPER
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION WHEN
THEY NO LONGER NEED TWO ALL THEY
NEED TO SUE FOR ITS FAILURE TO
PREVENT HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION.
AND THE COURTS A PARTY DETERMINE
THE SHOULD NOT BE A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THEY'VE FOUND
THAT IN ORDER FOR HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND PREVENTION TO
PEAK UMPS BROUGHT AS A LAWSUIT.
SHOULD BE CONJUNCTION WITH
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION
ITSELF THAT THERE ACTUALLY HAS
TO BE HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION THAT OCCURRED
PRIOR TO SUING FOR BAND FAILURE
TO PREVENT WHAT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY A HYPOTHETICAL
SITUATION.
SALAS OUR BIGGEST CONCERNS AGAIN
THERE'S ALSO ISSUES WITH THE NON
DISPARAGEMENT AND THE SEVERANCE
CLAUSES I'M WITH THOSE ISSUES
AND NON DISPARAGEMENT AGREEMENTS
ARE PART OF MOST SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS AGAIN I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE DON'T NECESSARILY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT BUT WITH THE
PLAIN LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
THIS WOULD HAVE POTENTIALLY
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS CAN NO
LONGER INCLUDE NON DISPARAGEMENT%
AGREEMENT --
IN SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS AND
ALSO FOR SEVERANCE AGREEMENTS
I'M REGARDING GENERALLY SAYS
OFTENTIMES THAT'S WHY
INDIVIDUALS GET SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS IS THE NON
DISPARAGEMENT PROVISIONS AND THE
A GENERALLY CITIZENS OF THAT
WILL TO BRING THOSE AT SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS AND COME AND US
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS.
BIGGEST A MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST PAYCHECK.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US WITH A
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
IF I COULD A CHRISTMAS KAYLIE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMBULANCE
ASSOCIATION OF FACTORIES THREE
ISSUES.
OF THE FIRST IS A SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL WHICH IS A NUMBER OF
STATEMENTS OF INTENT I THINK IS.
URINALYSIS NOTED THAT THESE ARE
NON BINDING FINDINGS --
AND DECLARATIONS AND OBVIOUSLY --
WHILE THEY COULD BE CONSIDERED
IT'S IT'S CHANGES IN THE LAW
THAT -- YOU
KNOW GIVE CLEAR DIRECTION TO THE
COURTS THEMSELVES AND THERE'S
QUITE A LOT OF INFORMATION IN.
THE STATEMENTS THAT IS NOT LATER
AFFIRMED IN ANY STATUTORY
CHANGES --
THE SECOND ISSUE JUST TO EXPAND
UPON THE COMMENTS THAT MISS
CURTIS MADE --
CENTER JACKSON HAS INDICATED THE
AUTHOR HAS INDICATED THAT SHE'S
TRYING TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
THE COURTS AND OUR CONCERN IS
THAT WE FIND THIS IS A
SUBSTANTIALLY LOWERING.
OF THE STANDARDS AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS I THINK THAT
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENT THAT WAS
TAKEN CERTAINLY GOES A LONG WAY
BUT THERE ARE OTHER AMBIGUITIES
FOR EXAMPLE.
IN SUBDIVISION QUE WHAT PART TO
A AT WHAT POINT DOES THE
EMPLOYER BEFORE AFTER THE
CONDUCT A HAS OCCURRED.
SO WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT WAS ON
WELCOME TO THE EMPLOYEES.
AND QUE TO BE.
IF IT INCREASED I THINK THE
CONCERN HERE IS THAT IT MAY NOT
MEET THE CURRENT LEGAL STANDARD
WHICH IS PERVASIVE --
OR SEVERE SEVERE OR PERVASIVE
RATHER THAN AND WHICH I THINK
HAS BEEN --
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES IT'S AN OR
BUT WHAT WILL IN THE FUTURE MEAN
IN ESSENCE FOR EXAMPLE I THINK
THE ANALOGY THAT SOMEONE IS USED
IN THE PAST IS.
BUT AS I'M COMING UP TO A STOP
SIGN OR A RED LIGHT I COULD
CROSS THROUGH IN BE CITED BUT IF
I STOP I HAVE NOT.
SO HOW DO WE DETERMINE THIS IF
IT INCREASED IN --
IN A AND B. THE STATUE OR THE
BILL USES THE THE TERM OF THE
CONDUCT AND THEN LATER IN SEE
SAME OR SIMILAR --
HOW IS THAT HOW IS THAT TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE EMPLOYER?
AND THE THE LAST ITEM THAT ALL
REYES IS IN SUBDIVISION
[inaudible] FIVE FIVE WHICH IS
WHAT WE VIEW TO BE CURRENT LAW
SAYS THAT EITHER PREVAILING
PARTY.
IS ENTITLED TO REASONABLE
ATTORNEYS FEES AND COSTS.
AND WE THINK THE VERY HIGH
THRESHOLD THAT WOULD ONLY BE
IMPOSED UPON THE DEFENDANT --
WILL SEVERELY LIMIT THEIR
ABILITY TO RECOVER REASONABLE
ATTORNEYS FEES AND COSTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AT THE WILD WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION UNFORTUNATELY ALSO
OR OTHER POST.
TRUE TO HIS THE CALIFORNIA THEY
GET FOOD PRODUCERS ALSO POST.
SEAN LOOKS NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF ANY BUSINESS OR READING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO POST.
NOT REMAIN COVERING TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WERE HERE
IN OPPOSITION.
CAITLYN COLEMAN CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
DAY BUTLER ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK
A COALITION OF LOCAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ORGANIZATIONS HERE IN
THE SACRAMENTO MARKETPLACE.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
WAS KILEY.
AT SUCH AS THIS BILL MAY CONDUCT
THAT DOES NOT MEET --
STANDARD OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ACTIONABLE NO.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT BECAUSE
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS A DIFFERENT
AGENDA.
THE CURRENT DUTY IS THERE AND
THERE'S HARDLY AN AFFIRMATIVE
DUTY TO PREVENT HARASSMENT.
BUT IT DOESN'T RISE TO THE LEVEL
OF SEVERE OR PERVASIVE.
UNTIL A LORD DOESN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF BEING ACTIONABLE UNDER
LAW.
UNLESS IT IS SEVERE OR PERVASIVE.
AND THAT IS THE STANDARD THAT WE
ARE USING SEVERE OR PERVASIVE
THAT IS WHEN THE BEHAVIOR
BECOMES ACTIONABLE.
WHAT WE ARE SAYING ON IN OUR --
LANGUAGE HERE IS THAT AN
EMPLOYER HAS A DUTY.
BEFORE IT BECOMES SEVERE OR
PERVASIVE.
I TAKE ALL REASONABLE STEPS TRY
TO PREVENT THE BEHAVIOR ONCE THE
EMPLOYER KNOWS OF THE BEHAVIOR.
THAT THEY KNOW IT'S ON WELCOME
SO ALL THIS STUFF ABOUT --
HOW DID THEY KNOW IT'S WHEN
SOMEBODY COMES TO THEM AND SAYS?
SO AND SO DID SUCH AND SUCH AND
IT MAKES ME FEEL BAD I'M ITS
UNWELCOME AT THAT POINT IN TIME
IT COULD BE ONE INCIDENT.
THE EMPLOYER THEN WILL HAVE AN
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY WHICH THEY HAVE
TO TAKE ALL REASONABLE STEPS IF
THEY TAKE STEPS AND THE BEHAVIOR
STOPS YOU'RE DONE.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT THE IRONY
IS WE'RE TRYING TO ARE ENCOURAGE
EMPLOYERS TO TAKE STEPS AS
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE STAGE SO THAT
IT DOESN'T RISE TO THE SEVERE OR
PERVASIVE STANDARD WHICH THEN
BECOMES A LAWSUIT.
I SEE SERVE THERE IS THAT A
SINGLE INCIDENT AND IT'S ON
WHILE TIME AND THE EMPLOYER
BECOMES AWARE OF IT --
AND THEY FAILED TO TAKE --
REASONABLE STEPS DOES AT THAT
POINT BECOME ACTIONABLE IT IS
THERE NOW THAT NEED TO BE
ANOTHER INCIDENT FOLLOWING THEIR
FAILURE TO TAKE REASONABLE STEPS
THEY HAVE TO TAKE THEY IF IT
BECOMES SEVERE OR PERVASIVE IS
WHEN IT BECOMES ACTIONABLE IS
WHEN THEY'RE ON THE PHONE.
OKAY SO IT IS NOT ACTIONABLE IN
LAST THE CONDUCT THE SEVERE
PERVASIVE.
IT IS IT IS ACTIONABLE IF THE
BEHAVIOR IS NOT.
HOME.
IT IF THE BEHAVIOR CONTINUES SO
THAT YOU NOW OR AT A SEVERE AND
PERVASIVE LEVEL WERE A LAWSUIT
CAN CAN.
BUT NOT ONLY BE FILE BUT SURVIVE.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION YEAH --
BUT AND THERE ARE INSTANCES
WHERE A SINGLE ACT COULD B. AS
SEVERE ACTON AND IN PRIOR
TESTIMONY WE'VE HAD TO A WOMAN
WHO WAS A NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHER OPERATOR.
WHO -- WAS
TAKING A NINE ONE ONE CALL WHEN
ONE OF HER COWORKERS STUCK HIS
HAND DOWN HER BLOUSE.
AND THAT --
WHILE SHE WAS TRYING TO DO OUR
JOB THAT NOW DID HAPPENED A
HUNDRED DIFFERENT TIMES.
A THE EMPLOYER AT THAT POINT IN
TIME WOULD HAVE TO TAKE ACTION --
THAT BECOMES AN EXAMPLE OF A
SEVERE PERVASIVE BEHAVIOR THAT A
COURT COULD THEN ACT UPON.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
IF SOMEONE SAYS SOMETHING THAT
MAKES YOU UNCOMFORTABLE
INAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS WE HAVE
INSTANCES WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE
ON WHITE BOARDS?
MAKING --
IMAGES OF GENITALIA --
IS AN EMPLOYEE AT THE AND AN
EMPLOYEE WALKS IN AND HAS SPOKEN
TO THE SUPERVISOR AND SAID THIS
IS GOING ON THIS MAKES ME
UNCOMFORTABLE.
THE EMPLOYER'S DUTY AT THAT
POINT TIME IS TO TAKE REASONABLE
STEPS TO STOP THE BEHAVIOR.
I THINK THE NEXT ONE TO GIVE YOU
OPPOSITION A CHANCE TO RESPOND
IF THAT ACCORD THE UNDERSTANDING
OF THE OF THE BILL IS WRITTEN.
LOWER THE SEVERE PERVASIVE
STANDARD FOR ACTUAL HARASSMENT
OR DISCRIMINATION BUT IT DOESN'T
FACT CREATED NEW PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION SO ONCE THE EMPLOYER
IS AWARE THAT THE BEHAVIOR WAS
AND WELCOME IF THEY DID NOT TAKE
ALL REASONABLE STEPS WHICH IS UP
THE EMPLOYEE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE STEPS.
THAT THEY THEY TERMINATE THE
EMPLOYEE BUT THEY ARE THEY RIGHT
EMPLOYEE UP BUT THEY DON'T
TERMINATE THE EMPLOYEE AND THE
EMPLOYEE COULD POTENTIALLY BRING
A CAUSE OF ACTION AGAINST THE
EMPLOYER NOW FOR FAILURE TO
PREVENT HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION THIS IS A NEW
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
RIGHT NOW IT'S BROADENED
CONJUNCTION WITH HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND NO LONGER
NEEDS TO HAVE HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THIS TO BRING A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION FOR FAILURE TO
PREVENT.
TOM HOW OLD ARE.
WELL IT'S KILEY HAS THE FLOOR SO
IT'S UP TO HIM TO ASK QUESTIONS.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO GIVE SENATOR
CANCERS.
I JUST A VERY QUICKLY THERE
ALREADY EXISTS A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION UNDER THAT.
THE CURRENT STATUTES SO TO SAY
THAT THIS CREATES A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THAT DOESN'T
CURRENTLY EXIST IT'S NOT
ACCURATE --
I ALSO WHICH IS LIKE IF I CAN
FOR JUST ONE MOMENT POINT OUT I
UNDERSTAND THEM AND THAT.
THEY HAVE TO STOP YOU THERE
BECAUSE THANK YOU FOR MEMBERS
ASK QUESTIONS WILL ADMIT TO THAT
OTHER.
QUESTIONS FROM THE DICE.
ALRIGHT SAID I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
AND IN FOR CLARITY WHAT'S WHAT'S
DIFFICULT ABOUT THIS I THINK IS
WE KNOW WHAT THAT THE STANDARD
IS THE SEVERE AND PERVASIVE.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TOO MANY
INSTANCES WHERE THERE IS SOME
ACTIVITY BY AN EMPLOYEE.
THAT THE EMPLOYER IS WARNED
ABOUT AND THEN BECAUSE THEY FEEL
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
ACTION DOESN'T.
THEY DON'T TAKE ACTION.
THEN THERE MAY BE SUBSEQUENT.
ACTIONS THAT ARE OFFENSIVE THAT
START TO HAPPEN.
AND THE NOTION WITH THIS BILL IS
THOUGH SUBSEQUENT.
ACTIONS WOULD BE PREVENTABLE IF
THE EMPLOYER FELT OBLIGATED TO
STEP IN AND A LOT OF THE
EXAMPLES ARE ONCE THAT I THINK
WE WOULD ALL SAY WAIT A MINUTE
NOBODY TOLD THAT EMPLOYER THAT
EMPLOYEE NOT TO DO THAT ANYMORE.
THAT BY ITSELF IS KIND OF
OUTRAGEOUS.
BECAUSE I'M THE THE EXAMPLES ARE
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES I
THINK WHERE IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE.
IS.
WHERE THEY'VE EMPLOYER NOW WAS
ON NOTICE AND HAS BEEN INFORMED
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO STOP?
FURTHER ABUSES IF THEY WOULD
JUST STEP ED THEY DON'T HAVE AN
INCENTIVE TO STEP IN THIS BILL
GIVES MATT INCENTIVE TO STEP AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY APPROPRIATE.
NO OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE HIS --
THE NOTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE THOUGH.
CORD COURTHOUSE DOORS BE
INUNDATED WITH PEOPLE.
IS JUST NOT ACCURATE THIS IS
PROBABLY THE LOOK LEAST REPORTED
BEHAVIOR.
BECAUSE FOR REASONS THAT WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING HERE IN OUR OWN
BUILDING.
VICTIMS FEEL EMBARRASSED THEY
FEEL SHAME THE FEEL WITHOUT ANY --
POWER THEIR DISEMPOWERED TO
RESPOND.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
AGAIN BY THIS LEGISLATION AND IN
SPITE OF ALL THE THE
MACHINATIONS AND ALLEGATIONS OF
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND DOESN'T
DO.
WE WANT EMPLOYERS TO STEP IN AT
THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME I
DIDN'T EVEN PUT IN THERE WHEN AN
EMPLOYER KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN.
THIS IS WHEN THE EMPLOYER KNOWS --
THEY DON'T THINK YES IT'S WHEN
SOMEONE COMES THEM SAYS THIS I
HI AM AM FEELING VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE BY THIS BEHAVIOR.
EMPLOYERS TAKING THOSE STEPS SO
THAT IT DOESN'T BECOME SEVERE
PERVASIVE SUBJECTING THAT
EMPLOYER TO A LAWSUIT.
THAT'S AGAIN THE GOAL HERE IS
NOT GOTCHA THE GOAL IS TO CHANGE
THE BEHAVIOR.
AND TO CHANGE THE CULTURE IN THE
WORKPLACE AND WITHOUT I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHOW.
CHOW AYE CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL GIVE RELY.
HAS FIVE NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE SO
WILL PUT IT ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALRIGHT.
SENATOR PELL ITEM NUMBER TWO S.
B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT IT'S
AND THIS
HAS BILL HAS SUPPORT RECOMMENDED
ON BOTH SIDES.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
THAT'S NICE --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF I
LIKED IT FIRST OF ALL THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THE WHO ESPECIALLY
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS TO MEMBERS ARE IN THE
BILL THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU.
OUR OUR OUR LAW THAT WE PASS AND
TWENTY TWELVE THE HOMEOWNER
BILLS OF RIGHTS WAS SIGNED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN. TWENTY TWELVE
AND IN JANUARY.
OF THIS LAW SUNSET.
OF THIS WILL READ THIS BILL
SIMPLY RESTORES AT LAW
[inaudible]
AND ESTABLISHES THESE
COMMONSENSE.
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT THEY
EXISTED FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS --
IN TERMS A REPORT --
TO THE KEEP YOUR HOME CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM --
RECEIVED.
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS FOR FROM
FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
HOMEOWNERS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ALONE SO --
WE STILL HAVE A MAJOR ISSUE FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
NOT AS BAD AS IT WAS FOR FIVE
YEARS AGO BUT IT'S STILL
[inaudible]
A SUBSTANTIAL.
SUBSTANTIAL FORECLOSURE ISSUES
OF EXISTING CALIFORNIA --
SO WE WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH THIS
BILL IT WORKED --
HELP HOMEOWNERS --
WE CAN'T JUST SIT AND WAIT FOR
THE ANOTHER ANOTHER CRISIS WE
HAVE TO GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE --
LET'S SO LET'S BE PROACTIVE AND
HELP THE VULNERABLE HOMEOWNERS
HOMEOWNERS AND ARCH AND I VOTE
HAVE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU SENATOR FIRST WITNESS
WITH GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON RONALD COLMAN HERE
BEHALF OF CLICK THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT ONE EIGHT AND BANKS
SENATOR BELFOUR'S LEADERSHIP.
IN MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD TO
ESTABLISH THESE KEY PROTECTIONS
HOT CERTAINLY WHETHER WITH THE
DUAL TRACKING PROTECTIONS THE
NOTICE OF DISCLOSURE PEOPLE GOT
OR EVEN NOW WITH THE INSURING A
SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT THESE
ARE VALUABLE PROTECTIONS. TO
GIVE HOMEOWNERS A FIGHTING
CHANCE TO SAVE THEIR HOMES
CALIFORNIA DURING THE FULL CLIP
FORECLOSURE PRICES CRISIS WITH
GROUND ZERO AYE AND WE THOUGHT
THAT WAS STATIONED THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE --
CERTAINLY AFTER THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR HOMES IN
TWENTY TWELVE WE DID SEE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MOVE FORWARD
ESTABLISH THE HOMEOWNERS BILL OF
RIGHTS AND CERTAINLY WE SOLVE
HOME OWNERS GETTING SUPPORT.
CLICK OF THE COALITION MOSTLY
LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDERS THAT DO
A LOT OF WORK AROUND CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUES FOR
CALIFORNIANS LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES DURING THE CRISIS
OUR ATTORNEYS HAD LARGE VOLUMES
OF CASES OF CLIENTS THAT NEVER
HAD ANY REAL OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE
THEIR HOME.
WHILE THEY WERE SEEKING A LOAN
MODIFICATION [inaudible]
FORWARD SERVICES WERE LOSING
DOCUMENTS LEFT AND RIGHT FAMILY
SUFFERED THROUGH A MAZE OF A
PROCESS WITH THOSE SERVICES THEY
WEREN'T NECESSARILY GIVEN
ACCURATE A RELIABLE INFORMATION
OR THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEEDED TO
BE ABLE TO SAVE THEIR HOMES.
ONCE THE HOMEOWNERS BILL OF
RIGHTS WAS PUT IN PLACE ALL OF
THOSE CONCERNS FEAST TO EXIST UP
WE CERTAINLY SAW FAMILIES NOT
FEED THE IMPEDIMENT THAT BASE
ALL WITH THE BEAR SERVICERS UP
PREVIOUSLY.
UP FAMILIES FACING FORECLOSURE
FORECLOSURE CERTAINLY DID THEN
HAVE A FAIR CHANCE TO SAVE THEIR
HOME AND ESSENTIALLY THESE
PROTECTIONS GAVE THEM DUE
PROCESS IF YOU WILL TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THEIR BANKS AND
SERVICERS.
TO ULTIMATELY SAVED THEIR MOST
VALUABLE ASSET FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TO
ESTABLISH THESE IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE HOMEOWNERS
BILL OF RIGHTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
CHAIR MEMBERS WHOSE AND MARTIN
DEL CONSUMERS UNION ALSO IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
REALLY APPRECIATE SENATOR BELLS
LEADERSHIP.
AND ALL THE STAFF AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND VERY STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THOSE ON ON THE SIDE
OF INDUSTRY WHO'VE BEEN WILLING --
TO TO COME TO THE TABLE IN GOOD
FAITH TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PRESERVE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FORECLOSURE PREVENTION
PROTECTIONS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT WERE AT THE TENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT FINANCIAL CRISIS AND NOT
TOO LONG AGO IT WAS A MONTH OR
TWO AGO CONGRESS.
PASSED LEGISLATION TO DEREGULATE
THE BANKING INDUSTRY YET AGAIN --
AND AT THE SAME TIME THE CURRENT
HEAD OF THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU WHICH OVERSEES
MORTGAGE REGULATIONS IS ISSUING
REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION.
BASICALLY EVERY WEEK ARE SEEKING
TO POTENTIALLY WE CAN UNDO A
PREVIOUS REGULATIONS THAT WERE
PUT IN PLACE TO STOP UNNECESSARY
FORECLOSURES AND OTHER KINDS OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS OF THIS IS THE TIME.
I'M IN A IN A TROUBLING FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO KEEP THESE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE A PRESERVE --
HOMEOWNERS RIGHTS TO HAVE
AFFAIRS MORTGAGES WHEN THEY'RE
FALLING BEHIND THAT WE DON'T SEE
ANOTHER FORECLOSURE CRISIS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE'VE ARE
STRONGLY OF SUPPORT THE BILL AN
URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MEDICINE RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
HERE SUPPORT.
TELL JACK SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MCLAUGHLIN --
VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
COURTESY DIDIA CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE OF VERY BACK THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THE CUTTING EDGES BRIEFLY THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AT BIKE
CONSIDERATION TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR IF YOU WOULD.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT --
TO TO ENSURE THESE PROTECTIONS
REMAIN AND HAVING LIVED THROUGH
THE CRISIS OF TEN YEARS AGO.
THERE WAS THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON A REALLY REALLY BAD
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND I THINK THIS IS A PROACTIVE
PIECE LEGISLATION CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT CNN'S HANNITY MIKLOS --
JUST ASTRONOMICAL THINKING.
THANK YOU BUSH'S DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE GABRIEL [inaudible]
GABRIEL I THAT BILLS OUT THANK
YOU SENATOR.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
THINGS ON CALL.
SO I'M GOING TO GO JUST THROUGH
THE LIST.
LIFTING THE CALL FOR ALLOWING
FOLKS TO ADD ON AS WE GO TO A
START WITH CONSENT.
THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT BUT CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER ONE IS ON CALL
THE CURRENT VOTE IS TO DO
NOTHING I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
CERTAINLY CUNNINGHAM.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB SIX NINETY
ONE LARA.
CUNNINGHAM I CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GABRIEL I FABULOUS OUT
[inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER.
CHU WE JUST HEARD THAT'S GOOD
ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS S. B.
EIGHT ONE NINE THAT'S HILL STILL
NEED A MOTION FOR THAT.
SO THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THAT MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
S. B. ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
[inaudible]
EIGHT ONE NINE HILL.
REYES AYE GABRIEL [inaudible]
GABRIEL I THAT BILL AS ADULTS.
I AM NUMBER FOUR IS ON CALL THAT
IS A S. B. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
LARA MIDDLE LIFT THE CALL VOTE
CURRENTLY IS TO DO NOTHING
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GABRIELLA.
THAT BILL IS ADULTS.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS ON CALL THE
VOTE IS THREE TO ONE THIS IS S.
B..
EIGHT TWENTY SIX JACKSON AND
ATKINS I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GABRIEL I THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AYE MEMBER SIX
WAS MOVED TO CONSENT TO THOSE
ARE DEALT WITH I AM NUMBER.
SEVEN IS SB NINE NINETY WIENER
OF SILICON FOR A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION IS THERE
SECONDS.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHOW.
CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
GABRIEL I
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SP. ONE ONE
FIVE FIVE HUESO IS ON CALL THE
CURRENT VOTE IS A FORD NOTHING
I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
NINE IS S. B.. TWELVE FORTY NINE
GALGIANI.
THAT BILL IS OUT BUT WE'RE GOOD
AT ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHOW I CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER.
TEN IS ONCOL CURRENT VOTE IS AT
IS TO TO THAT IS S. B.. TWELVE
EIGHTY FOUR TAX AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS STONE BY STONE
AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GABRIEL I THAT BILL AS ADULTS
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN IS S. B.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED JACKSON.
THAT BILLS ARE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF A LIFT THE
CALL [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE KALRA [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAIN CHINA.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S. B.
THIRTEEN A FIVE GLAZER I NEED A
MOTION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT IT MOTIONS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES
[inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GABRIEL I THAT BILL IS OUT --
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SP THIRTEEN
NINETY SEVEN HELLO.
I NEED A MOTION.
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHOW.
CHOW I CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GABRIEL I THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B. FORTINO TO
LARA.
IS ON CALL THE VOTE IS TO DO
NOTHING I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
THEY WERE [inaudible]
GABRIEL I THAT BILL IS OUT.
WERE MISSING MISTER KALRA ON A
NUMBER OF BILLS.
OKAY LET'S GO ALRIGHT LET'S GO
THROUGH THIS AGAIN.
SO WILL START AT THE TOP WITH
CONSENT [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE KALRA.
ALRIGHT SIR ITEM NUMBER ONE S.
B. SIX NINETY ONE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHIU.
CHIU AYE KALRA MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN I ITEM NUMBER TWO S.
B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT BELL
[inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE KALRA [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN I S. B. EIGHT ONE
NINE HILL [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN I ITEM NUMBER FOUR
IS S. B. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR LARA
[inaudible]
KALRA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHINA.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY SIX THAT EVERYBODY
ON FIVE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN OKAY ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. B..
WE GOT EVERYBODY ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible] TEN ELEVEN OKAY
[inaudible]
TWELVE HARM.
SO WE'RE MISSING LIZ REYES ON
OKAY I'VE NEVER.
THIRTEEN OKAY AND FOURTEEN OKAY
WILL WILL GIVE MISTER KALRA FEW
MINUTES [inaudible]
TO JOIN US
.
RIGHT.
YEAH FOR CONSENT.
OKAY SO CONSENT.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE.
WE NEED AMOUNT I DON'T.
ITEM ONE S. B. SIX NINETY ONE
LARA KALRA AYE KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT BELL KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
I DON'T NEVER THREE SB EIGHT ONE
NINE HAVE.
KALRA.
I'M THREE EIGHT ONE NINE HELP
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
I REMEMBER FOUR S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR LARA KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
I REMEMBER SEVEN S. B. NINE
NINETY WIENER KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SP ONE ONE
FIVE FIVE HUESO [inaudible]
KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN S. B.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED JACKSON KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
I REMEMBER TWELVE SP THIRTEEN OH
FIVE GLAZER KALRA.
CALLER I RAISED.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SP THIRTEEN
NINETY SEVEN HELL KALRA.
KALRA I'VE RAISED.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B.
FORTINO TO LARA KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
NO JUST WE WE'RE MISSING OR TWO
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S. B.
THIRTEEN OH FIVE GLAZER REYES.
BY REYES AYE.
AND ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN HILL.
REYES AYE REYES AYE.
RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR THE DAY WE ARE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH